ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FOR MORE QUESTING THAT THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
COME TO ROOMFOUR FOUR SEVEN WE
ARE IN A DIFFERENT ROOM TODAY
FOUR FOUR SEVEN. TODAY'S HEARING
IS TAKING PLACE AGAIN IN ROOM
FOUR FOUR SEVEN THE PANELISTS
LISTED ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING VIRTUALLY USING ONLINE
REMOTE PARTICIPATION TECHNOLOGY.
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THIS
HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND ON THE PHONE. THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT SHOULD BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THIS HEARING
ONLINE. THE PHONE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE NINE. AND
A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU
WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE HEARING PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS OF
FOUR. AT ASM DOT C. A. DOT G. O.
V. E. R. WE WILL DO A ROLL CALL. ONE MORE MEMBERS HAVE. THAT'S
AYE OF MYSELF COME TO THE- BUT
IT'S A FOR COMMITTEE AND ROOM
FOUR FOUR SEVEN BUT FOR NOW WE
WILL GET STARTED WE HAVE A LOT
OF ISSUES ON THE AGENDA TODAY-
WE WILL START WITH ISSUE ONE.
UPDATE ON DCC AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF BUDGET CHANGE AND DEPARTMENT-
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS FOR
FIRST ITEM WILL RECEIVE AN
UPDATE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. DISCUSSED TWO
OF THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET LET'S BEGIN IS- NICOLE
ELLIOTT. ON THE ZOOM READY TO
GO. ARE A GOOD AFTERNOON YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
TASTIC HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS LET ME GET
BEGAN BY THANKING THIS COMMITTEE
AND STAFF FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
DEPARTMENTS MY NAME IS NICOLE
ELLIOTT HAD THIS DISTINCT HONOR
OF SERVING AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE NEWLY FORMED DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. GIVE YOU A
QUICK UPDATE ON THE DEPARTMENT
AS YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT WAS
ESTABLISHED JULY TWELFTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
SIGNATURE ON AB ONE FORTY ONE.
THE DEPARTMENT REPRESENTS THE
CONSOLIDATION OF THREE SEPARATE
CANNABIS PROGRAMS THAT RESIDED
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE. OUR VISION
AS A DEPARTMENT IS TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A SAFE
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE
CANNABIS MARKET THAT SERVES AS
AN EXAMPLE FOR THE WORLD. IT'S
BEEN INCREDIBLE TO SEE WHAT A
CONSOLIDATED DEPARTMENT CAN DO
IN SUCH A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME A
FEW EXAMPLES OF THE MORE
EXPEDITED NATURE OF OUR WORK
INCLUDES THE SWIFT ESTABLISHMENT
OF A LEADERSHIP TEAM TO
STABILIZE THE TRANSITION. AND
AGGRESSIVE RECRUITING EFFORTS TO
FILL OUR VACANCIES THE
CONSOLIDATION OF THREE SETS OF
REGULATIONS AND TO ONE THE
LOCKET DISTRIBUTION OF A ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR LOCAL
GRANT PROGRAMS THE SEVENTEEN
JURISDICTIONS. TO SUPPORT THE
TRANSITION OF PROVISIONAL
LICENSES TO ANNUAL LICENCES BY
AMONG A VARIETY OF THINGS
FUNDING THE COMPLETION OF LOCAL
AND ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS. I AM
PROUD OF THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
HEADWAY WE HAVE MADE YET I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THERE IS MORE WORK TO
BE DONE TO CONTINUE SUPPORTING
THE MARKET WE DESIRE TO HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WITH THIS IN MIND
THE DEPARTMENTS CURRENTLY
FOCUSING ITS ATTENTION ON
ADDRESSING KEY UPCOMING MANDATES
AND ENFORCEMENT AND OPERATIONAL
NEEDS. OF NOTE OPERATIONALLY AND
RELATED TO LICENSING CURRENTLY A
LITTLE OVER 70% OF OUR LICENSEE
POPULATION HOLDS A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE WE ANTICIPATE THIS
NUMBER TO INCREASE SUBSTANTIALLY
WITH THE UPCOMING DEADLINE TO
ISSUE PROVISIONAL. LICENSES TO
NON EQUITY ACT LOOK. SO ASISTIR
OF THE DEPARTMENT IS ENHANCING
ITS FOCUS ON PROCESSING
THOUSANDS OF APPLICATIONS
ELIGIBLE FOR PROVISIONAL
LICENSURE. IN THE AREA OF
ENFORCEMENT WE ARE FOCUSING ON
HIRING STRATEGIC PLAN
DEVELOPMENT AND ENHANCED
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR STATE
LOCAL AND FEDERAL PARTNERS. ARE
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION IS TASKED
WITH CONDUCTING CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS OF ILLEGAL
OPERATIONS AND THEY WORK CLOSELY
WITH LOCAL SHERIFFS POLICE STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WHERE APPROPRIATE THIS
TEAM ALSO WORKS WITH OUR
COMPLIANCE DIVISION TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT WE CALL GREAT
MARKET OPERATIONS OPERATIONS WHO
WORK IN BOTH THE LEGAL AND
ILLEGAL MARKETS. THIS JOINT
EFFORT ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT TO
MORE SWIFTLY ADDRESSED THIS GRAY
MARKET ACTIVITY ADMINISTRATIVELY
AS WELL AS CRIMINALLY. OVER THE
LAST SEVEN MONTHS WE'VE FOCUSED
ON INCREASING HIRES IN THIS
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION AND THROUGH
THIS FOCUS FOCUS EFFORTS WE'VE
CUT OUR ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
VACANCY RATE IN HALF. ALONGSIDE
THESE PERSONAL EFFORTS THE
DIVISION HAS ALSO CONDUCTED
EIGHTY FOUR SEARCH WARRANT
OPERATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
TARGETING ILLEGAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATION OPERATIONS
DISTRIBUTION MANUFACTURING AND
RETAIL OPERATIONS. OUR
COMPLIANCE DIVISION COMPRISED OF
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE NON
SWORN STAFF OVERSEES THE
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE OF OUR
LICENSED OPERATORS THEY DO THIS
THROUGH CONDUCTING ROUTINE
INSPECTIONS AND THROUGH ISSUANCE
OF CITATIONS AND ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIONS TO LICENSED AND
UNLICENSED OPERATORS. SINCE THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT
THE COMPLIANCE DIVISION HAS
PERFORMED OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
INSPECTIONS ISSUED THIRTEEN
LICENSING ACTIONS FURTHERMORE
THIS DIVISION HAS A DEDICATED
TEAM OF INDIVIDUALS THAT WORKS
IN CONJUNCTION IN CONJUNCTION
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. TO SUPPORT ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS THEY PARTICIPATE IN
INVESTIGATIONS OF ILLEGAL
CULTIVATION OPERATIONS THAT ARE
DIRECTLY NEGATIVELY IMPACTING
THE ENVIRONMENT. THE TEAM HAS
PARTICIPATED IN NINETY EIGHT
INVESTIGATION ACTIONS LED BY
THESE AGENCIES AND IS PURSUING
THIRTY FOUR ADMINISTRATIVE
CITATIONS. WE CONTINUE TO
AGGRESSIVELY HIRE STAFF ACROSS
THESE DIVISIONS AS WELL AS
OTHERS WHILE REALIGNING OUR
BUSINESS OPERATIONS TO MEET THE
DEMANDS OF THE IMMENSE AMOUNT OF
WORK AHEAD OF US. AS WE CONTINUE
THIS WORK WE KEEP THERE ARE AYE
ON THE ULTIMATE FUTURE STATE FOR
ILLEGAL CANNABIS A SAFE DISTANCE
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE MARKET
THAT IS SUPPORTED BY A SMART
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK. THAT
PRESERVES THE ENVIRONMENT
SUPPORTS CONSUMER SAFETY AND
SUSTAINS BUSINESSES THAT WANT TO
DO THE SAME WHICH BRINGS ME TO
THE BUDGET PROPOSALS. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PUT FORTH. THAT
BEGINS TO SET A STRONGER
FOUNDATION FOR THIS FUTURE STATE
PROPOSALS THAT BUILD ON OUR
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THE CANNABIS
BUSINESS AND LICENSING PROCESS
HE'S DEVELOP POLICY UTILIZING
ROBUST STATUS DATA. AND HAVE A
MORE EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION
WITH THE PUBLIC AND CANNABIS
CONSUMERS. OUR FIRST PROPOSAL IS
A REQUEST FOR THIRTEEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION TO FIND THREE
DISTINCT PROJECTS FIRST
BEGINNING WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A UNIFIED LICENSING SYSTEM.
THIS INCLUDES PROJECT MANAGEMENT
SERVICES TO MAP BUSINESS NEEDS
MIGRATE EXISTING LICENSING DATA
AND DEVELOP AN ACQUISITION PLAN
FOR ONE SINGLE LICENSING SYSTEM
VERSUS THE THREE WE CURRENTLY
USE. THE SECOND IS A CONSUMER
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN THAT WILL
PROVIDE CONSUMERS BOTH
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
TOURISTS BASIC INFORMATION
NEEDED TO PURCHASE CANNABIS
THROUGH THE LEGAL REGULATED
MARKET. AND TO DETER USE OF
UNTESTED UNSAFE PRODUCT OBTAINED
FROM UNLICENSED SOURCES IT WILL
ALSO PROVIDE CONSUMERS WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT RESPONSIBLE
USE AND CONSUMPTION. AND LASTLY
ACQUIRING SOFTWARE AND
TECHNOLOGY EXPERTS WHO CAN HELP
THE DEPARTMENT AGGREGATE STORE
AND CLEAN LICENSING AND
COMPLIANCE DATA. INTERNALLY WILL
BE BETTER SITUATED AS A
DEPARTMENT TO UTILIZE THIS DATA
INTERNALLY TO SUPPORT OUR
OPERATIONS AND BEGIN TO SHARE
SOME OF THIS DATA EXTERNALLY TO
SUPPORT BUSINESSES ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS AND OTHER POLICY
RELATED EFFORTS. THE SECOND
REQUEST SUBMITTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT IS FOR ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY TO
CONDUCT SAMPLE TESTING SERVICES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF LAST YEAR'S
ASSEMBLYBILL FORTY FIVE WITHOUT
I WILL STOP HERE TO SEE IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. BEFORE WE
TAKE UP THE ISSUE OF TAX REFORM
. THANK YOU MISS ELLIOT I
ACTUALLY WANT TO GO BACK TO-
ENFORCEMENT INVESTMENTS. YOU
MENTIONED THE DEPARTMENT
EFFICIENT WILDLIFE AND I'M JUST
CURIOUS AS TO THE ENTIRE TO THE
ENTIRE. A NUMBER ON YOUR TEAM.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO ENFORCEMENT-
CAN YOU PLEASE CLARIFY WHAT YOU
HAVE ON STAFF WHAT YOU MAY
POTENTIALLY NEED. A RESOURCES
PARTNERSHIPS WHAT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
NEED TO IMPROVE ITS ENFORCEMENT
OPERATIONS AND WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE ON THE GROUND
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO- EBS
ILLICIT AND ILLEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET. ABSOLUTELY MOST OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS FUNDED FOR- IT
WITHIN THE ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
EIGHTY SEVEN POSITIONS I SEVENTY
SEVEN OF WHICH ARE SWORN AND TEN
OF WHICH ARE ADMINISTRATIVE AS I
MENTIONED IN THE DEPARTMENTS
FOCUSED AS SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS
ON REDUCING THE VACANCY RATE
THAT WAS 49% A DEPARTMENT ACT
CREATION AYE SO NOW WE CURRENTLY
HAVE FIFTY EIGHT SWORN POSITIONS
FILLED WITH NINE ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS FILLED AS WELL AND
AREN'T AND ARE AT ROBUST HIRING
EFFORTS CONTINUE IN THAT VEIN-
WITH THAT SAID WE ARE. CURRENTLY
ASSESSING ALL THE RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE AS YOU KNOW WE ARE STILL
WORKING TO I USE ALL OF THOSE
EXISTING RESOURCES THROUGH
THINGS LIKE EXPANDING OUR HIRING
HI HOWEVER IF WE FEEL LIKE WE
WILL NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
WE WILL DEFINITELY BE COMING
BACK TO YOU OF A FOR THE TIME
BEING WE ARE DEVELOPING ACT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO DEVELOP OUR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS AS WELL AS OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS- STRENGTHEN THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND WORK MORE
CLOSELY. WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS
AS FAR. THANK YOU FOR THE I- I
REPRESENT THE OF LOS ANGELES AND
ALSO UNINCORPORATED EAST LOS
ANGELES. THE CITY OF LA HAS
TAKEN REALLY GREAT MEASURES TO.
CURB AND STOP JUST POP UP.
ILLEGAL CANNABIS OPERATIONS BUT
THE COUNTY UNINCORPORATED EAST
LOS ANGELES WHICH IS OPERATED BY
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME- MEASURES
THAT THE CITY HAS HAD SO WE SEE
A VERY. INEQUITABLE WAY IN WHICH
SOME COMMUNITIES HAVE- SOME
ILLEGAL POP MORE ILLEGAL POP UPS
THAN MOST. SO I JUST WANNA PUT
THAT ON YOUR RADAR IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE SEE ON THE GROUND IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU MAY NEED AN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. TO ENSURE
THAT THAT'S NOT- SOMETHING
THAT'S PERVASIVE ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU CHAIR AND I'LL
JUST NOTE- WE DO HAVE AN
INFORMAL PARTNERSHIP WITH LA
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
REGULATION SO WE CAN LEARN FROM
THE ENFORCEMENT. WORK THAT THEY
DO AS WELL AND FIND THAT FOR
WORK OUTSIDE OF- THE MARKET AND
WHICH DATE REGULATE- SO THANK
YOU AND NOTED OKAY THANK YOU MAY
BE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN CHAT
OFF YOU KNOW JUST N PARTICULAR.
CAN WE HAVE THE MEMBERS OF YOUR
TEAM AT PRESENT THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS. IF YOU ARE RETURNING
REFERRING TO THE THREE ITEMS
YEAH IS THAT WE HAVE. OKAY I'M
HAPPY TO ASH TO TURN IT OVER TO
MY CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR RUSSIA
SELAMA FOR MORE DETAILS RELATED
TO THOSE PROPOSALS I DID
HIGHLIGHT BRIEFLY ALL THREE SO
IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THEIR SHE'S AVAILABLE
FOR THOSE. IF WE CAN BRIEFLY
REVIEW THOSE- WHEN YOUR DEPUTY
YOUR CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR THAT
BE GREAT AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
RUSSIA'S SELAMA SERVING AS THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL.
I'M THERE ARE THREE ITEMS ON THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL PUT FORTH
I'M I ITS FIRST. I THE BEGINNING
OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF A UNIFIED
LICENSING SYSTEM. THIS INCLUDES
PROJECT MANAGEMENT SERVICES. TO
MAP THE BUSINESS NEEDS MIGRATE
EXISTING LICENSING DATA. AND
DEVELOP ACQUISITION PLAN FOR ONE
SINGLE LICENSING SYSTEM. THE
SECOND ITEM IS EIGHT CONSUMER
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. THAT WILL
PROVIDE CONSUMERS BOTH
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AS WELL AS
TOURISTS. BASIC INFORMATION
NEEDED TO PURCHASE. LEGAL
CANNABIS REGULATED MARKET AND
INTERVIEWS OF UNTESTED UNSAFE
PRODUCT OBTAINED FROM UNLESS
SOURCES. IT WILL ALSO PROVIDE
THINGS YOU WITH AN ABOUT. USE
AND IN SOME OF CAN'T. OUR LAST
ITEM IS A FIRE SOME INTO EXPERTS
WHO CAN HELP THE DEPARTMENT IN
AGGREGATING STORING AND CLEANING
LICENSING DATA AND COMPLIANCE
DATA. THIS WILL ALLOW US TO
UTILIZE THIS DATA BOTH
INTERNALLY TO SUPPORT OUR
OPERATIONS AND BEGIN TO SHARE
SOME OF THIS DATA EXTERNALLY TO
SUPPORT THIS BUSINESSES ACADEMIC
RESEARCH AT AND OTHER POLICY
RELATED EFFORTS. I'M OUR SECOND
- BUDGET PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD IT
IS FOR REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY
TO CONDUCT SAMPLE TESTING
SERVICES FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF AB FORTY FIVE
. AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS FROM. THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU ONE
QUESTION I JUST ONLY FOR ME
BEFORE I TURN IT OVER BUT FIRST
WE'RE GOING TO DO- ROLL CALL
PLEASE MR SECRETARY WE CONTROL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREA PRESIDENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
RESIDENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
HERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER NIGERIAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEEKS. THANK YOU
I HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL DETAIL IF
YOU IF I COULD I WOULD LIKE SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THE
PROPOSED AWARENESS CAMPAIGN WHAT
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROLS PROJECTED TARGET
AUDIENCE AND WITH THE CAMPAIGN
HAVE SPECIAL A SPECIFIC REGIONAL
FOCUS WILL THE CAMPAIGN ALSO
HAVE. A MULTI LINGUAL COMPONENT. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE. THAT SPOT
ASSEMBLY WOMAN OUR CHAIR I. IT'S
FAR AS THE CAMPAIGN ITSELF THE
FIRST PART OF THE CAMPAIGN
WOULD- INCLUDE IS PROPOSED TO
INCLUDE A RESEARCH AND
ASSESSMENT. I TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN MEET THE TARGET AUDIENCE
WICH IS ALL CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS AS WELL AS TOURISTS. I
SO IT WITH THAT IN MIND AND
KNOWING THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF REGIONAL VARIATIONS WELL AS A
VARIETY OF LANGUAGES ARE SPOKEN
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
SEE. I DON AS PART OF THAT
ASSESSMENT. AND IT TURNED IT
OVER TO MEMBERS OF THE DIS
MISTER COOPER. THANK YOU MEASURE
JUST FOLLOWING UP ON THAT FOR
THAT MONEY FOR THE RICHER
RESEARCH ASSESSMENT I MEAN. IT'S
GOING TO BE ONGOING PROGRAM OR
JUST A ONE TIME THING OR HOW
THAT WORK. THEIR THEIR REQUEST
FOR THE CAMPAIGN IS FOR ONE TIME
PROJECTS IT. SO WHAT IS EXPECTED
OF SPENDING SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ON A CONSUMER AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. SO ANY CHANCE OF THAT
CAMPAIGN- HAS MULTIPLE FACETS-
SOME OF THE KEY ONES ARE TO-
EDUCATE CONSUMERS ON HOW TO
IDENTIFY. OUR LEGAL RETAIL
STORES DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
ILLEGAL AND LEGAL STORES I'M I
UNDERSTAND HOW TO LOOK AT
PRODUCTS AND IDENTIFY THAT THEY
ARE TESTED AS WELL AS PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION IN MULTIPLE.
LANGUAGES AND- ENSURING THAT
CONSUMERS KNOW HOW TO- KEEP
THEIR PRODUCTS IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT THAT IS NOT
ACCESSIBLE I'M TO CHILDREN. SO
THE TOBACCO HAS A HUGE ILLEGAL
MARKET WE SEE OF WHAT THE
NUMBERS ARE BALLISTICS IT'S
EXTRAORDINARY THAT. COMES IN- TO
CALIFORNIA. IF PEOPLE STILL BUY
IN TOBACCO SAY I'M TRYING TO GET
THE- WHAT DIFFERENCE WILL IT
MAKE HERE. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AS FAR AS
THE DIFFERENCE THAT IT MAKES
HERE TOBACCO AT HAS BEEN AROUND
FOR SOME TIME AND DESPITE THOSE
CONSUMER PATTERNS WHAT WE'RE
SPEAKING TO IT IS CONSUMER
PATTERNS CONSUMPTION PATTERNS
RELATED TO CANNABIS. WHICH IS A
PRETTY NEW LEGAL MARKET
INCLUDING THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
MARKET AYE SO WE WANT TO DO OUR
PART AS A STATE REGULATING
ENTITY TO ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE SO THAT THEY
ARE MAKING EDUCATED. PURCHASING
I CHOICES AS WELL AS CONSUMPTION
CHOICES. SO WHAT IS THE PART IN
DOING A TO GO AFTER SHUT DOWN
ILLEGAL RETAIL STORES. AND THE
MORE RESOURCES TO SHUT DOWN
THOSE ILLEGAL RETAILERS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- AS I
INDICATED IN MY COMMENTS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS- TAKEN SOME STEPS
OVER THE LAST SEVEN MONTHS- TO
ISSUE WARRANTS OR SUPPORT. OUR
PARTNERS WHETHER THAT BE ON THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT SIDE STATE
LINE OR STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SIDE. I RELATED TO ILLICIT OR
ILLEGAL CANNABIS OPERATIONS
INCLUDING RETAIL THOSE EFFORTS
WILL CONTINUE. DOES THAT MAKE
MORE SENSE TO IDENTIFY THE
ILLEGAL RETAIL STORES AND SHUT
HIM DOWN. INTO THE SPENDING SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONVINCE
CONSUMERS NOT TO BUY FROM THESE
ILLEGAL OUTLETS. AS I'VE SAID
PREVIOUSLY I THINK THAT THIS IS
A MULTI FACETED EFFORTS THEY ARE
NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE BOTH ARE
REQUIRED. BUT I THINK IT IS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT WHEN
THIS FIRST STARTED OFF A COUPLE
YEARS AGO- WITH THE WITH THE
COVETED. WE HAD A LOT OF ILLEGAL
DEATH WITH VAPING IT WAS
MARIJUANA VAPING FROM BLACK
MARKET SO WE HAD AND- AS FAR AS
I'M TOLD THAT STILL GOING ON.
JUST LIKE THE ISSUES WITH THE-
FIT IN ALL ITS JUST COVERT IS
SUCKED ALL THE AIR OUT OF THE
SPACE. SO YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
THAT MUCH THOSE DEATHS ARE UP-
UNTIL WE STILL HAVE GUESTS FROM
THE BLACK MARKET- VAPING. SO BUT
SIX MORE DOLLARS GO A LOT
FURTHER AND BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
LOT OF ALICE OUT THERE SELLING
RIGHT NOW. IN SHOWING THOSE
OUTLETS DOWN. I THINK WE REQUIRE
BOTH OF THOSE EFFORTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- WITH A VALLEY THERE.
WERE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER F
THOSE PRODUCTS THAT WERE
PURCHASED OFF OF THE ILLEGAL
MARKET HOWEVER WE DID SEAT
CONSUMER PATTERNS CHANGE- DURING
A VALLEY BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A
PUBLIC- RIGHTS CAMPAIGN QUITE
FRANKLY I RELATED TO THE HARM
THAT THOSE PRODUCTS WERE CAUSING
FOR CONSUMERS. SO ENSURING THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT PRODUCTS
ARE LEGAL IS IMPORTANT SO THAT
THEIR PURCHASING THOSE PRODUCTS-
LEGALLY AND CONSUMING PRODUCTS
THAT HAVE BEEN TESTED WHILE ALSO
CAN CURRENTLY GOING ON- AND
ENFORCING AGAINST THE RETAIL
OPERATIONS IN THE MANUFACTURING
OPERATIONS THAT ARE PRODUCING.
THERE'S A LEGAL PRODUCTS
INCLUDING BIG CARTRIDGES THAT
ARE HARMFUL TO CONSUMERS. WILL
THAT 506030% A MARIJUANA GROWING
CALIFORNIA'S GONNA LEAVE ILLEGAL
MARKET AS FAR AS RETAIL WHAT DO
YOU NUMBERS. ON ILLEGAL RETAIL
SHOPS WHAT PERCENTAGE. IT IS A
GOOD QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
NUMBER OF THE LEGAL RETAIL
LOCATIONS BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
THE STATE DOES NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO LEGAL RETAIL BECAUSE THE
JURISDICTIONS HAVE. PROVIDE ARE
PROHIBITED OP PATHWAYS TO
REGULATED RETAIL FOR BUSINESSES
IN THEIR JURISDICTIONS SO THAT
IS SOMETHING WE ARE ALSO WORKING
ON A SUPPORTING SUPPORTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. I AM CREATING
PATHWAYS FOR LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE LEGAL
PRODUCTS TO CONSUMERS WITHOUT
PART OF PROP SIXTY FOUR NICHOLS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHATEVER SAY
SO. WHEN THEY HAD CANNABIS IN
THEIR JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT. SO
IT IS STILL GOES BACK YOU CAN
SPEND MONEY ON A PROBLEM. AND
YET YOU DON'T KNOW THE SCOPE OF
THE PROBLEM. SO YOU CAN'T TELL
ME USING US BEEN A FREE LEGAL
RETAIL STORES. BUT YET YOU HAVE
NO IDEA. HOW MANY ILLEGAL
RESTORE RETAIL STORES ARE ARE SO
FOR ME THAT IS DOESN'T JIVE. YOU
GOT TO HAVE SOME IDEA WHAT
YOU'RE DEALING WITH. THANK YOU
FOR THAT THANK YOU FOR THAT
STATEMENT I THINK AS IT RELATES
TO SPECIFIC JURISDICTIONS. I WE
DO HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH WHEN IT COMES TO
ILLEGAL I RETAIL OUTLETS
STATEWIDE. I THAT'S A FLUID
THAT'S A LIVING SORT OF-
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE THOSE POP UP
AND DISAPPEAR. I SO WE CONTINUE
TO ASSESS RETAIL OUTLETS IT DOES
CONTINUE TO BE PART OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT STRATEGY- BUT
CONCURRENT TO THAT WE ALSO THINK
IT'S- JUST EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE CONSUMERS KNOW WHAT IS
THE EAGLE AND WHAT IT'S NOT. BUT
I STILL WANT TO PIN YOU DOWN
THIS YOU HAVE
OR NOT THEY'RE STILL THERE ARE
SOME POINTS SO I'M JUST TRYING
TO. DRILL DOWN DEEPER ON WHAT IS
THAT UNIVERSE. IS A THOUSAND IS
FIVE THOUSAND IS A COUPLE
HUNDRED I MEAN YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SOME IDEA. FOR THE OTHERWISE OU
TIME YOU HAVE ZERO IDEA
WHATSOEVER. SO HOW ARE YOU IT
WILL BE A METRIC WILL YOUR
MATTRESS MEASURING THAT PAUL. IF
YOU CAN IDENTIFY HOW MANY
ILLEGAL RETAIL OUTLETS THERE ARE
. HOW WELL WE WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS INCLUDING STATE
PARTNERS AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO IDENTIFY THOSE
ILLEGAL RETAIL LOCATIONS IN
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE-
I'M ADDS THAT IS AN ONGOING
EFFORT. BUT IT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR SOME TIME SO I WOULD THINK
THEM. WE TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS NOW
WITH THIS ISSUE. SO I THINK AT
SOME POINT. I'M NOT TRYING TO
BELABOR THE POINT. YOU HAVE SOME
NUMBERS SOMEHOW SOME WAY. AND I
SPENT TEN YEARS NARCOTICS
WORKING NARCOTICS I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THIS. FULL EXIT WE
GOTTA GET OUR ARMS AROUND THE
PROBLEM SO. I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM SPENDING MONEY ON ITEMS
BUT YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHAT THE
WHAT THE ISSUE IS AND YOU DON'T
OTHER THAN TELLING US. IT'S
ILLEGAL RETAIL STORES WITH THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM IS YOU HAVE
NO IDEA. THAT'S THAT'S WHY I'M
HERE YOU SEE RIGHT NOW. SO WHAT
I'M SAYING IS THAT THERE WHAT
WELL HAVING WORKED IN NARCOTICS
I THINK YOU KNOW QUITE WELL THAT
IN ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS OFTEN
RETAIL OPERATIONS TO RECEIVE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AND THEN POP
BACK UP SO LIKE I SAID IT IS A
LIVING POPULATION OF THE LEGAL
RETAILERS THAT IS FLUID IT
CONTINUES TO EBB AND FLOW- BUT
WE WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS OUR
STATE PARTNERS INCLUDING CD TFA
TO IDENTIFY. I ILLEGAL RETAIL
OUTLETS AND ADDRESS THOSE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT- I ANTICIPATE THIS
WILL BE A LONG EFFORT NOT
BECAUSE THE TRANSITION OF A VERY
OLD VERY LARGE DEEPLY ENTRENCHED
MARKET IS GOING TO TAKE TIME.
I'M AS THE POPULATION OF THE
LEGAL RETAIL WILL BE A PART OF
THAT EFFORT AND AN ONGOING BASIS
INCLUDING IDENTIFYING WHERE
THOSE ILLEGAL OPERATIONS ARE AS
THEY POP UP AND AS THEY
DISAPPEAR. BUT STILL EVEN HAVING
NUMBERS TO POP UP ON THE PUBLIC
NUMBERS YOU KNOW WHAT THE
NUMBERS ARE FOR THE POP UPS.
BECAUSE BE A POP OF TO MOVE FROM
ONE LOCATION OTHER BUT HOW MANY
PLACES MEN SHOT DOWN HOW MANY
WORDS I MEAN GIVE ME SOME NUMBER
BECAUSE OTHERWISE. IT IT REALLY
IS IT'S FRUSTRATING FOR YOU
ASKING FOR THE MONEY AND YOU
HAVE NO IDEA THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM THEIR POP UPS. YOU CAN'T
PIN THAT DOWN. AND THERE SHOULD
BE SOME WAY THROUGH SEARCH
WARRANTS THROUGH INVESTIGATIONS.
AND MOST AS INVESTIGATIONS ARE
NOT DONE BY THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. THEIR DOUBLE
YOUR LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS
AND SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS.
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME WAY TO
CAPTURE THESE NUMBERS. IN WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IF YOU'RE WORKING
WITH AND YOU HAVE A GOOD IDEA.
SO IT IS STILL COMES BACK FROM
THE MIDDLE THE- THAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THIS MONEY. BUT YOU
CAN'T QUANTIFY THE PROBLEM WE
GOT A PROBLEM WE'LL HAVE BIGGER
PROBLEM IS. IT I DON'T. ACCEPT
THAT POP UP EVERYTHING IS NOT A
POP UP. USED TO BRICK AND MORTAR
PLACES THAT STAY IN BUSINESS FOR
A LONG TIME. SEOUL IS POP UPS
20% A PROBLEM 40% A PROBLEM. YOU
CAN EVEN TELL ME THAT. WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
THAT SINCE DEPARTMENT'S CREATION
WE HAVE ISSUED OR SUPPORTED
EIGHTY FOUR SEARCH WARRANTS
TWENTY FOUR OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
ON RETAIL SINCE. THIS INST
ESTABLISHMENT OF A LEGAL
COMMERCIAL MARKET AND THERE HAS
BEEN A HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
SEARCH WARRANTS ON ILLEGAL
RETAIL THAT. THAT TELLS ME
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL BECAUSE YOU CAN
GET A LOCAL JURISDICTION EVEN
HERE SACRAMENTO WHERE IS THE IS
THE FIFTH LARGEST COUNTY AND
THEY DO THAT RESEARCH ONCE IN
ONE COUNTY SO IF THAT'S THE MOST
NOT YOU'VE DONE STATEWIDE. THAT
IS ABYSMAL. EMPIRE THE PROBLEM
IS THERE IS NO ENFORCEMENT FOR
THE FOR THE ILLEGAL MARKET
WHATSOEVER. THERE IS ZERO FOR
SMITH IT'S ALL BEEN ABOUT.
GETTING LICENSES AND GETTING
PEOPLE UP AND RUNNING AND WE
KNOW THE BLACK MARKET IS A BIG
PROBLEM IS NEVER BEEN TACKLED SO
FOR THOSE NUMBER OF WARRANTS
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT. THOSE ARE
MINUSCULE THAT IS ABYSMAL TO DO
THAT SO I'M NOT GONNA BELIEVE
THE POINT BUT I'M DONE BUT- YOU
GUYS HAVE TO HAVE BETTER NUMBERS
JUST A TO GIVE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR YOU GUYS TO GO
OFTEN AND TRY THIS IT JUST
DOESN'T SIT WELL WITH ME. WELL I
JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE I'M
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK
OF OUR SWORN STAFF- ON THEIR
WARRANT ISSUANCE AND THAT- THE
FOCUS ON. RETAIL WILL CONTINUE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOWEVER WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO DO A
CONCURRENT WITH THAT FOCUS.
ADDITIONAL THINGS LIKE
SUPPORTING. PATHWAYS TO
LICENSURE AS WELL AS CONSUMER
EDUCATION OFFICE HE SPOKE ABOUT
HER SUPPORT STAFF SALARIES FOR
STAFF DO YOU ACTUALLY HAVE. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE. FIFTY EIGHT
SMART IN THE STATE OF FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE WITH FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES THAT IS ONE PERSON FOR
COUNTY SO THE MAJORITY THIS WORK
IS BEING DONE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THE NOT THE STATE LEVEL AND
THAT'S WHERE THE MAJORITY ARE
EXPERTISE LIES WITH THOSE LOCAL
INVESTIGATORS NOT AT THE STATE
LEVEL. AND I THINK WE CAN CARE
WITH YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH
IS WHY THE MAJORITY OF OUR
WARRANTS ARE H. OURS ARE DONE IN
SUPPORT OF LOCAL EFFORTS. MISTER
COOPER. THANK YOU YORK- LACKING
. YEAH CERTAINLY I- I SHARE THE
FROM THE FRONT- THE WAS X. AND
THE LACK OF APPETITE ON THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE- CERTAINLY
THERE. WE TRULY KNOW THAT THE
ILLICIT MARKET THERE'S CLEARLY
OVERPOWERING THE LEGITIMATE
MARKET AND I SEE THAT THERE ARE
SOME EFFORTS HERE TO TRY TO.
CORRECT THAT TO SOME DEGREE BUT-
THAT THE ENFORCEMENT ASPECT
ESPECIALLY IN THE DISTRICT I
LOVE. NOT SO MUCH IN THE RETAIL
SPACE BUT AND THE- THE GROW. THE
ACT ILICIC GROWS THAT WE HAVE
OUT IN THE DESERT ARE ALARMING.
AND- WAY OVERPOWERING. AND IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THERE'S MUCH
OF AN APPETITE TO REALLY ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM. AND I THINK THAT-
THAT'S A VERY CRITICAL ASPECT.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT- YOUR
DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE INTEREST
IN TRYING TO PARTNER WITH WITH
THE EFFORTS TO TRY TO CURB. AND
TO ELIMINATE THAT PARTICULAR
ASPECT OF THE CANNABIS MARKET IT
TRULY IS A HEARTBREAK TO KNOW
THAT- THERE ARE PLENTY WHO ARE
TRYING TO FOLLOW BY THE RULES
AND PLAY BY THE RULES AND THEY-
THEY EXPEND A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY TO TRY TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE AND- THE DISTINCTION
EVEN AT THE RETAIL LEVEL AS
BROUGHT UP BY MY COLLEAGUE. IS
ALSO VERY- DISARMING. AND I
THINK YOU BRING UP A GOOD POINT
THOUGH THAT THE CONSUMER OFTEN.
HAS A HARD TIME DISCRIMINATING.
UPSIDE A PRICE- BECAUSE THE
PRICE ADVANTAGE IN THE ILLICIT
MARKET AS YOU KNOW. AS ARE NOT
CLOSE TO COMPETING AT HAS AN
EXTREME AND MANAGE AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S DOING SO WELL. SO
ANYWAYS I THINK THE LACK OF
APPETITE FOR FORSMAN IS
DISCOURAGING BUT- I'M HOPING
THAT- WE CAN WORK ON THAT
TOGETHER. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND I'LL JUST- I'LL
JUST ADD ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
OUR ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
REGULARLY PARTNERS WITH THE SAN
BERNADINO SHERIFF'S ON OPERATION
HAMMER STRIKE I BELIEVE ON A
WEEKLY BASIS AS WE ARE WELL
AWARE OF THE ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
OCCURRING I IN THE COUNTY AND
HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THOSE ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
LET'S MOVE ON TO A ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. OUT WE WILL- GO TO BE ON
CAMPUS TAX REFORM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET STATES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS CANNABIS
TAX REFORM. AND PLANS TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
MODIFICATIONS TO CALIFORNIA'S
CANNABIS. TAX POLICY TO HELP
STABILIZE THE MARKET. I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL BILLS INTRODUCED
RECENTLY IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE ADDRESSING.
CANNABIS TAXATION TODAY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL RECEIVE WILL
RECEIVE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
CURRENT TAX STRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA IN HERE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. ABOUT POSSIBLE
AVENUES FOR REFORM AND MY
APOLOGIES ONE MOMENTS BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO- LET ME JUST
FOR- TO INSURE THAT WE HEAR ALL
OF IT- I WANT TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND FROM
LA- IF THEY HAVE ANY COMMENT.
TWO ONE MY APOLOGIES AND MOVING
TOO QUICKLY ON ISSUE TO. FINANCE
KILEY MANNING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROLS
PROPOSALS WHICH WILL ALLOW FOR
THE PLANNING FOR UNIFIED
CANNABIS LICENSING AND
COMPLIANCE SYSTEM THE CONSUMER.
WELL AS TESTING AND INDUSTRIAL
HEMP PRODUCTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU L. L. I JUST COMPUTERS
CABALLERO WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE TO BCPS FOR
BERMAN CANNABIS CONTROL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN MY
APOLOGIES AND I'M MOVING ON TO
ISSUE TOO AS MENTIONED TODAY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL RECEIVE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE CURRENT TAX
STRUCTURE AND CALIFORNIA AND
HEAR FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
ABOUTPOSSIBLE AVENUES. OF
REFORM OUT OF THE FIRST WILL BE
A MISTER KIRSTEN LET'S START
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERYMUCH I'M SET
CHRISTINE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO ACCOMPANY MY
TESTIMONY TODAY WE'VE
DISTRIBUTED A BRIEF HAND AT.
WHICH I WILL START SHARING ON MY
SCREEN NOW OR SHORTLY WHEN I'M
GRANTED PERMISSION. OUR MOST
ASPECTS OF CALIFORNIA HERE WE GO
OKAY SO GO AHEAD AND SHARE. YEAH
SHARE MY SCREEN JUST A MOMENT
SHE. SO YOU CAN SEE THE FILE
THEN I'LL PUT IT ON FULL SCREEN
. OKAY THANK YOU SO MOST ASPECTS
OF CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS TAXES
COME FROM TO LAWS- NOTED HERE
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR WHICH THE
VOTERS PASSED IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND S. B. NINETY
FOUR TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AB PEOPLE
WERE SUPPOSED TO STATEWIDE
CANNABIS TAXES A RETAIL EXCISE
TAX WHICH RAISES ABOUT 80% OF
THE REVENUE THAT GOES INTO THE
CANNABIS TAX FUND IN A
CULTIVATION TAX WHICH RAISES THE
REMAINING 20% AS SHOWN IN THIS
FIGURE HERE. REVENUE FROM THESE
TAXES INITIALLY WAS PRETTY WEAK-
JUST IN THE IN THE MADE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER QUARTER
BUT THEN GREW QUITE RAPIDLY FROM
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REVENUES GREW
60% PER YEAR SIX ZERO BUT-
REVENUE GROWTH OVER THE LAST FEW
QUARTERS AS YOU CAN SEE HAS BEEN
MUCH SLOWER. NEXT WE WILL COVER
SOME OF THE BASIC FEATURES OF
STATE AND LOCAL CANNABIS TAXES
AND CALIFORNIA. PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR SET THE STATE'S
EXCISE TAX RATE AT 15% OF THE
RETAIL PRICE. SB NINETY FOUR
MOVED THE REMITTANCE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS TAX FROM
RETAILERS TO DISTRIBUTORS. BUT
WHEN RETAILERS BUY CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FROM DISTRIBUTORS
NOBODY KNOWS FOR SURE WHAT THE
ULTIMATE RETAIL PRICE WILL BE SO
TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
DISTRIBUTORS TO REMIT THE TAX SB
NINETY FOUR EFFECTIVELY TURNS
THEIR SO CALLED RETAIL TAX INTO
A WHOLE SALES TAX. THE STATUTE
DIRECTS THE DEPARTMEN OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION TO
ESTIMATE THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE
RETAIL MARKET. AND THEY USE THAT
NUMBER TO ESTIMATE THE WHOLESALE
TAX RATE IT'S EQUIVALENT ON
AVERAGE TO A 15% RETAIL TAX
RIGHT NOW THAT TAX RATE IS. 27%
OF THE WHOLESALE PRICE. THE
OTHER STATEWIDE CANNABIS TAXES
THE CULTIVATION TAX THIS TAX IS
A FIXED DOLLAR AMOUNT PER IN
HOUSE WITH DIFFERENT RATES FOR
THREE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OF
HARVESTED CANNABIS. PROP SIXTY
FOUR ESTABLISHED AN ANNUAL
INFLATION ADJUSTMENTS FOR THESE
TAX RATES AND THAT KEEPS THE
REAL TAX RATE CONSTANT OVER THE
LONG TERM. SB NINETY FOUR MADE
DISTRIBUTORS RESPONSIBLE FOR
REMITTING THIS TAX TO THE STATE
JUST AS IT DID FOR THE RETAIL
EXCISE TAX. THE THIRD MAJOR
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE IS THE
CANNABIS TAXES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IMPOSE ON BUSINESSES
ALL UP AND DOWN THE CANNABIS
SUPPLY CHAIN. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
WE ESTIMATED THAT THE TOTAL
STATEWIDE AVERAGE LOCAL CANNABIS
TAX WAIT RATE WAS ROUGHLY
EQUIVALENT. TO A 14% TAX ON
RETAIL SALES. NOW I'LL SHOW YOU
A FIGURE HERE. THE ILLUSTRATES
THE FLOW AND TAX PAYMENTS FOR
THE TWO STATEWIDE CANNABIS TAXES
. UNDER CURRENT LAW BEFORE
BUSINESSES MAKE TAX PAYMENTS TO
THE STATE AS YOU CAN SEE THE
FIGURE WE HAVE TAX PAYMENTS FROM
BUSINESSES TO OTHER BUSINESSES
AND THEN IN THAT CASE THE
CULTIVATION TAX SOMETIMES ONCE
OR TWICE MORE TO OTHER
BUSINESSES AND OTHER BUSINESSES
BEFORE THEY EVENTUALLY MAKE
THEIR WAY TO. THE STATE. AND
I'LL WRAP UP MY REMARKS BY
HIGHLIGHTING A FEW
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM A
STATUTORILY REQUIRED REPORT OUR
OFFICE PUBLISHED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
REFLECT A SEQUENCE OF THREE
MAJOR POLICY CHOICES FIRST
THERE'S THE CHOICE OF WHAT TYPE
OF TAX TO LEVY. OUR PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO REPLACE
THE STATE'S CANNABIS TAXES WITH
A POTENCY BASED OR CHEERED AT
VALOREM TAX ALTERNATIVELY IF
EASE OF ADMINISTRATION AND
COMPLIANCE IS THE TOP PRIORITY
THE LEGISLATURE COULD. STICK
WITH THE RETAIL EXCISE TAX
EITHER WAY WE RECOMMENDED
ELIMINATING THE CULTIVATION TAX.
SECOND WE RECOMMENDED COLLECTING
TAXES FROM BUSINESSES THAT
PARTICIPATE DIRECTLY IN WHATEVER
ACTIVITY IS BEING TAXED. THAT
WOULD MEAN FOR EXAMPLE
COLLECTING THE RETAIL EXCISE TAX
FOR RETAILERS RATHER THAN
DISTRIBUTORS. AND THIRD WE NOTED
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REASONABLY
COULD CONSIDER A WIDE RANGE OF
TAX RATE. I CONCLUDES MY
PREPARED REMARKS AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS IF YOU
HAVE ANY. THANK YOU MISTER
CONSTANT LET'S MOVE TO DIRECTOR
MODELS FOR HIS PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
. THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S NICK
MOTORISTS AND- DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION AND THERE ARE
THREE TAXES MR PERSON SAID THERE
TO SPECIFICALLY AROUND CANNABIS
BUT THERE ARE THREE IN OUR VIEW
THAT- STATE TAXES ON CANNABIS.
IN WE ADMINISTER ALL THREE OF
THOSE THE CULTIVATION AND EXCISE
TAXES WHICH JUST HEARD ABOUT AS
WELL AS THE SALES AND USE TAX
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OF THESE THREE TAXES
TOGETHER BROUGHT IN JUST SHY OF
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN REVENUE. AND THAT FIGURE
INCLUDES- A SUBSTANTIAL PORTION
SALES AND USE TAX ACTUALLY GOES
BACK- TO MUNICIPALITIES AROUND
THE STATE- AND SO THAT INCLUDES
THOSE FIGURES THAT'S NOT ALL
STATE REVENUE- I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF TALK ABOUT TAX
RATES IN THE TAX RATES ON
CANNABIS BEING TOO HIGH AND CD
TFA. IS THAT GNOSTIC ON THAT
QUESTION- WE WILL ADMINISTER THE
TAXES AS YOU IN THE LEGISLATURE
TOGETHER WITH THE GOVERNOR- I.
SEE FIT AND SET THE POLICY. AB
THE RATES HOW. I DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE- ARE TWO IMPORTANT
GENERAL TAX PRINCIPLES- THAT I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP IN
MIND AS YOU CONSIDER ANY
POSSIBLE MODIFICATIONS- TO THE
STATE'S CANNABIS TAXES. FIRST
TAXES SHOULD BE AS SIMPLE AS
POSSIBLE AT C. D. T. F. A. WE
ADMINISTER THIRTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT TAX AND FEE PROGRAMS.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I CAN CONFIRM
WHAT MANY IF YOU ALREADY
SUSPECT. TAXES ARE COMPLICATED.
BUT EVEN IN- THAT WORLD
COMPLICATED TAXES CALIFORNIA'S
CAMPUS TAXES ARE PARTICULARLY
COMPLEX AND THAT COMPLEXITY.
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS OUR
ADMINISTRATION OF THE TAXES AND
IT ADDS A BURDEN FOR BUSINESSES
THAT ARE BEING RESPONSIBLE AND
IF YOU'RE INTO THE POOLS. MIGHT
BE HAPPY TO DISCUSS THOSE
COMPLEXITIES I'M IN MORE DETAIL
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS. THE
SECOND PORTENT POINT I THAT I
THINK- I ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP
IN MIND. IS THAT THE TAX
STRUCTURE SHOULD BE FAIR TO
THOSE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
COMPLYING AS YOU HAVE ALREADY-
BIRD TODAY. CALIFORNIA FACES
THIS- A PROBLEM OF NON
COMPLIANCE I IN THE CANNABIS
SPACED. AND WE AT CD TFA
FREQUENTLY HEAR FROM LEGAL
CANNABIS BUSINESSES THAT THEY
ARE BEING UNDERCUT BY THOSE
BUSINESSES OPERATING OFTEN
OPERATING TOTALLY OUT IN THE
OPEN- OUTSIDE OF THE LEGAL
MARKET. AND TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM AND TO BRING FAIRNESS TO
THE MARKET I IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
CONSIDERATIONS OF TAX CHANGES
INCLUDE ROBUST ENFORCEMENT
MEASURES TO PREVENT ILLEGAL
CANNABIS OPERATORS FROM
EXPLOITING ANY UNFAIR TAX
ADVANTAGE- I THERE ARE MANY
POSSIBLE WAYS TO DO THIS EVEN
JUST EXPECT EXTENDING MANY OF
THE ENFORCEMENT MEASURES THAT WE
HAVE FOR SALES AND USE TAX FOR
INSTANCE. TO THE CANNABIS TAXES
WOULD HELP GREATLY- AS WE TRY TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD AND
CLOSE DOWN ILLEGAL OPERATORS
ANYWAY THOSE ARE THE TWO-
CONSIDERATIONS THAT I WOULD.
SUGGEST YOU KEEP IN MIND AND I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER
MOTHER DOES WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT SPEAKER LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
KIND OF A CONTROL A DIRECTOR
ELLIOT ARE YOU ABLE TO SHARE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S VERSION FOR
CANNABIS TAX REFORM THIS YEAR.
SO I'M NOT ABLE TO SHARE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S VERSION BUT I
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS A FEW
THINGS ABOUT HOW THE DEPARTMENT
IS APPROACHING THE ISSUE IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED. SURE GO AHEAD
OKAY GREAT AS YOU KNOW WE DO NOT
SET TAX RULES OR BATES THAT'S UP
TO YOU GUYS IN THE VOTERS AND WE
DO NOT ADMINISTER COLLECT TAXES
THAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF MR
MATATUS ADDS THAT DIRECTOR OF C.
T. F. THANK HAVING SAID THAT
THOUGH DCC IS UNIQUELY SITUATED
TO SHARE WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
LICENSEES ON IMPACTS OF THE TAX
STRUCTURE- AND THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE ADMINISTRATION ON TAX
REFORM TO SOME EXTENT. OF WHAT
WE'RE HEARING THE MOST OBVIOUS
COMPLAINT TAXES ARE HIGH AT
LICENSEES ARE ALSO SHARING WITH
US HOW THE TAX STRUCTURE POSES
SIGNIFICANT OPERATIONAL
CHALLENGES FOR EXAMPLE WE'RE
TOLD THAT THE IMPOSITION OF A
FIXED TAX RATE ON CULTIVATORS
RATES TIED TO OVERALL INFLATION
I DID NOT APPROPRIATELY CONSIDER
AGRICULTURAL MARKET FLUCTUATIONS
THEREFORE THIS TAX POLICY HAS
BEEN TO AN EQUALLY BURDEN
FARMERS PARTICULARLY CALIFORNIA
SMALL FARMERS. IMPOSITION OF
MULTIPLE TAXES FOCUSED ON
MULTIPLE POINTS AND THE CANNABIS
SUPPLY CHAIN OUT MAKES THE
SYSTEM UNNECESSARILY COMPLICATED
AND ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME
THE COMPLEXITIES OF THE
STRUCTURE AS DIRECTOR MURDER US
MENTIONED TO CAN MAKE IT
CHALLENGING FOR OPERATORS TO
TRACK TAXES OWED AND KATE
RESULTING IN THE NEED FOR SOME
TO EXPAND ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO REMAIN COMPLIANT. THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE IN WHICH BUSINESSES
AND A CASH BASED INDUSTRY
WITHOUT READY ACCESS TO CAPITAL
ARE ASKED TO PAY ESTIMATED TAXES
IN ADVANCE AND SEEK REPAYMENT
LATER IS ESPECIALLY BURDENSOME
FOR SMALLER OPERATORS WITH FEWER
EGAN. THIS INCLUDING. OUR EQUITY
OPERATORS. INSIDERY NEED
STRUGGLE SHARED BY LICENSEE WE
CAN. WITH WHAT APPEARS TO BE A
SHARED SENTIMENT FOR. HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO HELP MVING KEEP
OPERATORS AND CONSUMERS IN THE
REGULATED MARKET. ALTHOUGH WE
ARE JOINING THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
WITH MEMBER OFFICES AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THEIR POSITIONS ON
TAX REFORM. AND WE BEGAN
REVIEWING THE RECENT TAX
PROPOSALS THAT YOU MENTIONED
WE'RE JUST AFFORD I'M BY YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS
INDICATED THAT IT PLANS TO BRING
TOGETHER STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
THE LEGISLATURE AN INDUSTRY WITH
A GOAL OF IDENTIFYING A
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE TAX
REFORM SOLUTION THAT WILL HELP
STABILIZE THE INDUSTRY. WHILE
STILL MAINTAINING THE INTEGRITY
OF PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR WHICH
PROMISED VOTERS REVENUE FOR
YOUTH PROGRAMS ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS AND ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST THE MARKET. DISEASE
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND THE ULTIMATE
DEVELOPMENT OF TAX POLICIES THAT
PROMOTE EQUITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND THAT STABILIZE THE MARKET.
WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU WE WILL
MOST DEFINITELY BE ASKING
QUESTIONS BUT BEFORE WE DO IS
THERE ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FINALLY MAKING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
BUT HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GO INTO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE DÍAS HAVE SOME
JUST A POOR FINANCES ARE A
TIMELINE FOR WHEN WE WILL SEE A
POTENTIL TAX REFORM PROPOSAL
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION. SURELY
MANY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
WILL HAVE SOMETHING TO SHARE
LATER THIS SPRING. CAN YOU GIVE
ME A- MONTH TO DATE BY SPRING
YOU MEAN ONE. I DON'T HAVE THE
SPECIFIC THE. OKAY AT THIS IS
LOOKING FOR SOMETHING PART IN A
FINANCE ALSO WERE WORKING WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO DEVELOP A PROPOSAL TOGETHER
SO- CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING
AND WE WILL HAVE SOMETHING FOR
YOU LATER THIS SPRING WE DON'T
HAVE A- DATE CERTAIN YET. OKAY
PLEASE SON JUST KNOW THAT.
HAVING THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THE MEMBERS OF
THIS. COMMITTEE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION ON.
WHETHER TO ACCEPT OR REJECT A
PROPOSALS COMING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION SO PLEASE KEEP
THAT IN MIND SO THAT WE CAN. DO
OUR DUE DILIGENCE AND CONVEY
THAT TO OUR COLLEAGUES AS WELL.
THAT THANK YOU. I HAD SOME
QUESTIONS IN GENERAL AND THANK
YOU AGAIN TO ALL THE PRESENTERS-
WHAT ARE THE FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE FLUCTUATIONS
IN CAMPUS TAX REVENUE. CHARLIE
MANNING DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
SO FLUCTUATIONS AT THIS POINT IN
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS TAX
REVENUES ARE GENERALLY DIFFERENT
DRIVEN BY OVERALL. ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS CHANGES IN CONSUMER
PREFERENCES AND MARKET PRICES.
THIS IS NOT A RESTAURANT CDFA I
WOULD SAY- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAPPENED- RELATIVELY EARLY
ON THAT CAUSED AN INCREASE IN
TAX REVENUE WAS THE ADJUSTMENT-
THE- MARK UP. FROM 60% TO EIGHTY
PERCENT- BECAUSE AS THIS MISTER
BURSTING I EXPLAINED BETWEEN THE
TIME OF PROP SIXTY FOUR S. B.
NINETY FOUR THERE WAS THIS
CHANGE- FROM THE 15% TAX RETAIL-
TO- TO. MOVING THE INCIDENCE OF
THE TAX TO THE DISTRIBUTOR- WE
EAT EVERY SIX MONTHS AND CITY
CHIEF I CALCULATE BASED ON
SIMPLY ON A TRACK AND TRACE
DATA- THE AVERAGE STATEWIDE
MARKUP BETWEEN WHOLESALE AND
RETAIL- THAT THE SET NATIONALLY
IT'S 60% WHEN IT MOVED 280% THAT
DID- BECAUSE AN INCREASE IN. TAX
REVENUE- I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
THAT. I DO THINK IN ADDITION TO
THE- IDMS MENTION BY THE PARTNER
FINANCED THAT THE AMOUNT OF-
CONSUMPTION THAT GOES TO THE
LEGAL MARKET VERSUS THE ILLEGAL
MARKET CERTAINLY PLAYS A ROLE.
WHICH IS WHY I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WE- DO YOU FOCUS ON
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL. THANK YOU
FOR THAT I THINK THAT'S THE
CRITICAL POINT THAT MR COOPER
WAS MAKING EARLIER IN TERMS OF
ENFORCEMENT AND WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE TO SHUT DOWN THE LEGAL
MARKET SO THAT WE CAN FOCUS ON.
UP YOU KNOW WHAT THE REST OF IT
COULD POTENTIALLY LOOK LIKE AND
HOW AT THE END OF THE DAY- THE
DEPARTMENT IS BETTER RESOURCE-
ARE. I'M SORRY GO AHEAD MAKE
JUST THAT IF I MAY JUST
ADVENTURE- TO MR COOPER'S
EARLIER COMMENTS- YOU KNOW IT.
ECC IS NOT THE ONLY SB AUTHOR
THE STATE LEVEL TRYING TO WORK
ON ENFORCEMENT WE ARE AS WELL WE
HAVE PEOPLE WORKING EVERY DAY
ALL AROUND THE STATE- THIS
FISCAL YEAR AT LEAST THROUGH
LAST WEEK I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS THROUGH- RIGHT. NOW WE
HAD PERFORMED FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE INSPECTIONS THIS
FISCAL YEAR OF CANNABIS
BUSINESSES- WITH AN ADDITIONAL
THREE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
BUSINESSES- VISITED OR OBSERVE
CLOSER BY OUR AND OUR- TAX
SPECIALISTS RATHER THAN OUR-
OFFICERS ARE RESULTING IN A
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX SEIZURES OF
ILLEGAL CANNABIS- AND WE DO TRY
TO KEEP TO THE EXTENT WE CAN.
LIST OF- ILLEGAL OPERATING-
BUSINESSES ALL AROUND THE STATE
AND- YEAH DISCUSS ALL OF THOSE
HERE- I WOULD JUST- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED OR WANT MORE
DETAIL- WE'D BE HAPPY TO.
PROVIDE YOU WITH WHAT WE CAN.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER THANK
YOU MEASURE- ALLOCATION THROUGH
THE CANNABIS TAX ONE. INCLUDES
YOUTH EDUCATION PREVENTION.
EARLY AFTER INTERVENTION AND
TREATMENT ACCOUNT. HOW MUCH OF
YOU THEY CAN'T RECEIVE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND THEN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. MISTER COOPER THIS
IS KIMBERLY HARVESTED APARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE'VE GOT THE NUMBERS
FOR THAT- SO FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AT THE END GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THIS YEAR THE YOUTH
EDUCATION BUDGET IS FOUR HUNDRED
ONE. POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION. YEAH. FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND WHAT
WHAT WAS IT FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- I WOULD HAVE TO ACTUALLY
LET ME LOOK IN THE- LEAVE IT ON
THE AGENDA. AT TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT'S TWO HUNDRED TO
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
. TWO HUNDRED TWO AND SIX AND
FORTY SEVEN MILLION. YEAH.
THIRTY MILLION SEVEN THOUSAND
OKAY TWO TWO OKAY MILLION OKAY
CHECKS ON IF IT'S HELPFUL THE
CHARGES ON PAGE NINETEEN OF THE
AGENDA WITH ALL THE YEARS OF THE
DOLLARS. SIX OVER FOR THAT FLOWS
TO THE MOTORCYCLES OVER SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. SO WHAT
PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED AND- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FOR THE YOUTH CAL. WE'VE GOT
THEM CDPH SURVEILLANCE EDUCATION
ACTIVITIES SOCIAL SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR ACCESS TO
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE- AND
HEALTHCARE SERVICES FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANTS AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY FOR COMMUNITY
ACCESS. FOR WHAT ACCESS. FOR
COMMUNITY ACCESS WHAT WHAT DOES
THAT ENTAIL THESE PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO GET LICENSES OR WHAT.
AND THAT'S IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES THERE IS A THAT'S
OUTSIDE MY AREA OF EXPERTISE BUT
I'D BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU. OKAY DO WE ALSO DO IS- LIST
SOMEWHERE OF PROGRAMS THAT WERE
FUNDED. AND HOW MUCH EACH
PROGRAM RECEIVED. WE CAN PUT ONE
TOGETHER FOR YES THAT WOULD BE
NICE THANK YOU- DO YOU KNOW HOW
THESE PROGRAMS WERE SELECTED-
TWEET IT'S MY TIME ON SIGN UP
BUT WE CAN FIND OUT I KNOW THAT
THE BUCKETS. SO THE ALLOCATION
THREE BUCKET OF YOUTH- EDUCATION
AS EXPERTS AT THAT SET IN PROP.
SIXTY FOUR. THEN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION PART
IS 20% AND THEN STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT GETS FINAL TWENTY
PERCENT. AND THEN WITHIN THOSE
PERCENTAGES THERE ARE. SMALLER
DIVISIONS. AND THEN WHAT LESLIE
ON MY LAST QUESTION IS WHAT
DEPARTMENTS RESPONSIBLE FOR
AWARDING THE FUNDING. VISA BEEN
FAIRLY STATIC THOUGH SINCE THE
BEGINNING. OKAY CUSTOMER LIST OF
WHAT DEPARTMENT SO. CHUCK OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
. THANK YOU WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
OR FOUR ITEMS TO FOLLOW UP ON
YOUR QUESTIONS OKAY MISTER
COOPER IMPORTANT. ARE THERE
OTHER LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
CANNABIS US TAX STRUCTURES AND
OTHER STATES. SEP BURSTING WITH
THE L. A. **** MAYBE I'LL JUST
START BY DOING A REAL QUICK
SKETCH OF WHAT CANNABIS AX
STRUCTURES AND OTHER STATES LOOK
LIKE- THE MOST COMMON TYPE IS-
IS THIS SORT OF BY PERCENTAGE OF
RETAIL RETAIL PRICE SO WE CAN WE
TALK ABOUT THE RETAIL EXCISE TAX
THAT'S- I MEAN HYPOTHETICALLY IF
IT WERE COLLECTED DIRECTLY FROM
THE RETAILER THAT WOULD LOOK AT
PRETTY SIMILAR TO THE MOST
COMMON TYPE. OF STATE AND LOCAL
CANNABIS TAX ADMINISTERED IN
OTHER STATES- FAR LESS COMMONLY
AND THERE ARE OTHER TYPES OF
TAXES SUCH AS- A WEIGHT BASED
TAX CULTIVATION TAXES LIKE THE
ONE WE HAVE HERE THEIR COUPLE
STATES THAT HAVE THAT- ILLINOIS
HE HAS A TAX THAT IS. HERE BASED
ON THE POTENCY OF THE PRODUCT.
NEW YORK IN ABOUT A MONTH IS
GONNA BE ROLLING OUT A- A- IT.
IS TO BE ROLLING OUT ATTACK THAT
IS- POTENCY BASED SORT OF LIKE
THE ONE WE DISCUSSED IN OUR
REPORT THAT'S ANOTHER TYPE IT'S
OUT THERE- SO THAT'S IT WITH
REGARD TO SIR STATE LEVEL TAXES
THAT'S SORT OF AN OVERVIEW. ONE
STRIKING DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES WITH
LEGAL CANNABIS IS HOW WE
APPROACH LOCAL TAXATION SO MOST
OTHER STATES. ARE PLACED AT A
FAIR BIT OF- LIMITS OR
RESTRICTIONS ON HOW THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN TAX CANNABIS AND
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE DON'T DO
THAT PRETTY MUCH THE LOCALS ARE.
ARE PERMITTED TO TAX AS THEY
WISH- AND SO ARE THE SPECIFIC
TYPES OF RESTRICTIONS THAT YOU
TEND TO SEE IN OTHER STATES IS
TYPICALLY LIMITING LOCAL
TAXATION OF CANNABIS TO THE
RETAIL LEVEL ON- THE ONLY OTHER
STATE THAT WE'RE AWARE OF THAT
ALLOWS TAXES ON OTHER TYPES OF
NON RETAIL CANNABIS BUSINESSES
IS. ILLINOIS AND EVEN THEN THEY
DO CAP RATES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN LET THE STAFF
JUST A QUICK OVERVIEW AS FAR AS
LESSONS LEARNED- THE ONE MAJOR
CANNABIS TAX REFORM IN OTHER
STATES THAT WE'RE AWARE OF IT IS
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AND
WASHINGTON. WHAT THEY USED TO
HAVE WAS THEY HAD- TAXES THAT
WORK PERCENTAGE OF THE PRICE AT
A VARIETY OF OUR- DIFFERENT
LEVELS STAGES OF PRODUCTION
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. AND WHAT THEY DID WAS
THEY DID NOT SIMPLIFY THEIR
SYSTEM TO ARE THEY ESSENTIALLY
ELIMINATED THE TAXES OF THE
OTHER PARTS OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
AND INCREASES THE RATE AT THE-
RETAIL LEVEL SO THAT SORT OF DAY
I THINK THEY DID FIND THAT.
PRIOR SYSTEM TO BE- UNDESIRABLE
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
CERTAINLY THERE'S THE COMPLEXITY
ASPECT BUT. ALSO- I THINK THAT
THE I THAT IT I. CREATE A- I. AN
ADVANTAGE FOR VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED BUSINESSES THAT
POSSIBLY DUE TO TAX STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS- MISTER
LUCKY. IT'S JUST A KIND OF A
COMMENT AND THEN A- A QUESTION
REAL QUICKLY. MY BELIEVE THAT
IS. THAT THE GOAL OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR WAS TO TAKE CANNABIS
PRODUCTION OF CELLS OUT OF THE
HANDS THE ONLY. THE ILLEGAL
MARKET THAT IS NECESSARY AND WE
HEARD THIS EXPRESSED EARLIER.
FOR THE LEGAL MARKET TO BE
FAIRLY TAXED AND OPERATE IN A
SIMPLIFIED COMPLIANCE AND
REPORTING SYSTEM- AND IT ALSO
HAS TO BE SUBJECT TO INSPECTION
AND ENFORCEMENT. THAT COULD BE
CARRIED OUT RELATIVELY SIMPLE
THESE ACTIONS CANNOT. CANNOT
OCCUR UNDER THE CURRENT
CONDITIONS. IF THERE'S TO BE A
CANNABIS TAX REFORM WHAT WOULD
THAT LOOK LIKE AND HOW THE
IMPACT. THAT THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY OF THE INDUSTRY THAT'S
THE SOURCE OF THE CANNABIS TAX
FUND AND THE PROGRAMS THAT RELY
ON ITS FUNDING HOW WOULD THAT
LOOK AT I HEAR THAT YOU- VOICE A
BIT OF FRUSTRATION THAT- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COULD TAX AT ANY
LEVEL AND I SHARE THAT
FRUSTRATION. I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S A BIG APPETITE TO- TAX
THE COMPETITIVE NATURE. OF THE
LEGAL MARKET RIGHT OUT OF THE
PICTURE AND I THINK TO SOME
DEGREE THAT'S WHAT OUR PROBLEM.
IS CURRENTLY WOULD YOU SHARE
THAT VIEW. I THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY FOR THE QUESTION-
I THINK- IT IT'S- THERE'S
CERTAINLY A VARIETY OF FACTORS
AT PLAY WE HAVE NOT CONDUCTED A
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF THE-
AND- CHALLENGES FACING- THE
LICENSED CANNABIS INDUSTRY I
THINK YOU YOU'VE IN YOUR REMARKS
IDENTIFIED A FEW AS WELL AS SORT
OF GET THE EARLIER DISCUSSION IN
HEARING- I. WOULD SAY THERE IS-
AT. OUR TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT I
DID EXAMINE ONE SPECIFIC ISSUE
WHICH WAS THEIR STATEWIDE TAXES
WITCHER'S STORED AT A FAIR BIT
OF WHAT WE'RE DISCUSSING NOW AND
DID FIND THAT- LOWER STATEWIDE
TAX RATES WOULD- MAKE THE- I
SINCE MARKET MORE COMPETITIVE
WITH THE ILLICIT MARKET AND
THERE ARE CERTAINLY A NUMBER OF
OTHER POLICY OPTIONS BAKER THAT
PUTS THINGS IN THAT DIRECTION AS
WELL. THANK YOU I JUST THINK
IT'S THAT DESERVES TO BE STATED
AS LOUDLY AS POSSIBLE. THAT THE
THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO COMPLY.
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE THE ONES
TO GET MORE. ENFORCEMENT AND I
FIND THAT TO BE AN ENIGMA WHEN.
THOSE WHO ARE IN THE ILLICIT
SPACE SEEM TO HAVE A LOT MORE
FREEDOM OF ENFORCEMENT AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S A- MISGUIDED
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO
BETTER AND- SIMPLIFYING. OUR TAX
STRUCTURE AND- ALLOWING ARE
THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO COMPLY
AND RECOGNIZE THAT AND ALLOW
THEM TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU MISTER LUCKY IF THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WE
CAN MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE
CALIFORNIA HELD THE- JUST MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO ONE ON THAT
ADDITIONAL PANEL THE HOW TO
COMMENT. SEEING NONE OKAY.
CALIFORNIA HELD HELD A
COMBINATORIAL RECALL ELECTION ON
SEPTEMBER FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AB ONE TWENTY ONE
AND SB ONE FIVE TWO OF LAST YEAR
APPROPRIATED FUNDS TO CONDUCT
THE ELECTION AND REQUIRED. THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO REPORT THE
FINAL COST BY FEBRUARY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR. FOR THIS NEXT ITEM
SECRETARY OF STATE WILL PROVIDE
A REPORT OF THE COST OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. CALIFORNIA
GUBERNATORIAL RECALL ELECTION.
OUR PANELISTS FOR THIS ITEM WILL
BE SUSAN LAPSING SET WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY AND TO KEEP AN
INFECTION IF THAT WAS YOU
COVERED A LOT OF MY BY A
MISSILE. TALKING POINTS SO IF
YOU COULD INDICATE EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT SB ONE FIFTY TWO
ALLOCATED THE FUNDS FOR THE
RECALL ELECTION. AND IT WAS TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE COUNTIES AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S. AB TWENTY
EIGHT ALSO REQUIRED OUR OFFICE
TO REPORT TO YOU THE LEGISLATURE
THE RESULTS OF THOSE. OF THOSE
COSTS WHICH WE DID HONOR BEFORE
FEBRUARY FIRST- OUR OFFICE THE
NUMBER OF REPORTS AND IT IT
DETAILS THE- VARIOUS COSTS THAT
WERE INCURRED BY BUT THE
COUNTIES AND OUR OFFICE. IF
YOU'RE SOURCE TWO HUNDRED FORTY
THREE MILLION THREE AT FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE THREE
NINE EIGHT FIFTY CENTS WERE
ALLOCATE TO A COUNTIES. AND OF
THOSE EVENTS FUNDS OUT ALLOCATED
EIGHTY ACTUAL COSTS WERE A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR MILLION.
YOU NINE THOUSAND AND THIRTY
DOLLARS AND WE HAD SOME COUNTIES
THAT FUN THAT WERE REMAINING FOR
A LITTLE OVER SIXTEEN MILLION.
AND WE HAVE THAT SIXTEEN
COUNTIES THAT NEEDS NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO YOUR MEETING
CONSTABLE AND A LITTLE OVER FOUR
DOLLARS. AND FORTY TWO COUNTIES
HAVE FUNDS AVAILABLE AS I HAD
INDICATED AT AND- DOES IT RANGES
ANYWHERE FROM. HAVING THAT. JUST
A FEW THOUSAND DOLLARS LEFT OVER
TO YOU ADD MILLIONS DOLLARS LEFT
OVER AND ON THE NEED IT'S- HAS A
WHOLE SPECTRUM OF SUB. NEEDING A
COUPLE THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU I'M
SO NAY AT COUPLE NIGHTS DOLLARS
IT THAT'S IT OUT IN THE REPORT
THAT WAS. THAT WAS SENT TO YOU
GUYS- YES I'M HAPPY TO GO
THROUGH WHAT ALL OF THOSE EACH
OF THOSE COUNTIES HONORED BUT
ARE PROVIDED TO YOU AFTER THIS
HEARING. FOR THE SURGERY STATE
BECAUSE OUR OFFICE WAS ALLOCATED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION WE HAD
ESTIMATED ACTUALLY THIRTY TWO
MILLION. ACTUALS WORD TWENTY SIX
MILLION- OVER TWENTY SIX MILLION
WE STILL HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
COSTS THAT WE ARE ANTICIPATING
MAY STILL COME AND BASED UPON
THE PROCESSING. TIME AND
INVOICING. THE GENERAL SERVICE
IN OUR- AND DISCOUNT LOOKING TO
THAT PROCESS. THOSE ARE THE- HE
IN THE AT AB WHAT EIGHT. HE BUT
HAD INDICATE THAT HE HAD FUND
RECEIVING COUNTY ACTUALLY USE ON
SEPT BECAUSE FOR THE NAY
ELECTION CONNECT BY THE CAT THE
NEXT DATE ELECTION CONNECT BY
COUNTY. I'M AND THEN IT. WAS ALL
INDICATED S. B. ONE FIFTY TWO
THAT IT WAS INTO THE WEBSITE TO
CONSIDER AND- TO THE THAT WAS
ALLOCATE BASED ON THE FINAL. BUT
NEXT ELECTION SO GET HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. AB RIGHT
LARGE DETAIL. THANK YOU THAT
MATH LABS THE- THE SECRETARY TO
RIP NOW THAT COUNTIES HIGHER
THAN ANTICIPATED COSTS AND WILL
NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING. DOES
THE SECRETARY OF STATE HAVE A
PLAN IN PLACE TO COVER THOSE
GAPS. SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
MINIMUM ADVENTURE IT WAS LOOKING
AT THE BILL LANGUAGE. THAT WAS
INCLUDED AND IT WAS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE AN
ADJUSTMENT SO WE HAVE NOT.
SUBMITTED ANYTHING BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ATKINS AT
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS TO DO WHAT'S
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
COUNTIES ARE MENTAL. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS. OKAY SEEING NONE- WOULD
HAVE BEEN GREAT TO USE THOSE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SOMETHING ELSE LIKE FUNDING OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL I'M
SORRY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES THIRTEEN PROPOSALS FROM
THE SECRETARY OF STATE THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HEAR SOMEONE OF
THEM ON THIS PANEL. TWO ARE
RELATED TO THE SECRETARY OF
STAE'S A PHYSICAL FACILITIES
AND FOR RELATED TO I. T.
PROJECTS. THERE IS ALSO A
PROPOSAL TO WAIVE BUSINESS
FILING FEES- WE HAVE SEVERAL
PANELISTS. BUT WE WILL BEGIN
LET'S START WITH THE BCPS
RELATED TO FACILITIES AND
PHYSICAL SPACE. IF WE COULD HAVE
MARIA WALTON AND- IS TO MERA
MARTIN COVER THE REQUEST FOR
AUGMENTATION OF WRENCH FUNDING.
AS WELL AS EXPANDING SPACE AND
RESOURCES FOR HISTORIC ARTIFACTS
AND RECORDS. ANY UNIT NUMBER
ONE- GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARRILLO AS WELL AS THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION MY NAME IS
MARIA WALTON I AM THE ACTING
DIVISION CHIEF OF THE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES DIVISION OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE. AT
THIS I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE AT PCP ARE EXITING YES THE
FALL B. C. P. ON AUGMENTATION OF
GRANT FUNDING FOR THE SECRETARY
OF STATE. THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE IS REQUESTING A
PERMANENT AUGMENTATION OF THREE
POINT SIX MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWO THREE AND FOUR
MILLION ANNUALLY THERE AFTER TO
REALIGN THE APPROPRIATIONS. RAN
THE MEN'S AS INVOICE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
RENTAL RATES ARE ESTABLISHED ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
PUBLISHED IN THE TGS PRICE BOOK
AN INVOICE QUARTERLY. SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE HAD INCURRED
AN AVERAGE ANNUAL INCREASE OF 4%
AND RENTAL EXPENSES FOR THE MARK
MARCH FUND YOU BUILDING. WITHOUT
A COMMENSURATE INCREASE IN
APPROPRIATION CREATING A
COMPOUND THE IMPACT TO THE
FUNDING OF THE AGENCY THAT
CANNOT BE SUSTAINED WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE
IMPACT. TO THE OPERATIONS OF THE
PROGRAM AND ITS PRO PROGRAM
RESPONSIBILITIES. I'D BE HAPPY.
TO DISCUSS OR ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU. THANK YOU
MISS MARTIN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY M NAME IS TAMERA
MARCH AND I'M THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ARCHIVIST. OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ARCHIVES IS THE
DIVISION OF THE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE. WE
WERE CREATED BY CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST ON JANUARY FIFTH EIGHTEEN
FIFTY WE ARE THE OLDEST STATE
ENTITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE ONE OF THE LARGEST STATE
ARCHIVES COLLECTIONS THE UNITED
STATES WITH OVER THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION RECORDS AND THAT'S
INCLUDES RECORDS FROM ALL THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT INCLUDING
THE LEGISLATURE. MEMBER RECORDS
AS WELL AS- LIMITED. OF LOCAL
GUY RECORDS AND PRIVATE. BUT THE
BACK SIDE OF OUR COLLECTION OUR
CURRENT STORAGE FACILITY FOR
CLOSE 290% ALL AND WHAT THE
EXISTING SHOPPING INFRASTRUCTURE
WE ANTICIPATE TO BE COMPLETELY
ALL OF THE NEXT SEVEN TO TEN
YEARS. AND EACH OF EACH YEAR
OFFICER THOUSANDS OF BIG
SEARCHERS AND OTHER CUSTOMERS
ACCESSING OUR COLLECTIONS MOTHER
PRESS PUBLIC. AND CURRENTLY WE
ARE. ON INCREASING PUBLIC
ACCESSIBILITY TO THE STATE FOR
STARK RECORDS ARTIFACTS IN OUR
COLLECTION. AS WELL AS ENSURING
THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE STORAGE
BASEMENT QUITMAN TO PRESERVE
THESE TREASURES FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. SO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE HAS RESPECTFULLY
SUBMITTED. BE THINKING EXPANDING
SPACE AND RESOURCES TO
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC RECORDS
AND ARTIFACTS IN THE AMOUNT OF
ONE MILLION FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AND. SIX
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THERE AFTER.
THIS INCLUDES BY FOR IT CHAU.
DISASTER IMPROPER RESEARCH FOR
RECORD. GAINING EXCITEMENT ON
GOING TO. FUNDING AND SHE HAS.
ARE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL WILL
ADDRESS THE CREDIT NEED TO
CONVERT THE REMAIN EXCEPT
STATION SHOPPING TOMORROW
SHOPPING TO DOUBLE THE CAPACITY
OF A SHOPPING RANGERS. TO FULLY
MAXIMIZE EXISTING BUILDINGS. IT
WILL ALSO ADD SPECIALTY. OR
ARTIFACTS AND ARTWORK AS WELL AS
ADDING FREE THREE THIRTY
EQUIPMENT IMPRESSED. SUPPLIES
FOR DISASTER. FOR TREATING
RECORDS THAT ARRIVED THE STATE
ARCHIVES NEEDING CONSERVATION
WORK. IT ALSO ADDS ON A- FUNDING
TO PROVIDE ON THE ACCESS TO
HISTORICAL RECORDS. IN PAPER
FIFTH FORM FROM OF THE PUBLIC.
AND IT BUILDS ON TO OUR INDUSTRY
TO PUBLIC AWARENESS AND ACT TO
THE ARCHIVES COLLECTION. AS WELL
AS ADDING CRITICAL STEP. I AM
ALSO DID MARCH SPEND A SPECIAL
YOU TO THE MEMBERS ON THE
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE TRANSFERRED
THE RECORDS OF THE STATE ARCHIVE
WE REALLY APPRECIATE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESERVE YOUR LIKE AT THE
HEART CARE. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MS MARTIN LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE I. T. RELATED AND
OTHER PROPOSALS LET'S HAVE. A
MISS SMITH BETSY BOGARD JOE
WHITE AND MARLA WALTON FOR THE
PROPOSALS ON CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
CONNECTS BUSINESS PROGRAMS
PROCESSING TIME. IMPROVING. THE
PMO STRUCTURE AND FISCALE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THIS IS BETSY BOGAERT. I
AM THE CHIEF OF THE BUSINESS
PROGRAMS DIVISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF STATE.
AS WELL AS CO SPONSOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS CONNECT OUR
ONE OF OUR MAJOR IT PROJECTS
AUTOMATING. BUSINESS ENTITIES- I
AM EXCITED TO SHARE THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS CONNECTORS
IN ITS FINAL PHASE- MODULE FOR
WHICH WILL. IMPLEMENT IN MARCH
OF. MARCH TWENTY NINTH OF THIS.
THIS YEAR. AND IT WILL COVER ALL
OF BUSINESS ENTITIES SO
CORPORATIONS LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANIES LIMITED PARTNERSHIPS
CAN FILE ONLINE. WE ARE ASKING
FOR EIGHT POINT ONE MILLION.
FROM THE BUSINESS FEES FUND. AND
BUSINESS PROGRAMS MONETIZATION
FUND TO CONTINUE TO FINISH OUT
THIS PROJECT AND- AFTER LARGER
WILL GO INTO MAINTENANCE AND
SUPPORT I'M ALSO HERE TO-
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE BUSINESS
PROGRAMS DIVISION PROCESSING
TIMES BCP. THIS IS YOUR- SOME
MEMBERS MAY RECALL ARE LIMITED
TERM FUNDED POSITIONS IT
ORIGINALLY WAS FIFTY SIX
POSITIONS WERE NOW DOWN TO FORTY
SEVEN POSITIONS ALL SEEKING FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THOSE
LIMITED TERM FUNDED POSITIONS AS
WELL AS TEMPORARY STAFF AND OVER
. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. YOU MIGHT HAVE ON EITHER OF
THESE PROPOSALS. THANK YOU ARE
HEARING FROM MR JOE WHITE AND-
MARIA WALTON. I'LL GO HADN'T AND
PERCEIVED AT MADAM CHAIR- AGAIN
I AM AT HERE TO TESTIFY ON THE
SYSTEM FISCAL AUGMENTATION THAT
WE HAVE SUBMITTED THE SECRETARY
OF STATE IS REQUESTING A
PROMINENT AUGMENTATION OF THE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO
FUND ONE ASSOCIATE ACCOUNTING
ANALYST WHICH IS A NON IT
CLASSIFICATION WITHIN THE
SYSTEMS YOU KNOW THE FISCAL
AFFAIRS BUREAU THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE EXPERIENCED A
DIFFICULT TRANSITION ONTO THE
NEW MORE ROBUST AND COMPLEX
STATEWIDE FINANCIAL SYSTEM OF
RECORD THIS GAL. WELL WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS WITH REGARD TO GETTING
ON TRACK WITH THE TIMELY
SUBMITTAL OUR OF OUR YEAR END
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS THIS
FUNDING WILL POSITION THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE TO
SUCCESSFULLY PERFORM THE DUTIES
OF MAINTAINING FISCAL CODING.
RUNNING IN TROUBLE SHOOTING COST
ALLOCATION AND LABOR
DISTRIBUTION APARTMENT CLEARING
ACCOUNT RECONCILIATIONS. AND
SERVING AS THE- I I'M ARMS BUT
IT'S BEEN. TWENTY THE SUCH AND
OUTS CAN AGENCIES WHICH ARE SCO
P. SCALP INDIO AT. EDUCATIONALLY
IT WILL RECTIFY THE CURRENT
SITUATION OF A SINGLE PERSON
DEPENDENCY FOR THESE STUDENTS.
BE HAPPY TO DISCUSS ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU MS WALTON MR JOE WHITE
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THIS IS
PERFECT THE RESPECTFULLY
SUBMITTED A PCP TO FUND A ONE
POINT TWO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO HAVE SIX PERMANENT POSITIONS
TO INCREASE OUR CAPACITY IMAGE
FOR OUR PROJECT MANAGEMENT
PROCESSES HERE AT SECRETARY OF
STATE AS WE HAVE A HIGH NUMBER
OF LEGACY SYSTEMS HERE AT
SECRETARY STATE WE'RE
ANTICIPATING ANYWHERE FROM. FOUR
TO SEVEN ADDITIONAL POWER
PRACTICES THAT WE WILL WE WILL
BE ALIGNING TO WITH CTE OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS THESE
WITH OUR OVERALL EIGHTY
PORTFOLIO AND PROJECTS ONGOING
INCLUDING THE ONES THAT WAS
JUST- ALLUDED TO BY. BETSY WITH
THE CBC AND OTHER AREAS AS WE
CONTINUE TO MATURE THESE
PROCESSES. I AM HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS IN REGARDS TO THE
- THANK YOU MISTER WHITE LET'S
HEAR THE FINAL PROPOSAL WHICH IS
A REQUEST FOR THIRTY NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION IN THE GENERAL
FUND TO WAIVE DOCUMENT FILING
FEES. ON A ONE TIME BASIS FOR
ALL NEW BUSINESS REGISTERING
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE E
WILL HEAR FROM FINANCE ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON TEN WEBER DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. AT THE BUDGET
INCLUDES THIRTY NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TWO WAY FIRST TIME FILING
FEES FOR NEW BUSINESSES
REGISTERING WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO
ENCOURAGE BUSINESS GROWTH. AND
FOR CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES. AT
THE WAY BY THE DEPARTMENT
PARTNERSHIPS LLCS AND
CORPORATIONS. I REQUEST ALSO
INCLUDES BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
WHICH SPECIFIED THAT MONEY MUST
BE SPENT ON READING OF THESE
SPECIFIC FEES. AT THE NOW TO
COULD POTENTIALLY BE INCREASE
MORE BUSINESSES THAN ANTICIPATED
FILE. AND CIGARETTES HM REPORT
ON THE FINAL AMOUNT OF WEIGHT
HE'S- ENDORSED BONTA WE REVIEWED
ELLIOTT'S COMMENTS ON THIS AND I
WANT TO SAY THAT ALTHOUGH THE
FIVE P. MOUNTS ARE RELATIVELY
SMALL IT'S THE ONLY A POINT GOT
INTERVIEWED. PROPOSAL IT WAS THE
WIND IS BOTH IMPORTANT. AT THE
MAYBE CALIFORNIA DIVIDE ABOUT
GREEN BUSINESS BUT HAVEN'T DONE
SO YET THIS COULD BE THE
CURTAIN. FIRST STEP INTO ITSELF.
AND ALSO THE MINISTRATION PLEASE
IMPORTANCE FOR BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S FUNNY
PROJECTED POSITIVE IMPACT
THOUSANDS BUSINESSES. HAPPY
ANTHONY CORDESMAN PROPOSAL AND
HEALTHCARE IS A GREAT STATE IF
THERE'S SPECIFIC. QUESTIONS WE
CAN'T ANSWER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT WE'RE GONNA OPEN IT
UP FOR. I DO HAVE ONE TO THE-
TO. THIS LAW FINAL PROPOSAL CAN
THE SECRETARY OF STATE PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THE HOW.
AND HOW THE THIRTY NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION FIGURE. WAS
DEVELOPED. AND I CAN ACTUALLY
ANSWER THAT ONE CHIPPER
DEPARTMENT FINANCE WE DID WORK
WITH THE SECRETARYOF STATE TO
GET THEIR NAME TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE WE CAN
PROVIDE A BACK. AT YOUR HOURS IF
NECESSARY BUT- WE LOOK AT THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS- AN AVERAGE
THE GROWTH TO GET THE NUMBER.
THANK YOU AB BEFORE WE MOVE ON
CAN WE HEAR COMMENTS FROM THE
LA- PLEASE. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS NICK SCHROEDER FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
YEAH JANET OUTLINES THE COMMENTS
THAT WE HAVE SOLDIERS. I LIKE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MAKE
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WERE. UP PROPOSAL
BECAUSE WE DON'T THINK THAT- THE
PROPOSAL MEANINGFULLY. STIMULATE
BUSINESS GROWTH IN STATE. ON
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN- GROWTH IN
. ASIAN YOUR BUSINESS AND WE
DON'T THINK THIS WILL MEAN FOR
THE FACT THAT GROWTH I'M GOING
IF THE LEGISLATURE DOES- APPROVE
THE REQUEST WE DO RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MODIFY THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO MAKE IT
MORE EXPLICIT AS FAR AS WHICH
FEES ARE BEING WAVED AND TO
ACTUALLY- CITE THE SECTIONS OF
CODE THAT ARE PLEASE WAIT FOR.
SOMEONE IN THE THING THAT WE
RECOMMEND IS THAT THE- BUSINESS
FILING FUND HE- THE REVIEWED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION THINK THAT.
WITH THE CAMERA BUSINESS
CONNECT- HAVING ITS LAST MODUL
GOING TO AFFECT NOW STILL SECTOR
STATE LIKELY WON'T KNOW FOR THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS WHAT IT'S
RESOURCE NEEDS ARE URGENT
BECAUSE THE BUSINESS CONNECT
WILL DRAMATICALLY CHANGE ITS
OPERATIONS- BUT ONCE IT IS
KNOWN- WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT. MINISTRATION
REVIEW THE FINDINGS LUNACY
LEVELS AND RESERVE REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE- HISTORICALLY IT SEEMS
THAT THE FEE LEVELS ARE FAR
HIGHER THAN THEY NEED TO BE. ON
THE BUSINESSES. THANK YOU MISTER
SCHROEDER MY LUCKY. YEAH I WOULD
NOT. I DON'T REALLY HAVE A
QUESTION I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT THE L. A.
ALWAYS JUST IDENTIFIED- THAT WE
REJECTED PROPOSAL NUMBER OF
OTHER LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
AND- AS AS NOTED IN THE NOTES
THAT- THE HUNDRED OR SEVENTY
DOLLAR FEE IS UNLIKELY NOT MUCH
CONSIDERATION TO A PROSPECTIVE
BUSINESS OPERATOR GIVEN THE
OTHER MUCH HIGHER COSTS TO DO
BUSINESS IN THE STATE. EVERY BIT
OF THE STATEMENT IS TRUE. AND
FOR THE HIGHLIGHTS THE
UNFRIENDLY CLIMATE THE STATE HAS
TOWARDS THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
WELL THIS PANDEMIC HAS PUT A
SPOTLIGHT ON TEMPORARY FIXES
BEIT WAVING THE EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLAR MINIMUM. FRANCHISE TAX-
LET ME OF ONE TIME CREDITS THE
LONGSTANDING POLICIES OF THE
STATE. IS TO TAKE TOO MANY BITES
OF THE APPLE WHEN IT COMES TO
TAXES AND FEES ON BUSINESS. NO
MATTER THE AMOUNT ANY FEES OR
TAXES THAT COULD BE REDUCED ARE
DESPERATELY NEEDED AND I SUPPORT
THOSE. THAT'S IT. THANK YOU
MISTER LUCKY WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE OF
NINETEEN LET'S MOVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
FOR THE FIRST PANEL WE WILL HEAR
TWO BUDGET PROPOSALS RELATED TO
THE- BREE EASE SYSTEM. AND TCA'S
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PLAN.
LET'S HAVE A DC 18% THEIR I. T.
PROPOSAL. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
CARILLO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JACOB
COUNTY CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. IT INTRODUCED THE TWO
BCPS THAT REQUEST FUNDING
SUPPORT SOFTWARE MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATION RECOGNITION THAT THE-
BURKE. THE PEOPLE OPERATE THAT
MAKE THAT THE CREDIT CARD
FUNDING REQUEST WILL TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION YEAH TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING. RECESS
FROM FRIDAY STATE HUNDRED AND
TEN TWENTY SIXTEEN HAVE BEEN
INTIMATED AND OPERATION. THAT
SUPPORTING THE BUSINESS. EIGHT
HE'S A PROGRAM. WHAT IT REPORT
BY STATE STAFF UP THE FOR
CONTINUE CAN HIRE HIS VALUE
ANOTHER YEAR FIGURES WITH YOUR
MASS OR MAYBE COULD SPEAK INTO
YOUR MICRO YOU STILL MUFFLED IN
A LITTLE FAR AWAY. WORK. BETTER. YES I THINK WE'RE JUST GOING
TO ASK IF YOU CAN PROJECT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THIS FUNDING
WILL COVER COST CENTERS
IDENTIFIED ITS ONGOING COST
INCREASE IF YOU IF YOU REQUEST
PUTTING FUNDING FOR STATE IT
STAFF SALARIES AND BENEFITS FOR
ANY PERHAPS DEVELOPMENT SOFTWARE
AND HARDWARE FONG. THE FUNDING
REQUEST IN THE BCP BRIEF SUPPORT
REPRESENTS THE BASELINE FOX THE
DEPARTMENT. TO SUPPORT NORMAL
MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS MOVING
FORWARD. UP A TWELVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS REFLECTED FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ROUGHLY A THIRD OF THE REQUEST.
WILL BE ALLOCATED TO PAY FOR
PROPERTY FEES ON BEHALF OF
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES. ONLINE
USING A CREDIT CARD. THE SECOND
BCP REQUEST ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE FIRST FULL YEAR OF
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS FOR
THE CONNECT. WHICH IS UTILIZED
BY FOR DCA PROGRAM. THIS PROJECT
AT DELIVERED FIVE MAJOR SOFTWARE
RELEASES AND PROJECTS STARTING
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY. THAT
ALLOW THE FORTY C. PROGRAMS
LICENSE AND APPLICANTS TO SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS ONLINE REMEDIATE
ANY APPLICATION DEFICIENCIES
ONLINE AND RECEIVE EMAIL AND
TEXT MESSAGE ALERT RELEVANT TO
THEIR PENDING. APPLICATION FOR
LICENSE STATUS. THIS SYSTEM ALL
ALLOW FOR THE- PROCESS UP TO
WORK. AMONG OTHER FEATURES. THE
PROJECT IS DELIVERY SYSTEM
FUNCTIONALITY I'M SORRY THE
PROJECT IS SCHEDULED TO COMPLETE
IN LATE APRIL BUT BECAUSE OF THE
INCREMENTAL APPROACH THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN BEFORE PROGRAMS
INCLUDED IN THE PROJECT ALREADY
BEEN HIGH UTILIZATION OF THE
SYSTEM. THE FIRST MAJOR SOFTWARE
RELEASE IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR PROGRAMS THAT
PROCESS OVER TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONLINE TRANSACTIONS.
AND OVER 90% OF THE OVERALL
PAYMENTS MADE IN THE NEW. RPF
ONLINE CREDIT CARD. YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED TO
REQUEST. AND MYSELF AND MY
COLLEAGUE JOHN O'CONNOR ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE- THANK YOU FOR THAT DO
WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE L.
L. INTERNAL DEPARTMENT FINANCE
THE REQUESTED RESOURCES ALLOW DC
TO EFFECTIVELY. AND EFFICIENTLY
SUPPORT BREEZE AND THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION QUARKS ONES
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS. THE
PROPOSAL ARE CONSISTENT WITH
INVESTMENT FROM PREVIOUS BUDGET
AX AND SUPPORT FUNDING FOR
EXISTING POSITIONS ONGOING
SOFTWARE COSTS AND IT COSTS THAT
WILL ALLOW PROGRAMS. TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO THE PUBLIC
AND LICENSE FEES RELY ON. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU L. L. THE
COMPUTERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M UP WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS WE NOTE THAT
THREE AT THE SPECIAL FUNDS
INCLUDED IN THESE TWO PROPOSALS
ARE PROJECTED TO BECOME
INSOLVENT WITHIN THE NEXT TWO TO
THREE YEARS- I'M SPECIFICALLY
THESE FUNDS ARE THE CONTINGENT
FIND OUT THE MEDICAL BOARD. THE
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATION FIND AND THE
STATE BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC
EXAMINERS AND THE INITIATION IS
PLANNING TO SEEK THE INCREASES
TO SUPPORT THESE FUNDS THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THIS
YEAR WHICH IS COMMON PRACTICE.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED
EXPENDITURES FROM THE FUNDS THAT
WE RECOMMEND ADOPTING
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR SUFFICIENT
REVENUE IN THE RESPECTIVE FUNDS
TO PAY FOR THESE ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURES SPECIFICALLY FOR
EACH APPROVED EXPENDITURE WE
RECOMMEND SPECIFYING THAT THE
ASSOCIATED FUNDING IS AVAILABLE
ONLY IF LEGISLATION IS ENACTED
IN THE CURRENT SESSION TO
INCREASE EASTER SUFFICIENT LEVEL
TO SEPARATE THE EXPENDITURES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION B. C. P. REQUEST
ONE TIME FUNDING TO COVER CREDIT
CARD PROCESSING FEES WELL THE CA
BOARD IN BUREAUS CONTINUE TO
ABSORB CREDIT CARD PROCESSING
FEES IN THE FUTURE OR WILL TO
SEE EVENTUALLY PASSED THE COST
DOWN. TO APPLICANTS AND
LICENSEES. DCA THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION- CHECK THREE UP.
BC IS PROVIDING AN OPTION UP
REPORT. AND THEY LEFT THE PATH
ON THE CREDIT CARD TO BE NEED TO
BE FOR THE APPLICANTS LIKE THAT
THE- EPA AND IT IS IN THE
PLANNING STAGES OF THE
TRANSITION AT CONTRACTING TO BE
AMENDED. AND IT PROGRAMMING IF
NECESSARY TO SUPPORTING PROGRAM
WHICH TRANSACTION. PROGRAM TO
FIGHT THE TRANSITION A PATH ON
THE CREDIT CARD BEING ITS SPEED
AT THE TIME OF EMPLOYMENT
PATIENTS. THE PROGRAM BUDGET
WILL BE REDUCED ACCORDINGLY AT
ANY APPROPRIATIONS BOARD
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED. SUPPORT
CREDIT CARD BEING ISSUED PAYMENT
WOULD NO LONGER BE. NEEDED BY
THE PROGRAM. THANK THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS. IF NOT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
EVERYONE ON THE PANEL WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX- I'M SORRY. OKAY ARE GOOD
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
EIGHT BCPS RELATED TO SUPPORTING
WORKLOAD FOR VARIOUS REGULATORY
BOARDS AND BUREAUS UNDER DCA A
LET'S HEAR FROM AT MISTER
TAYLOR'S SHTICK IF WE CAN HAVE
YOU BRIEFLY PERCENT THE REQUEST
INCLUDED IN THE BOARD IN BUREAUS
FOR PC PIECE. REPORTER WHEN
AROUND RIGHT GOOD MORNING OR
GOOD AFTERNOON YEAH RUBIO. AND
FELLOW MEMBERS MY NAME THAT THEY
WISH THAT I AM THE FISCAL
OFFICER FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EUROPE THERE'S- I WILL BE
INTRODUCING THE PROPOSALS
OUTLINED UNDER DISPUTE THAT. AND
IT'S UNDERSTOOD THAT. FIRST UP
THE DEPARTMENT AS WE- A PER BY
THE CONSOLE. WHAT PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD IMPLEMENT TO PREVENT OF
FOURTEEN PIECE OF THE POLITICAL
. THAT WERE CAPTURED LAST BEST.
THE PROPOSAL INCORPORATES FROM
ELEVEN DIFFERENT FOURTEEN HEROES
AND DEPARTMENT AND TOTAL SEVEN
POINT TWO MILLION AND TWENTY
POSITION. IN ADDITION THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO REQUESTING
APPROVAL FOR SEVEN BOARD AND
YOU'RE A PROPOSAL AS FOLLOWS.
THE PORTABLE FROM THE STREET
REQUESTING HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
THOUSAND AND TWO POSITIONS
FINANCE CONSUMER PROTECTION BY
HELPING TO IMPROVE. ITS CLOSURE
TIME. THANK INDUCT CONTINUE
EDUCATION. THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
THE REQUESTED AMOUNT AT ONE TIME
FUNDING TO CONDUCT THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE STUDIES FOR THE
LICENSED PROFESSION ARTICLE LAND
AND CONTRACT WHEN SPENCER. AND
THE UNLICENSED PROFESSIONS
OPTOMETRIC ASSISTANT THE STUDY
IS NEEDED TO CLARIFY THE ACTUAL
PRACTICE AND PARAMETERS. BUT
NEXT UP WE HAVE THE OF PHARMACY
AND THEIR REQUEST READ AND FOUR
THOUSAND AND TWO POSITIONS
REDUCE OVERALL. PROCESS IN TIME
FOR TEMPORARY LICENSE
APPLICATION AND ADDRESS
INCREASED WORKLOAD FOR THE BOARD
TO MANAGE AND CONTROL I DID WHAT
. REPORTER REGISTERED IS
REQUESTING ONE POINT NINE
MILLION TO EXPAND LIMITS FOR
RESOURCES FRANCISCO TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL. AND INCREASED
LICENSING AND ENFORCEMENT
WORKLOAD AND TO FURTHER REDUCE
LICENSING TIME FRAME.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSAL WOULD
REDUCE THE POSITION OF AUTHORITY
RECEIVE THEM THAT 200-019-2060
590% THE DOUBLE ORDERS
REQUESTING. THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PROVISIONS OUTLINED IN
CHAPTER NINE NINE THAT'S WHAT
MAKES ME. THIS REQUIRED THE
COURT TO SPECIFY THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR INITIAL
PERMITTING AND CONTINUED
MAINTENANCE OF GENERAL
ANESTHESIA AND SEDATION BERMAN
INCLUDED IN THE FUNDING ACROSS
THE SUPPORT THE BILL STATED
MODIFICATION OR QUITE CONVINCED. THE DOUBLE FIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S. ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND AND ONE POSITION
TO SUPPORT CONTINUED EDUCATION
OTHER WORKLOADS A THREATENING
FIVE NONCOMPLIANCE RATE AND PART
OF THE DENTAL HAS BEEN. ZERO
HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND SERVICES- IS
REQUESTING SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND FOUR POSITIONS
THROUGHOUT THE BUREAU CAN PROVE
INVESTIGATIVE AND IT'S BOTH I'M
- AND IMPLEMENTING PROACTIVE
ENFORCEMENT APPROACH MANDATE AND
THAT'S TO. FIVE THE BUREAU POST
SECOND EDUCATION REQUIRED A
POINT FIVE. MILLION ADULTS THE
CAN TO THE OFFICE OF STUDENT
ATHLETES AND RELAY. AND THE
SECOND QUESTION RECOVERY ACTIVE. THE LAUNCH. THAT THE REMAINS
IN COMPLY WITH PROVISIONS OF
CHAPTER NINE THREE THAT COULD OF
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. AT THIS I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THAT THE IS
AWARE OF ONLY OKAY
RECOMMENDATION. BUT THAT'S STILL
WAITING FOR THAT WOULD MAKE THE
PROPOSAL COULD ON INCREASE. BUT
APART BELIEVES THE BEST WITH
CREATE WITH CORN I IF YOU THAT
COULD IMPACT CONSUMER PROTECTION
AT SEVERAL DIFFERENT. ARE THEM
THIS THING RESOURCES. IS RIGHT
NEXT AT THE END OF THE CALL
FISCAL YEAR AND SINCE INCREASE
WHAT WILL NOT BE. THE LATE. ONE
EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY. AND NOT
AFFECTED TENURE FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IT WOULD PROBABLY
GAPS AND HARPER RESOURCES WITH
BOTH THOSE FORTY ZERO ATTENTION
OPEN FROM AT. IN THE AREA. BUT
OUR LOOKS FORWARD TO WORK WITH
THE CAN STAFF CONTINUE BOOK BUT
AND WE'RE WORK WITH LITTLE.
THANK YOU YOUR KIND OF
CONSIDERATION OF THE PROPOSAL.
ARE WE HAVE REPRESENTED COMPETE
PROPOSED AT THE TANK ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS MAY HAVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MUCH OF. TO
YOU INTO A ON PANEL THUS FAR
WE'RE GONNA ON TO NEW SIX. THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET AND THREE C. P.
RELATED TO THE PART OF REAL
ESTATE. LET'S HAVE THE DEER YOU
TEAM A BROUGH OVERVIEW OF THEIR
REQUEST. MISTER ABILITY IN ARE
YOU WANT. I AM YOU VERY MUCH
MATTER CHAIR. SO GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
FUNDED. I'M THE SISTER
COMMISSIONER LEGISLATION AND
REGULATIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
REAL ESTATE. AND WE ARE PLEASED
TO PRESENT THREE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS TODAY. IN OUR FIRST
PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
I'M GOING. FROM THE REAL ESTATE
FUND FOR TO I. T. SPECIALIST
POSITIONS TO WORK ON INFORMATION
SECURITY ISSUES. REALLY THERE'S
ONLY ONE POSITION AT THE
DEPARTMENT THAT IS DEDICATED TO
INFORMATION SECURITY. THESE
ADDITIONAL PROPOSED POSITIONS
WILL HELP THE DEPARTMENT TO
IMPLEMENT AUDIT FINDINGS. FROM
OUR BIANNUAL CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT SECURITY GOT IT. THE
LAST AUDIT IDENTIFIED SECURITY
DEFICIENCIES WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WORKING TO
ADDRESS. THE CURRENT LACK
SUFFICIENT EXISTING RESOURCES TO
FULLY ADDRESS AND TIMELY MANNER.
THESE POSITIONS WILL HELP
PROTECT THE DEPARTMENT. I
DISTRICT ALL OF THE SYSTEMS FROM
CYBER CRIMINALS AND RANSOMWARE
ATTACKS. IN OUR SECOND PROPOSAL
DEPARTMENT REQUEST A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR I'M
GOING. FOR ONE PEOPLE I FOR
SENIOR MANAGEMENT OR AUDITOR
THIS WILL ESTABLISH A PERMANENT
INTERNAL AUDIT FUNCTION AT THE
DEPARTMENT. THIS POSITION WILL
HELP THE DEPARTMENT TO MEET
STATUTORY AND ADMINISTRATIVE
REQUIREMENTS REGARDING INTERNAL
AUDIT FUNCTIONS FOR STATE
AGENCIES WHICH SPEND MORE THAN
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY HAVE STAFF
ON LOAN FROM OTHER PROGRAM AREAS
TO COMPLETE THIS FUNCTION IN A
RECENTLY CREATED INTERNAL AUDIT
UNIT. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
MEETING IT WAS PROVIDES
INDEPENDENT AND OBJECTIVE
GUIDANCE TO MITIGATE RISK AND
IMPROVE OPERATIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT. IT IS RESPONSIBLE
PERFORMING INTERNAL AUDITS.
SPECIAL MANAGEMENT REVIEWS
EMPLOYEE INVESTIGATIONS AND
OTHER SPECIAL REQUESTS BY
EXECUTIVE MANAGEMENT. THE BUDGET
REQUEST WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT ADEQUATELY STAFFED A
PERMANENT INTERNAL AUDIT UNIT.
AND LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT
REQUEST RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
LEGISLATION PASSED INTO LAW LAST
YEAR. THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
SENATE BILL TWO SIX THREE BY
SENATOR RUBIO WHICH CALL FROM
FIFTY FIVE FOR HOUSING TO BE
INCORPORATED TO THE COURSES
REQUIRED FOR REAL ESTATE
SALESPERSON AND REAL ESTATE
BROKERS BOTH OF THOSE EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR INITIAL
LICENSURE. AND CONTINUING
EDUCATION. WE'RE REQUESTING TWO
ONE SIXTEEN THOUSAND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TO TWENTY
FOUR ONGOING. FOR TWO P. WEISS
IMPLEMENT THOSE CHANGES.-WORKABLE INCLUDE PROVIDING COURT
GUIDELINES FOR PRE LICENSURE IN
CONTINUING EDUCATION COURSES.
REVIEWING AND APPROVING NEW AND
MODIFIED INITIAL LICENSURE
COURSES. REVIEWING AND APPROVING
NEW AND MODIFIED CONTINUING
EDUCATION COURSES. AUDITING
COURSE MATERIALS AND EDUCATING
EDUCATION AND COMMUNICATION WITH
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC RIGHT OR SOME
OTHER TASKS. THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ENTER HOW
DEPARTMENT FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS COPY TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS L. L. WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
. THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE-
I APPRECIATE YOU MISSED PUBLIC
YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES TWO
BCPS FOR THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL. LET'S HAVE THE C. A. C.
TEAM PRESENTED ON THEIR TO BCPS
PLACE DO WE HAVE MISS. AND BROWN
CRAWFORD ON THE LINE. HELLO
THANK YOU WITH CHAIR AND- MANY
MEMBERS. ABOUT CRAWFORD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTING OUR
ABILITY TO DESIGNATE CULTURAL
DISTRICT IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
IN AB ONE EIGHTY NINE WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR
FOR VALUING THIS PROGRAM TO THE
EXTENT THAT HE INCLUDED IT IN
HIS PROPOSED BUDGET THIS YEAR.
WE'RE EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND OUR STATE'S COHORT OF
CULTURAL DISTRICTS. WE'RE ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR THE VALUE HE'S PUT
ON OUR CALIFORNIA POET LAUREATE
. AND THE YOUTH POET LAUREATE I
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR. THIS IN
HIS PROPOSED BUDGET AS WELL. OUR
COUNCIL PROHIBITED DURING THE
PANDEMIC TO ADDRESS THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON OUR ARTS
COMMUNITY STATEWIDE. THIS PIVOT
INCLUDES A PRIORITIZATION ON
RACIAL EQUITY WHICH WE
RECOGNIZED AS A PERVASIVE AND
TRANSFORM OF INJUSTICE NOT JUST
TO THE ARTISTS WE SERVICE TO
EVERYONE. THE EXPANSION OF OUR
CULTURAL DISTRICTS PRIORITIZE
THE ECONOMIC INCLUSION OF BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND OTHER CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS OF COLOR FOCUSING ON
COMMUNITY BUILDING AND NURTURING
CULTURAL IDENTITY AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CITY
GOVERNMENT BUSINESS WHILE
PREVENTING DISPLACEMENT. THIS IS
WHAT WE DO THE C. A. C. THIS IS
OUR WORK. THE POET LAUREATE
PROGRAM IS A STATEWIDE
CELEBRATION OF HOW POETRY
AMPLIFIES VOICES THAT FRAME ALL
OF OUR CHALLENGES FOR JURIES ARE
GRIEF. CELEBRATION AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY RIGHT NOW HOPE. I'M
HERE WITH C. EIGHTY STAFF TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE ABOUT THE GROWTH AND
EXPANSION OF OUR CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS FROM A
COOPERATIVE THE FOURTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR AND- POETS LAUREATE
PROGRAM WHICH ALSO INCLUDES
POETRY OUT LOUD FOR PROGRAM THAT
INVOLVES STUDENTS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU MISS ABOUT
CRAWFORD I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- BUT BEFORE WE- I'LL
GO INTO THAT ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE ALEJO. MY WORK
PERMIT FINANCED NOTHING TO AT
THIS TIME. LOL DISTRIBUTORS ARE
LAID OUT AND WE DO HAVE SOME
COMMENTS ON THE CULTURAL
DISTRICTS PROPOSAL IN PARTICULAR
AND SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING
I AM A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THE CULTURAL
DISTRICTS PROGRAM THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS I'M FOR THIS PROGRAM I'M
WHICH WAS THERE'S A LADY TO BY
THE ARTS COUNCIL WAS ESTABLISHED
BY THE LEGISLATURE TO CREATE
THESE DISTRICTS AND HAS BEEN A
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY I'M IN THE
PAST HOWEVER WE FIND THAT THERE
ARE CERTAIN KEY DETAILS FROM THE
PROPOSAL THAT ARE LACKING OF FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE IF ON THE PROPOSAL.
AND HOW THE FUNDS TO BE SPENT
REALLY ALIGNED WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES FOR THE PROGRAM I'M
IN PARTICULAR AT THE ARTS
COUNCIL HAS NOT PROVIDED
INFORMATION ON HOW THE FUNDS
WOULD BE ALLOCATED BETWEEN
EXISTING DISTRICTS AND NEW
DISTRICTS I'M THE AND
COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF ALLOWABLE
USES AT THE FANS THE CRATER
ANYWAY USED TO AWARD GRANTS-
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM NOW WHAT-
MEASURABLE GOALS OR OUTCOMES
WOULD BE THOUGHT BY THAT
CONVERTS ON HOW THOSE TO BE. DIE
COUNCIL HAS IN THAT MORTGAGE ON
THE PROPOSAL WOULD BE AVAILABLE
LATER IN THE BUDGET PROCESS THIS
SPRING- WE FIND THAT WITHOUT%
THESE DETAILS IT'S NOT POSSIBLE
TO DETERMINE THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THE PROPOSED SPENDING WAY TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS ABOUT HAVE BEEN
RAISED IN A STUDY OF THIS PILOT
PROGRAM ABOUT A LACK OF
DIVERSITY OF CULTURAL DISTRICTS.
AND TO WHAT EXTENT DO YOU
PROPOSE FUNDING WHAT LINE WITH
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES ARE BEING
APPROPRIATE FOR ONE TIME USE A
ONE TIME FRIENDS AND SO WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WITH FULL ACTION ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND STILL
GOT THIS INFORMATION IS PROVIDED
SOTHAT YOU. CAN PROP MORE
PROPERLY A PATH. THE PROPOSAL.
IN ITS ENTIRETY THANK YOU. THANK
MISTRANSLATED EIGHT THAT I WOULD
HAVE TO THAT I WITH YOUR-
INCLUDE ACTUALLY I FEEL THE SAME
WAY MESS UP ABOUT CRAWFORD I
HEARD YOU SAY BLACK INDIGENOUS
AND OTHER WHEN YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT DOING YOUR PUBLIC OUTRAGE.
I WILL I WILL SAY THIS- WE HAVE
AN INITIATIVE BOTH AND IN THE
LATINO CAUCUS CALLED THE UNSEEN
AT THE NINE ISSUED OF. LATINOS
LATINAS THE LEAD NEXT COMMUNITY
IS THE LARGEST COMMUNITY AT THE
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD JUST ADVISE
THAT IT'S COMPLETELY OKAY TO SAY
THAT THE NON. LET THE NOT LET
NEXT AND NOT JUST SIMPLY LUMP IT
INTO OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR- WITH
THAT SAID HOW WILL THE C. A. C.
ENSURE THAT CULTURAL DISTRICTS
ARE INCLUSIVE CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE COMMUNITY WHAT IS YOUR
PUBLIC OUTREACH PLAN. FOR PUBLIC
OUTREACH PLAN IS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CREATIVE CORE. WE ARE
PLAN FIRST AND FOREMOST TO
GATHER AT THE FOURTEEN- MEMBERS
OF THE ORIGINAL COHORT TOGETHER.
TO REALLY. SEE IF THEY CAN
ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS WHERE.
WHAT WHAT ARE THEIR NEEDS
CURRENTLY WHAT ARE THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY EXPERIENCED
WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES AND SEE
GOING FORWARD WHERE THE
SUCCESSES. AND THEN DO WHAT WE
ARE DOING. WITH CREATE A CORD IT
MENTIONED AND HOW REGIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES FROM REGIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FOR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TO COME TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEY SEE. HE'S DISTRICTS
WHAT'S WHAT SERVICE THEY SEE
THESE DISTRICTS ARE SERVING-
THIS IS BECOME A VERY. EFFECTIVE
WAY OF DEVELOPING THE GUIDELINES
FOR THE CREATIVE CORE. WE REALLY
HEARD FROM PEOPLE THAT HAVE
THEIR FEET BOTH FEET IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY NEED AND BEFORE WE CAN DO
THAT WE CAN'T REALLY DO A TOP
DOWN ASSESSMENT- WELL THIS
COMMUNITY AND EXISTENCE
COMMUNITY NEEDS AS INTEL WE
ACTUALLY DO INAPPROPRIATE FEEL
SCANNED AND LISTEN. CAREFULLY SO
I REPRESENT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES L. A. COUNTY BEING THE
BIGGEST COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT IS THE OUR TO
PLAN FOR L. A. COUNTY. SO L. L.
A. COUNTY THE OUTRAGE PLAN WOULD
BE THAT WE WOULD HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES. FROM THAT
COUNTY FROM THAT DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES IN THAT COUNTY. YEP
WHAT COME TO A COMMUNITY PANEL.
AND AS REPRESENTATIVE OF THAT
COMMUNITY. TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
NEEDS ARE WHAT THEY THINK THE
BENEFIT OF A CULTURAL DISTRICTS
WOULD BE IN THEIR COMMUNITY BUT
WHO ARE YOUR PARTNERS ON THE
GROUND SPECIFICALLY. OUR
PARTNERS ON THE GROUND WE HAVE
STATEWIDE PARTNERS WE HAVE STATE
LOCAL PARTNERS IN EVERY COUNTY.
SO I'M ASKING SPECIFICALLY FOR
L. A. COUNTY WHO ARE YOUR L. A.
COUNTY PARTNERS TO DO PUBLIC
OUTREACH. FOR THIS PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY BEING THE LARGEST IN
THE STATE. AT THIS POINT IN TIME
OUR OUR- BEST AND STRONGEST
PARTNER THERE IS THE- THAT
COUNTY- DEPARTMENT OF ARTS AND
CULTURE HEADED UP BY CHRISTMAS
THE CODE SHE'S ALSO ONE OF OUR
STATE LOCAL PARTNERS FOR THE
ARTS COUNCIL. I ASK THIS
QUESTION BECAUSE I FEEL WE'VE
WE'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
BEFORE IN TERMS OF. WHAT IS THE
ACTUAL ON THE GROUND APPLICATION
FOR PUBLIC OUTREACH FOR PEOPLE
OF COLOR LOOK LIKE. WHEN IT'S-ACTUALLY BEING IMPLEMENTED AND
WHO GETS TO HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
RESOURCES. DO YOU HAVE A
BREAKDOWN OF WHAT HAS BEEN DONE
IN THE PAST IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
BEEN FUNDED. AND WHAT THAT OUT
REACH ACTUALLY LOOKS UP. YES WE
DO HAVE A BREAKDOWN OF WHAT'S
BEEN DONE IN THE PAST AND WHAT
THAT OUTRAGE LOOKS LIKE AND HOW
WE HOPE TO EXPAND IT. AND I'D BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOUR STAFF TO PROVIDE THAT DATA
TO. BY WHEN DO YOU THINK YOU
MIGHT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
DATA. I'M NOT TOO SURE- MOST
LIKELY WITHIN A COUPLE OF WEEKS. OKAY WELL YOU ARE EXPECTING
THIS FUNDING PROPOSAL TO MOVE
FORWARD CORRECT. YES WE ARE OKAY
I AND I AND I SAY THIS IN THE IN
THE BEST INTENTION OF I LOVE THE
ARTS I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE FUNDS THAT ARE GOING
TOWARDS. HELPING COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE ACCESS
TO RESOURCES ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING TO THOSE COMMUNITIES SO
IT IS VERY CRITICAL TO ME TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT IN THE COUNTIES
THAT YOU ARE WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP. YOU HAVE FOLKS ON
THE GROUND THAT UNDERSTAND THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THAT OUT
REACH EFFORTS. THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING THEY'RE NOT GOING TO THE
SAME. YOU KNOW RESOURCES AS THEY
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN BUT THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY A PLAN AND
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU DIRECTLY. BUT WE WILL GET
YOU THAT INFORMATION OF HOW WE
ARE CURRENTLY DOING THAT. EXPECT
TO DO THAT IN THE FUTURE. AND
WHAT WILL BE YOUR YOUR
DETERMINING FACTOR OR MEASURE OF
SUCCESS. OUR MEASURE OF SUCCESS
RIGHT. IN IN OUR MINDS WOULD BE
THE HEALTH OF THAT PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN CITY. AND CITY
GOVERNMENT BUSINESS PARTNERS.
AND THE COMMUNITY OF ARTISTS
THAT ARE IN ANY PARTICULAR PLACE
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF. LITTLE
DISTRICTS RIGHT NOW THAT
DEMONSTRATE BEST PRACTICES AND
SHOW US WHAT THAT IS SO MUCH
FILIPINOS IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
MARIO LOGAN IN SAN DIEGO. THERE
WE HAVE COMMITTED CALLED JUST
THAT EACH STEP THESE PRACTICES
CURRENTLY AND WE CAN LOOK
CAREFULLY AT THOSE WITH. THANK
YOU THAT'S THAT'S EXACTLY WHY
I'M ASKING LIKE WHAT WHEN YOU
SAY YOU'RE GOING TO LOOK
CAREFULLY AT THOSE PROPOSALS
AYE. I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE ALSO PROPOSALS THAT ARE
REFLECTIVE OF THE DIVERSITY OF
THE COMMUNITY THE REFLECTIVE OF
THE DIVERSITY OF THE STATE. AND
LASTLY I WILL ASK YOU WHAT IS
THE C. A. C. DOING TO INSURE
THAT UNDERREPRESENTED ARTS
COLLECTIVES CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE PROPOSED PROGRAM. SO THAT
. TO IT TO ENSURE THAT IS
GREATLY AS POSSIBLE WOULD BE
MAKE SURE THAT OUR OUTREACH IS
EXTENDED THROUGH OUR REGIONAL
PARTNERS THE PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY LIVE IN THE REGIONS
THAT WERE TRYING TO. GET INTO
AND THEIR WEALTH. REGIONS ARE
THE GAPS IN OUR CURRENT COHORT-
WELL IDENTIFIED BY THE- REPORT
AND THE EVALUATION THAT WE HAVE
DONE. AND THAT CAN BE DONE.
THROUGH PARTNERSHIP WITH OTHER
WE HAVE MANY OTHER COMMUNITY
ARTS PARTNERS THAT ARE. EMBEDDED
INSIDE OF EVERY COUNTY. IF I CAN
INTERJECT MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO ADD THAT YOU KNOW WE DO
HAVE CULTURAL DISTRICTS IN AN
LOS ANGELES LITTLE TOKYO WE
WOULD CERTAINLY PARTNER WITH
ENTITIES SUCH AS YOU KNOW.
POSITIVE RAZA AND LATINO ARTS
NETWORK WITH NORTH NETWORK WE
WORK WITH FOR DECADES AND
DECADES- AND SO- YOU KNOW THESE
ARE PARTNERS THAT WE COULD
ALWAYS BRING TO THE TABLE- OUR
PLAN IS TO HAVE A LISTENING TOUR
AND THIS IS HOW WE STARTED IN
THE PAST- IT IT'S ABOUT REALLY
KIND OF OPENING THE DOOR OR AND
BRING EVERYBODY TO THE TABLE AND
SO. WE UNDERSTAND- WHERE THEY
NEED IT UP RIGHT IF THAT DOES
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME IT
TAKES TIME FOR US TO GET INTO
THE COMMUNITY AND HAVE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE TO CABLE LIKE WE SAID-
AND SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENT- WE ALSO WILL BE YOU
KNOW REACHING OUT TO BUSINESSES
AS WELL BECAUSE- WE HAVE TO
START WITH EVERYBODY AT THE
TABLE BECAUSE OF COURSE WE'RE
TRYING TO AVOID. SITUATIONS THAT
INVOLVE GENTRIFICATION- WE HAD A
GREAT EXAMPLES OF BEST PRACTICES
BUDGET BARTLE- AND SO WE WOULD
CERTAINLY HIGHLIGHT. THOSE
PRACTICES. AND ONE OTHER THING
IF I COULD HAVE MET OF CHAIRS.
PLAY ON I JUMP IN AND DO SHARE
THAT. IT IS IT'S TIME. WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING I THINK REALLY
REST WITH ALL THIS. BY THE WAY
I'M ON THE KEYBOARD AND DEPUTY
TO STACY PART OF WHAT WE'VE DONE
ALREADY THE COUNCIL HAS BEEN.
COMPLICIT IF PUTTING TOGETHER A
RESPECTIVE REQUIRE SO WE A QUITE
. FOR PROGRAM PROGRAMS. IT'S A
RACE EFFORT ACT RIGHT HERE WHERE
THEY WHERE APPLE MY DEMONSTRATE
NOT NOT YEAH. THEY HAVE
PARTNERSHIPS BUT HOW THE
PARTNERS HAVE A RACIAL IT'S LAND
HOW THEY'RE ACTIVELY ENGAGED.
COMMUNITIES EITHER THEY ARE OF
THE- WHERE THE THAT THEY SERVE
THEY HAVE TO. HOW THEY DO THAT
AND THEY TO DEMONSTRATE HOW
THEIR IN COURT. A RACE EQUITY IN
THE- FOR FOUND. WE WILL KEEP
THAT MY- THAT WOULD BE ONE OF
THE GREAT. ONE OF OUR MANAGERS
FOR. I WANTED CRITERIA WITH. FOR
ALL OF THE APPLE. AND I THINK
THE OTHER. TO READ TO MAKING
SURE THERE'S- ACCESSIBILITY WE
ALSO HAVE AN ACCESSIBILITY
CRITERIA. THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
USING AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THIS- ACCESSIBILITY FOR PEOPLE
WITH DIFFERENT ABILITIES. IT'S
ABOUT WHAT MODEL. HAVE YOU USE
TO INCORPORATE MARKETING. WHAT
ARE YOU USING TO GET- THE
DIFFERENT VARIOUS COMMUNITIES
THAT VARIOUS DIFFERENT AREAS OF
THE COMMUNITIES. AWARE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
OFTEN. USE THE SAME MODES OF
GETTING THE MESSAGE OUT AND YOU
GET THE THING PEOPLE ALWAYS THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE BALL THAT
HAVE THE ACCESS. THAT HAVE THE
BROADBAND THAT HAVE THE ACCESS
TO. THE EMAIL THAT WAS SENT OUT
AND SO WE DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN SO WE HAVE THOSE TWO
CRITERIA. STANDARD GRANT
PROGRAMS AND IT CERTAINLY WOULD
BE INCORPORATED IN THIS ONE AND
THEN IN ADDITION TO THE CULTURAL
DISTRICT. WE HEY EXPANDING. WE
WANT TO KNOW HOW ENGAGING WANT
TO KNOW. THAT ACTUALLY A WAY
THAT THEY ARE. ALL ASPECTS OF
THE COMMUTE. WE WOULD FIRST BE
LOOKING FOR VALUE- THAT WOULD
AND RECOMMENDED. FROM
INDIVIDUALS AND VARIOUS AREAS.
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT WITH THAT ON
OUR COMMUNITY PANEL AND WE WOULD
HAVE OPENED FORMA DISCUSSION OF
WHAT ARE THE ISSUES. YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES A CUT THE IDEA OF THE
PUBLIC DISTRICT THAT'S ONE THING
BUT HOW IT'S ACTUALLY BEEN.
IMPACTING THE COMMUNITY AS A
MATTER SO WE WANT. TO KNOW THAT
FROM THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS. I
WOULD ADD. TO OTHER CREDIT. THE
ENGAGEMENT AS WELL AS IS THAT
PARTNERSHIP REALLY FUNCTIONING.
WHEN WE ORIGINALLY ROLLED OUT
THE PILOT OF THE CULTURAL
DISTRICT WE DIDN'T JUST DO AN
APPLICATION WE DID AND LETTER OF
INTENT. THEY DID AN APPLICATION
AND THEN WE DID A SITE VISIT.
AND WILL BE WITH THE OTHER
FACTOR THAT WE FOUND OUT THAT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
INDICATED IN THE APPLICATION
ONE. IMPLEMENTED IN REAL
RELATIONSHIP AND SO IN THIS CASE
IF WE DO THE SAME THING. THAT
THEY DO THE APPLICATION THEY
WOULD HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE. AND
SHOW LETTERS OF. PARTNERSHIP BUT
ALSO THAT WE HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE
AND PROVE THAT. THROUGH WITH.
THE CROSS. I THINK WE LEARNED A
LOT IN THE- BUT WE WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE IN OUR- OUT OF THIS. I
WANT. TO EXPAND OUR PARTNERSHIP
AND I DO WANT TO GET ONE MORE
CHECK BACK APPLE TO. ONE OTHER
THING WHEN WE FIRST ROLLED OUT
THE PA. WE DO NOT HAVE GOOD.
ACROSS THE STATE. THERE WERE-
THERE WERE SOME. GROUP THAT WERE
NOT RIGHT. IN OUR TOOK A- AND I
REGIONAL. AND WE HAD BACK. AND
ROLLED OUT A- OP. FOR THAT WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD MORE
DIVERSITY AND I CAN'T JUST FOR
THE FOURTEEN THAT'S A VERY SMALL
GROUP BUT WE USED OUR OWN. THEIR
OWN OPERATING MONEY TO DO IT.
YES TO HAVE DESIGNATED FUD
CONTROVERSY FOR THE FIRST PILOT.
AND WE WILL DEFINITELY TAPPED.
THEM TO HELP US DEVELOP THE
GUIDELINES FOR THE NEXT. FOR THE
NEXT AS AN EXPANSION. THANK AND
ALSO AND IT. IN TERMS OF THE-
YOU WITH INFORMATION- WE CAN DO
THAT RIGHT. WE CAN PROVIDE YOU
WITH INFORMATION ON. HOW WE ROLL
THIS OUT THE LAST TIME- AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REACHED OUT
TO YOU. ON THE OTHER COMPONENT
OF THIS THAT WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
IS THE IDEA OF HAVING. THESE
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS BECAUSE WHAT WE FOUND IS
ON THE LAST ROUND. THERE WERE
DISTRICTS THAT JUST WERE QUITE
READY YET. AND MAYBE GET THAT
SUPPORT. AND MOST OF THOSE WERE
FOLKS THAT WERE IN THESE.
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE NOT HAD
ANY SUPPORT THERE'D CERTAINLY
UNDERREPRESENTED. AND SO THAT'S
WHERE OUR FOCUS WILL BE GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU AND YOU ARE
MISS KRISTEN MARGOLICK. THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ARTS
COUNCIL THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
WANNA THANK YOU MISS CAN BURY
FOR THE VERY DETAILED
EXPLANATION AS TO THE PLANNING
PROCESS REALLY APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THAT VERY DISTINCT LANDS- IN
THIS CONVERSATION ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE IS A VERY DIRECT
PLAN. FOR A PUBLIC OUTREACH THAT
WILL DETERMINE THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF FUTURE CULTURAL DISTRICTS AND
THE CONVERSATION ON INCLUSIVITY
AND EQUITY NEEDS TO BE A PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION ONE LAST FINAL
QUESTION IN TERMS OF HOW WE CAN
BE SUPPORTED THE LEGISLATION CAN
BE SUPPORTIVE. THE C. A. C.
CURRENTLY HAS TWENTY THREE
AUTHORIZED POSITION POSITIONS
DOES THE COUNCIL HAVE ENOUGH
PERSONNEL TO BE ABLE TO
ADMINISTER SUCH A SIZEABLE
PROGRAMMING PLAN. SO WE DO HAVE
WE HAVE TWENTY THREE POSITIONS
THAT SUPPORT. OUR CURRENT- BASED
FUNDING. AND WE WOULD. I THINK
WE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS IN ORDER
TO SUPPORT. THIS LARGE EXPANSION
OF THE COVERT. AND IF I COULD
GET IF I COULD JUST VERIFY WE
ARE TINY AGENCY BUT WE HAVE BIG
DURING THAT WE DO BIG WERE AND
ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THE POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE THAT
WE HAVE I'M SORRY ALL OF THE-
POSITIONS ALREADY THAT WE HAVE
WE ARE LOOKING. AND HOPING FOR
SUPPORT TO TAKE SOME OF THAT
FUNDING TO ALLOCATE FOR LIMITED
TERM POSITION WE JUST DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH STAFF TO TAKE ON AND DO
THE REGULAR WORK AND MEET THE
GOALS OF OUR CURRENT PROGRAMMING
SO WE ARE LOOKING. TO SEE WHAT
WHAT WE CAN DO AND WHAT CAN BE
NEGOTIATED TO I'M SUPPORT
LIMITED TURN. THANK YOU FOR THAT
THAT SIX. WHAT I. WAS HOPING TO
BE ABLE TO GET SOME CLARITY ON
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT IT IS.
AN INCREDIBLE AND- POTENTIALLY
LIFE CHANGING OPPORTUNITY FOR SO
MANY COMMUNITIES WHO NEED ACCESS
TO THE ARTS INTO RESOURCES. I
KNOW MINE IS ONE OF THEM. LOS
ANGELES USED TO BE THE MURAL
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. A LOT OF
OUR MURALS IN MY COMMUNITY HAVE
BEEN WHITEWASHED DUE TO
GENTRIFICATION. SO I KNOW THIS
FIRST HAND WHICH IS WHY I'M
ASKING. SUCH DETAILED
INFORMATION AS TO THE PLANNING
OF HOW THIS IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE SO THE COMMUNITIES DON'T
LOSE- THE HISTORICAL ASPECT OF
WHAT MAKES A COMMUNITY A
COMMUNITY SO I. THANK YOU I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOU FOR THE DETAILED.
INFORMATION IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT- ISSUE. THE
GOVERNORS AND THANK YOU AGAIN TO
ALL THE PANELS AND THIS TO ALL
THE PANELISTS ON ISSUE EIGHT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
FOUR PCPS RELATED TO EXPOSITION
PARK. LET'S HAVE OUR PRESENTERS
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THEIR FOR BCPS STARTING WITH- I
BELIEVE MISS CAMERON SHOP. HELLO
EVERYONE. AND MY NAME IS CAMERON
SHAW I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA AFRICAN
AMERICAN MUSEUM. I CAM REQUESTS
THE AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH A
PERMANENT POSITION THAT FILLS A
CRITICAL ADMINISTRATIVE ROLE IN
THE DEPARTMENT REGARDING
PROCUREMENT FOR OUR MISSION
CRITICAL FUNCTIONS. THERE IS NO
INCREASE IN FUNDING REQUESTED
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THE REQUEST. THANK THANK
YOU FOR THAT- IS MISS
MINNESOTA'S PARCELLS ARE
PRESENTING. YES HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WHAT THE
OFFICE OF EXPOSITION PARK
MANAGEMENT HAS THREE BCPS THAT
WILL BE PRESENTED FOR
CONSIDERATION JUNE THE COMMITTEE
THE FIRST IS A BUDGET INCREASE
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY SO THE OFFICE
OF EXPOSITION PARK MANAGEMENT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ONGOING
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY INCREASE
OF EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO HELP
PARTICIPATED INCREASES AND
REMEMBER REIMBURSABLE PUBLIC
SAFETY EXPENSES ARISING FROM THE
OPENING OF THE LUCAS MUSEUM OF
NARRATIVE ART. AND INCREASED
ACTIVITY THROUGHOUT THE PARK THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
PROVIDES PUBLIC SAFETY SERVICES
TO OTHER ENTITIES ON A
REIMBURSABLE BASIS OF THIS WILL
ALIGN WITH PAST AND CURRENT.
PRACTICE AND POLICY. I CAN SEE
FOR. OR I CAN CONTINUE WITH THE
OTHER US BCPS. LET'S CONTINUE
WITH THE OTHER TWO BCPS PLACED.
THE SECOND INSPIRATION THAT IS A
REQUEST FOR TEMPORARY POSITIONS
TO ASSIST TO ASSIST WITH THE
CYCLICAL SURGEONS IN PARK
ACTIVITY ASSOCIATED WITH
SEASONAL ACTIVITIES SUCH AS USC
FOOTBALL LAFC SOCCER VEASEY OF
PEAK SEASON EXHIBIT OPENINGS IN
CONCERTS AND FESTIVALS THAT TAKE
PLACE AROUND THE PARK. TEMPORARY
HELP WOULD INCREASE ONLY PM'S.
TO RESPOND TO THE GROWING NEEDS
TO COLLECT REVENUE AND RENDER
CERTAIN REQUIRED SERVICES ON A
SEASONAL BASIS. THE THIRD AND
FINAL PCP FOR CONSIDERATION- IS-
IN RESPONSE TO AB FORTY THREE SO
THE OFFICE OF EXPOSITION PARK
MANAGEMENT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
. ONE MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND AND TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
ONGOING GENERAL FUND- CLOSE TO
FULL TIME I'M GOING POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL AB I'M SORRY
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY THREE PEACE
OFFICERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE CENTER AT EXPOSITION
PARK. THESE RESOURCES WILL
SUPPORT ALL ONE TIME AND ONGOING
ACTIVITIES REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS OF AB FORTY FRANK
WHICH PRACTICE OFFICER STATUS TO
OUR SECURITY OFFICERS APPOINTED
BY THE OFFICE OF THE EXPOSITION
PARK GENERAL MANAGER MEET THE
TRAINING AND SCREENING
REQUIREMENTS AS PRESCRIBED BY
THE COMMISSION. ON PEACE OFFICER. STANDARDS AND TRAINING OR POST
. WELCOME BACK PRESENTATION TO
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU LET'S
GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PLEASE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MIKE
MCGINNIS WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME
BUT WE ARE AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON ANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS. THANK YOU FOR
THE L. L. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
HELEN KIRSTY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. BUT WE'RE HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS AS WELL. THANKYOU MRS FAR SOMEONE TO GO BACK
TO YOU FOR SOMETHING VERY
SPECIFIC BECAUSE I'M- A BIG FAN
OF THE MUSEUM IN EXPOSITION PARK
IN GENERAL- THE PEACE OFFICERS
IN THE CURRENT. SITUATION IN LOS
ANGELES RELATED TO HOUSING- AND
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS. WHAT'S IT
LOOKING LIKE AN EXPOSITION PARK
. SO THE GREAT THING ABOUT
EXPOSITION PARK IS OUR
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC SAFETY IS
DEDICATED TO TWENTY FOUR HOUR ON
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE OPERATION. SO OUR
OFFICERS ARE ABLE TO ESTABLISH
RELATIONSHIP THEY CAN SEEK OUT
OR IN THE CITY- NO YOU KNOW OUR
REGULAR. VISITORS AND SO WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO IS WORK
WITH OUR ALLIES AGENCIES AS- YOU
KNOW HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS HAVE
POPPED UP TO WORK WITH- ENSURING
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND. THE
LIMITATIONS OF OVERNIGHT CAMPING
AND ALSO WORKING WITH OUR ALLIES
AGENCIES TO REFER- ANY SERVICES
TO THOSE. INDIVIDUALS. FOREIGN
HOUSE. AND DO YOU SEE A PATTERN
OF. LIKE WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE
ON THE GROUND AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF STUDENTS THAT
GO TO THE MUSEUM. WITH SCHOOLS
BEING IN FACT WE OPENED THEM I
AM THINKING ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE. WITHIN
CATCHMENTS AROUND- EXPOSITION
BOULEVARD AND THE NEW REAL WAY
THAT THAT RECENTLY OPENED UP A
FEW YEARS AGO. SURE SO.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH AND I THINK
YOU CAN AND AS A RESULT OF OUR-
HM AT POLICING AND PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICES THAT ARE OFFERED
THROUGHOUT THE PARK BUT- THE
PARKING ITSELF DOESN'T SPEAK
HASN'T EXPERIENCED ANY
INCREASES. IN HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS IT HAS BEEN IN THE
SURROUNDING AREAS HI WE ARE PART
OF THE FEDERAL BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT. AND WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE COUNCIL OFFICE
AND THE VARIOUS COUNTY AND CITY
SERVICES TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION GET HELP WHERE
NEEDED SERVICES- AND SUPPORT
SHOULD ANY ISSUES COME UP BUT
THE PART IN AND OF ITSELF
ACTUALLY HASN'T EXPERIENCED. ANY
SPIKES OUT. THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY HOUSE. YEAH CAN. TO BE
FROM IN OUR POLICING SUPPORT
THOSE THAT ARE. YEAH GREAT THANK
YOU FOR THAT I ONLY BRING THAT
UP BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD A HEARING
RELATED HOUSING AND HOMELESS AND
WRAP SIR IN. MENTAL HEALTH AND
RESOURCES AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CONVERSATIONS
HAPPENING IN THIS COMMITTEE ARE
TIED BACK TO COMMUNITY AND
ACTUALLY HOW IT'S IMPLEMENTED ON
THE GROUND AND WHAT YOU NEED TO
BE ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY. FOUR YOU
KNOW THESE RESOURCES FOR PROJECT
ROOM KEY HOME KEY AT CETERA ARE
USED ON THE GROUND WHERE WHERE
THEY'RE NEEDED THE MOST SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU- WITH
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM. THE COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TEN. FOR THIS ISSUE THE
FOLLOWING PANELIST- WILL PRESENT
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
IN THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. LET'S HEAR FROM-
MISTER MARKMAN WROTE. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
MARK TWAIN WROTE THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE STATE'S MIDDLE
MILE. BROADBAND INITIATIVE
PROGRAM WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY I'M
HAPPY TO CHECK NEED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
RECAP OF THIS PROGRAM FOR THE
COMMITTEE AND A STATUS UPDATE ON
OUR PROGRESS WE APPRECIATE. YOUR
ONGOING SUPPORT ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT- I'M
GONNA TRY TO- SHARE A- THIS
FEATURE HERE TO KIND OF WALK
THROUGH A SLIDESHOW- ARE A
NUMBER OF SLIDES IN THE. I
BELIEVE THAT WORK. ALL RIGHT.
THOUGH- YEAH. OKAY I'M FIRST OF
ALL FOR THE- CHIEF JUSTICE
REVIEW- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
MARKET WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT BRINGS
BROADBAND SERVICE FROM THE CORE
NETWORK OF THE WORLD WIDE WEB TO
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE LAST MILE
PROVIDERS A TAKES SERVICE TO
HOUSEHOLDS- BUSINESSES ANY
CURRENT SITUATIONS THE MILE
BROADBAND INITIATIVE ARE IN AND
THE IDEAS OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IS THAT IT WILL ADDRESS
THIS GAP BY CONSTRUCTING THE
SEGMENTS THAT HAVE NOT
PREVIOUSLY BEEN BUILT BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR OR MADE
AVAILABLE- AT AFFORDABLE RATES.
THE BROADBAND FOR ALL EFFORT
IT'S INCLUDED MULTIPLE EFFORTS-
THE WORK- THE WORK OF THE
CALIFORNIA BROADBAND COUNCIL THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
THE BROADBAND ACTION PLAN UP ALL
THAT TO THE BROADBAND INITIATIVE
PROVIDED FOR IN SB. ONE FIFTY
SIX WAS SIGNED THIS LAST JULY-
ISN'T AS- NOTED WE HAD CHEN DOT.
SB ONE FIFTY SIX PROVIDE SIX
BILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE A SPECIFICALLY
IT- PROVIDES- C. T. WITH THREE
POINT TWO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
TO DEVELOP A STATEWIDE- MIDDLE
GROUND THAT WORK AND- THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WITH A TWO
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR. LAST MILE EFFORTS THAT
THEY'LL TALK ABOUT IN A MINUTE-
IN UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. SB ONE FIFTY SIX A
SCIENCE- NUMBER ROLES TEST
PACIFIC ENTITIES THAT FIND CITY
TEAM AT THE PAST- OF- OVERALL
PROGRAM- OVERSIGHT PC'S TASKED
WITH THE- PROVIDING MAPPING DATA
FOR- FOR THE UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AT A
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR-
GOLDEN STATE NET IS THE A SIDE
OF IT IS- SANITY OF MANAGING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SYSTEM
INCLUDING LEASES WERE NECESSARY.
I CALTRANS IS- WHAT WILL BE
DOING A MAJOR OF- COULD. OF THE
PROCESS ALONG THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM IN FINANCE TOGETHER READ
AND- TRACKING AND REPORTING-
THAT EXPENDITURE OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDS- ON BEHALF OF THE STATE-
AS WELL AS THAT OUTCOMES. WE ARE
IN TERMS OF THAT COULD THAT THE
PROCESS OF THE WAY THAT THE PROD
THE PROJECT AS WELL BUT IT'S
UNFOLDING OF PC'S ARE PUBLIC
PROCEEDING WAS HELD IN AUGUST
AND SEPTEMBER- IT IS THE MAP OF
THE UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. ALONG THE STATE AND
A LOT AS WELL AS THE STATE HAVE
ASSISTANCE TO CONNECT THEM IN
DECEMBER- WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE DESIGN ENGINEERING STAGE AS
THE OVERALL SYSTEM IS BEING
DESIGNED. AS THE REMAINING
NETWORK SEGMENTS ARE IDENTIFIED
C. T. WILL DIRECT CALTRANS TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH
RECONSTRUCTION. A TO SIGN
CONTRACTS BY DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND THEN WE HAVE TO
COMPLETE THE SYSTEM BY DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. THE SATISFIED
REFLECTS THE FACT THAT BECAUSE
THE MAJORITY OF THE COST FOR
THIS PROJECT WILL BE FOR
CONSTRUCTION. OF THE MAJORITY OF
THE EXPENDITURES OF THESE FUNDS
WILL OCCUR IN THE OUT YEARS
BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY TWENTY SIX PRIMARILY A
FALLING CALTRANS COMPLETION OF
PRE CONSTRUCTION WORK. AS NOTED
PREVIOUSLY THE MODEL IS BEING
BUILT USING ALL FEDERAL FUNDS
MADE AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
AMERICAN. A PLAN AFTER ABOUT-
THESE FUNDS MUST BE UNDER A
CONTRACT BY DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND THE PROJECT
COMPLETED BY. DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. ARE THESE PHONES ARE
EXPECTED TO BE SUFFICIENT TO
FUND CONSTRUCTION OF
APPROXIMATELY- THREE QUARTERS OF
THE- ROUGHLY EIGHT THOUSAND MILE
SYSTEM. WITH A LEASES BEING NOT
USED AT THE CLOSE THE GAP-
NOVEMBER US HE CANNOT EACH
FINANCIAL PROJECTS THAT ARE
INTENDED TO- TEACH US ABOUT
BUILDING AND GEOGRAPHICALLY
DIVERSE LOCATIONS- THAT WILL
SERVE URBAN RURAL AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AND- TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF A BUILDER PERTINENTES COBLE
DR TUNING KEYS AND- LEASE
OPPORTUNITY. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND SINCE THE ONE THIRTY
SIX WAS SIGNED IN ADDITION TO
ESTABLISHING MEDIA THE MIDDLE
MILE ADVICE YOU'RE CONNECTED
RIGHT THROUGH TO ME WHICH MEETS
ON A MONTHLY BASIS- AND SONIC
REMOTES WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION CALTRANS
AND GOLDEN STATE NET AS THE
STATE'S. THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR CDT IS ESTABLISHED
A WEBSITE TO PROVIDE UPDATES TO
THE PUBLIC AND IS POSTED PC'S
WRAPS UP UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AT THIS
ADDRESS. AS NOTED PREVIOUSLY HAD
REVISED ITS MAPS OF THE HIGHWAYS
THAT CONNECT UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. CITY IS
CURRENTLY- WORKING WITH THE-
STATE NOT TO IDENTIFY THE BEST
ROUTES TO CONNECT THESE
COMMUNITIES. ARE TO THE CORE OUR
FIRST MILE. AND AND CALTRANS
WILL. BUILD THE MAJORITY OF THE
SYSTEM ALONG THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEMS. BACKGROUND THE CALTRANS
ROLES NOTED CALTRANS WILL
CONSTRUCT MAJORITY THE SYSTEM-
ADDING TO TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS AS WELL AS YOUR STAND
ALONE PROJECTS ALONG ITS- THE
STATE HIGHWAY RIGHT OF WAY. THIS
PART OF THE SENATE DID ONCE
EFFORTS CALTRANS CURLY-
EXPLORING A SKETCH SCHEDULE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS WHICH
FIBER CAN BE ADDED OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS WITHIN THE IN THE
FEDERAL ENCUMBRANCE THAT LINE.
THESE THESE WANTS OPPORTUNITY-
OPINION ARE AT ITS BORDER- RANGE
FROM EIGHTY TO A HUNDRED
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS THAT
PROPERTY AS MUCH AS SEVEN
HUNDRED MILES OF THE OVERALL
NETWORK. CALTRANS IS CURRENTLY
IDENTIFYING THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE AREAS
FOR THE SYSTEM AS WELL AS THOSE
WITH THE GREATEST- INTERACTION
WITH OTHER UTILITIES TO GET
STARTED ON THE SIDE OF. THE MOST
CHALLENGING AREAS THAT'S ALSO
WORKING WITH PERMITTING AGENCIES
TO STREAMLINE ITS PERMITTING
PROCESS HE'S- SB FORTY SIX-
PROVIDES FOR PROJECT DELIVERY
TOOL SUCH AS DESIGN BUILDING JOB
ORDER CONTRACTING. DISSIPATED TO
FURTHER HELP CALTRANS COMPLETE
PROJECTS- BY THE FEDERAL
DEADLINE. SO IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
HAVE BUT IT'S NOT COMING FORWARD
HERE WE HAVE A C. T. IS THAT- IS
MOVING FORWARD TO PROCURE A-
PARKING THREE THOUSAND MILES OF
FIBER RELATED MATERIALS TO GET
AHEADOF ANY SUPPLY CHAIN
RESTRAINTS ARE CHAINED
CONSTRAINTS AND RISKS- THE FIRST
THAT. LEGISLATIVE WILL NOT STAND
REPORT BE RELEASED SHORTLY.
PROBABLY EXPECTED TO IDENTIFY
THE BROADER STATEWIDE NETWORK
ASSOCIATED PROJECTS LATER THIS
SPRING. ADDITIONAL SYSTEM DESIGN
IS EXPECTED BY JULY AND- FIBERS
BEING ADDED TO EXISTING
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS ARE
CURRENTLY. VETERANS WILL BE
STARTING UP PRE CONSTRUCTION ON
A BROADER SYSTEM BY THIS JULY AS
FOR MANY PROJECTS ARE ANNOUNCED
AND LEASE AGREEMENTS WILL FOLLOW
AS- A DUPLICATION ON THESE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE IDENTIFIED.
WITH THAT- BUT LIKE I THINK MANY
BRIDGE TIME AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO ROB OSBORNE THE DIRECTOR
OF COMMUNICATIONS FOR THAT IF
YOU SEE. YOUR DOCTOR THE PUC'S
ROLE IN THE BROADBAND INITIATIVE. THANK YOU MARK MY NAME IS
ROBERT OSBORNE I'M DIRECTOR OF
THE COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION AT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION- NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
BUT SINCE THE PASSAGE OF SB ONE
FIFTY SIX THE CDC HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY WORKING ON COMPLETING
THE MIDDLE MILE ANALYSIS OPTIMAL
TENUOUSLY IMPLEMENTING THE LAST
MILE GRANT PROGRAMS. THE FLIGHT
PROVIDES AN OVERVIEW OF THE
CPC'S BROADBAND RESPONSIBILITIES
INCLUDING OUR NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER SB ONE
FIFTY SIX AND AB ONE SIXTY FOUR.
ON THE LEFT YOU HAVE THE BLUE
BOX WHICH HIGHLIGHTS THE TTC'S
MIDDLE MILE RESPONSIBILITIES
UNDER SB ONE FIFTY SIX WHICH
INCLUDES IDENTIFYING ROUTE.
PARTY AREAS. THANK PUBLIC
COMMENT ON PROPOSED ROADS AND
REPORTING THIS ANALYSIS TO
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY FOR USE IN
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION. THE
GREEN BOX IN THE CENTER-
HIGHLIGHTS THE PC'S
RESPONSIBILITIES IN IMPLEMENTING
THE TWO BILLION DOLLAR LAST MILE
FUNDING THE CDC WILL SOON
RELEASE A PROPOSED DECISION BUT
THE FINAL PROGRAM SENATE PROGRAM
RULES. AND FUNDING ALLOCATIONS.
ON THE RIGHT OF THE ORANGE BY
WHICH THE OTHERS BROADBAND
PROGRAMS THIS INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND THE LOAN LOSS RESERVE
PROGRAM. AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AND THE CALIFORNIA
THAT SERVICES FUND AND OTHER
UNIVERSAL SERVICE PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CPC LIKE
LIFELINE AND CALIFORNIA
TELEKINETIC FUND AMONG THE
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THIS WORK
. EXCELLENT. SO WITH REGARD TO
MIDDLE MILE LOCATIONS DESPITE
PROVIDES A TIMELINE OF THE CPC'S
ACTIONS ON THE MIDDLE MILE
BETWEEN AUGUST AND OCTOBER LAST
YEAR WE FOCUSED ON THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PROCESS THROUGH THE
BROADBAND PRECEDING. SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY SIX GIVE US NINETY
DAYS FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL. IN DECEMBER
IN JANUARY OF THE CPC IN
COORDINATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY RELEASED ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS MAPS AND DATA INCLUDING
THE PUBLIC COMMENT MAP.
LOCATIONS WITHOUT BROADBAND
ACCESS AT TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS
PER SECOND DOWN AND THREE
MEGABITS PER SECOND UP. AND
CALTRANS SCHEDULED PROJECT MAPS
. THE CPC OF BEEN WORKING ON ITS
REMAINING ANALYSIS AND
COORDINATION WITH DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ANTICIPATE ITS POLICE
SHORTLY. THANKS BYE. THE FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WAS ALLOCATED
FOR ELIGIBLE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO
FACILITATE DEPLOYMENT OF LAST
MILE BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THE FLY PROVIDE THE
TIMELINE OF THE CQC'S
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE LOCAL AGENCY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THANK YOU
SEE SPENT SEPTEMBER THROUGH
JANUARY REALLY THINKS THAT
PROPOSALS AND SOLICITING
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK. THE CDC
FORMALLY ADOPTED PROGRAM ROLES
AT THE FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH
VOTING MEETING LAST WEEK AND WE
PLAN TO BEGIN ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS AROUND MAY OF THIS
YEAR. EXPIRED PLATES. ON THE
LAST MILE INITIATIVE A LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ALSO ALLOCATED TWO
BILLION AND FEDERAL ART THE
FUNDS TO EXPEDITIOUSLY CONNECT
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO LAST MILE
BROADBAND SERVICE THROUGH THE
FEDERAL FUNDING ACCOUNT. THE CPC
HAS RELEASED SEVERAL RULINGS
SOLICITING PUBLIC FEEDBACK ON
PROPOSED LAST MILE FUNDING. A
FINAL PROPOSAL WILL BE RELEASED
VERY SHORTLY AND THE CBC EXPECTS
TO OPEN APPLICATION CYCLES
AROUND JULY THIS YEAR. AND
APPROVING APPLICATION THROUGH
THE END OF THIS YEAR. CURRENTLY
THE U. S. TREASURY HAS BEEN
RELEASING GUIDANCE AND RULES FOR
SPENDING THESE FUNDS.
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION THE LAST
MILE I THINK COMES FROM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT ARPA.
NOT SPEAK RECAP FISCAL RECOVERY
FUNDS AND A FURTHER FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION COMES FROM THE
ARPA CAPITAL PROJECTS FUND. U.
S. TREASURY RELEASED THE FINAL
RULE FOR OUR FOR STATE FISCAL
RECOVERY FUNDS ON JANUARY SIX
AND THE RULES ARE PUBLISHED IN
THE FEDERAL REGISTER ON JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTH. CALIFORNIA FIVE
PRE CAPITAL PROJECTS FUNDS FOR
CAPITAL PROJECTS FUND IN
DECEMBER AND TREASURY NOTIFY
CALIFORNIA B. WARD IN JANUARY.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET ALSO CREATED A NEW STATE-
FUNDED LOAN LOSS RESERVE TO A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND APPLYING
PUBLIC NETWORKS WITH THE GOAL OF
EXPANDING THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SECURE FINANCING
THE BILL BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. CPC HAS
SOLICITING FEEDBACK AND FORMALLY
FROM STAKEHOLDERS WE ANTICIPATE
RELEASING A STAFF PROPOSAL IN
QUARTER THREE OF THIS YEAR IN
ADOPTING PROGRAM ROLES IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ME DID POINT OUT
THE LOAN LOSS RESERVE MONEY
COMES FROM THE GENERAL FUND NOT
THE FEDERAL FUNDS SO IT'S NOT
SUBJECT TO DISTRICTS FAT FEDERAL
ENCUMBRANCE DEADLINES. LAST
NIGHT PLEASE. THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND SO THIS
IS IN ADDITION TO THE BROADBAND
FUNDING ALLOCATED TO A SOME LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET AB FOURTEEN AND
THAT'S BEFORE EXTENDED FUNDING
FOR THE CALIFORNIA MAP SERVICES
FUND INFRASTRUCTURE PUBLIC
HOUSING ADOPTION CONSORTIA
COUNTS. IN DECEMBER THE CPC
ACTED ON ALL OUTSTANDING CASF
INFRASTRUCTURE APPLICATIONS. IN
A SEPARATE AND DURING THIS MONTH
THE CPC OF TARGETING- TO MAIL A
RULING WITH PROPOSED PROGRAM
RULES FOR THE CONSORTIA THE
ADOPTION AND THE PUBLIC HOUSING
SUB ACCOUNTS AS WELL AS PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR FUNDING ALLOCATIONS
FOR EACH ACCOUNT IN THE TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR. THE
TPC OF TARGETING OPENING
APPLICATION CYCLES IN JULY OF
THIS YEAR FOR THOSE SUB ACCOUNTS
. IF YOU SEE ABOUT THE WORKING
ON ALLOCATION- BASED ON THE
APPROPRIATIONS THE ALLOCATION I
MENTIONED EARLIER- BASED ON THE
PROPOSED STATE BUDGET. THE CDC
WILL CONSIDER SURCHARGE. WHERE
HAVE AN OPEN PROCEEDING ON THAT
RIGHT NOW LOOKING AT A BUDGET
INCREASE IN THE OUT YEARS. AND
WITH THAT I'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION CAN WE HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON DEEMING
THEM NOT A PROPER FINANCE I HAVE
NOTHING TO ADD TO THIS
PRESENTATION BUT I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
LOL. BRIAN METZGER L. A. O. THE
AGENDA AND PRESENTATION DO A
GOOD JOB SUMMARIZING THE
ADMINISTRATIONS AND LEGISLATURES
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
AGREEMENT- JUST FOR REFERENCE
OUR OFFICE RECENTLY PREPARE TO
HAND OUT WITH SOME DETAILED
BACKGROUND INFORMATION ON THE
MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND INITIATIVE
FOR A RECENT ASSEMBLY
COMMUNICATIONS AND CAMPAIGNS
COMMITTEE HEARING AND WILL
PREPARE ANOTHER HAND OUT FOR AN
UPCOMING HEARING IN THE SAME
COMMITTEE ON LAST MILE PROJECTS
AND- WITH THAT WERE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
BACKGROUND INFORMATION OR ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S GOING TO AT THAT
PARTICULAR COMMITTEE WILL IT
HAVE- MORE INFORMATION ON SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS BOTH FOR MIDDLE
MILE AND LAST MILE. BUT YEAH
AGAIN MARK ONE ROW WITH CDT- I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT QUESTION WAS
WAS TARGETED TOWARD OR SOMETHING
THAT THAT THE L. A. L. BUT-
CALTRANS IS IN THE PROCESS AND-
YOU KNOW ALL POINT- THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO THAT
METABOLIC BY THREE COMMITTEES
US. AS WE GET UPDATED
INFORMATION- IN THE MONTHS TO
COME FROM CALTRANS REGARDING-
YOU KNOW WHAT WHICH SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS- IT'S GOING TO BE ADDED
TO- WE WILL BE PROVIDING UPDATES
ARE. MISERABLE YOU BE PROVIDING
THAT INFORMATION TO SPECIFIC
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT ARE WHOSE
DISTRICTS ARE IMPACTED BY.
MIDDLE MILE. AND LAST MILE OF
PROJECTS. YEAH BUT WHEN WE WHEN
WE WILL BE PROVIDING THAT
INFORMATION. ARE WE HAVE A
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH PROCESS-
THAT THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED- AND
THAT SO AS AS THE INFORMATION
BECOMES AVAILABLE- WE WANT TO BE
OUT I WAS PRESENTING YOU KNOW IT
THAT ANY ANY UPDATES AFTER A
MILD HIGHS YOUR COMMITTEE- AND
TO THE EXTENT I CAN LOOK AT HER
WELL ONCE MONTHLY BUT TO THE
EXTENT EXTENT WE KNOW BEFOREHAND
WE WOULD- ALSO. A PLAN AND
REACHING OUT. OKAY I SURE THAT
BECAUSE- BROADBAND. CLEARLY IS A
PRIORITY TO ALL MEMBERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE BOTH AND RURAL. AND
URBAN AREAS GIVEN THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF CODED. WE HAVE SEEN-
REALLY HOWL. LACK OF AXIS HAS
IMPACTED STUDENTS. THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS ONLY GROWING
BIGGER. AND SO WHETHER YOU ARE
IN THE INNER CITY LIKE ME AND
STILL HAVE A DISTRICT THAT IS
20% BELOW THE NATIONAL POVERTY
LINE. AND NOT HAVING ACCESS TO
BROADBAND OR WHETHER YOU ARE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR ANY OTHER
AREA. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
NEED IS REALLY ABOUT EQUITY. AND
IT REALLY IS ABOUT ENSURING
THAT. ACCESS TO BROADBAND GIVEN
THE TECHNOLOGY IN THE WORLD THAT
WE LIVE IN. THIS ACCESSIBLE TO
ALL AND SO I THINK IT WOULD BE.
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF. THE
AGENCY AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATORS TO UNDERSTAND AND
KNOW. HOW THIS IS BEING IMPACTED
AND IMPLEMENTED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND IN THEIR
DISTRICTS. SO I HAVE A
CONFIRMATION FROM YOU THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS BEING PROVIDED.
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. YES YES. OKAY. I
DON'T DO YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO OKAY
PRETTY MUCH OKAY MY QUESTIONS
ARE DIRECTED TOWARDS- CDT AND MR
MORALE THE NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE
EIGHTEEN INITIAL MIDDLE WHILE
PROJECTS INCLUDE MANY OF THE
URBAN IN NATURE OF COURSE BUT
ONE OF THE EIGHTEEN THAT IS
NUMBER FOURTEEN IS LOCATED IN
SAN MARINO COUNTY AND IS
INTENDED TO RUN ALONG HIGHWAY
TWO FORTY SEVEN FROM HIGH DESERT
BARSTOW TO A PLACE CALLED. BORN
MY QUESTION MY FIRST QUESTION IS
HOW MANY UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS. IN
THIS AREA. ARE IN THIS AREA AND
WILL BE CONNECTED TO THE LAST
MILE FACILITIES AS A RESULT OF
THIS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
LOCATION. YOU HAVE ANY IDEA.
YEAH I'M SORRY I DON'T HAVE THAT
NUMBER FOR YOU I KNOW THAT WE
TRACK THAT- TO YOUR POINT- YOU
KNOW WHEN WE BUILD MIDDLE MILE-
YOU KNOW WE REMIND. PEOPLE THAT
THAT MIDDLE MILE DOESN'T YOU
KNOW THAT GETS THE BROADBAND TO
A COMMUNITY- AND SO- WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE POTENTIAL
COMMUNITIES THERE- ON THE ON THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION'S
MAPS. THAT'S WHERE WE WOULD
IDENTIFY THAT- THE NUMBERS ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALONG THOSE
ROUTES THAT WOULD EVENT THAT
COULD EVENTUALLY BE SERVED- BUT
THEN THERE. THERE'S THE
SUBSEQUENT PROCESS FOR THAT NOT
EVEN SUBSEQUENT BECAUSE BUT AS
FAR NOTABLE MISTRUST BORN THERE
ARE A- THAT- SEVENTEEN YEARS
PROCESS OF THAT THAT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IS GOING
THROUGH HER DEFINING THOSE LAST
MILE PROJECTS. BUT BUT IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBER. OF HOUSEHOLDS- WE
CAN CIRCLE BACK ON THAT- I KNOW.
WE HAVE WE HAVE AN ESTIMATE. BUT
BUT I DON'T HAVE THAT WITH ME.
K. MANY OF THESE QUESTIONS THAT
I'M GUESSING YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE
THE ANSWER TO BUT I WOULD HOPE
THAT YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO GET
THEM TO US. I BECAUSE THEY'RE
THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
OF MY FOLLOW UP QUESTION WOULD
BE DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT THE
COST WOULD BE OF DEPLOYING THE
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK. IN THAT
LOCATION AND I JUST REFER TO.
I'M GUESSING PROBABLY TO. ARE
PREPARED FOR THAT ANSWER. RIGHT
OKAY- I ALSO WANT TO ASK ABOUT
THIS PROJECT RELATIONSHIP TO THE
DIGITAL THREE NINETY FIVE
PROJECT DUE TO ITS LOCATION AND
THAT DIGITAL THREE NINETY FIVE
PROJECT WAS COMPLETED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN I CONNECTED ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE ACRE
INSTITUTIONS BUT IT'S UNCERTAIN
HOW MANY PREVIOUSLY UNSERVED
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE BECOME CONNECTED
. FOR EXAMPLE ALL SEVEN INDIAN
RESERVATIONS IN THE DIGITAL
THREE NINETY FIVE QUARTER MAY
HAVE. A CENTRAL FFICE
CONNECTION BUT MOST INDIVIDUAL
HOMES STILL DO NOT HAVE LAST
MILE SERVICE. AND MY NEXT
QUESTION WOULD BE PREDICTABLE
HOW HOW WOULD YOU ENSURE THAT
THE NEW STATE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK INCLUDING THE BAR
STARTED TOWARD ROUTE. WELL
ACTION RESULT IN LAST MILE
CONNECTIONS. TO THESE UNSERVED
HOUSEHOLDS BECAUSE THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE GOAL. ABSOLUTELY AND
THAT'S REALLY WHERE I THINK THAT
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSIONS- THE FUNDING
PROVIDED BY THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THIS LAST MILE- ACCOUNTS THAT
PROJECTS AND THE PUBLIC UTILITY
CAN UTILITIES COMMISSIONS
PROCESS FOR. ADMINISTERING THOSE
GRANTS IS GOING TO BE HELPFUL-
WE KNOW THAT- MORE BROADLY- THE
PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN RELUCTANT TO
FUND THE COST- IN A LOT OF CASES
OF. BOTH THAT THAT MIDDLE MILE
SEGMENT TO GET OUT TO THAT LAST
MILE SO- WE KNOW THAT- WHEN
SIMILAR MARKETS TODAY ANNOUNCED
WHERE I'VE BEEN REALLY CREATES-
A AND IT'S MUCH MORE OF AN
INCENTIVE- FOR LAST MILE
PROVIDERS TO BECOME INVOLVED AND
TO WORK. TO BUILD OUT THEIR
SERVICE BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE ADDED COST OF BUILDING UP
THAT MIDDLE MILE. SO WE KNOW
THAT CERTAIN ALTERNATIVE MARKET
WILL HELP US ALL FOR THAT AS
WELL AS- THE FUNDING BEING
PROVIDED BY- THAT'S BEEN
PROVIDED SB. ONE FIFTY SIX
THROUGH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. OKAY I WOULD. I'M
ALSO GONNA CISCO BUT I HAVE HERE
YOU MIGHT NOT BE AWARE IS THE
PROPOSED NEW BAR STARTED THORN
ROUTE INTENDED TO CONNECT WITH
DIGITAL THREE NINETY FIVE. BE
AWARE WHETHER THAT'S A REALITY
OR NOT- YES I BELIEVE. THERE
THERE'S THE EIGHTEEN PROJECTS
WHICH WERE DONE PRIMARILY TO
LEARN RIGHT I MEAN WE HAD A THEY
WERE AREAS WHERE AT THE- THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION HAD
GONE FAR ENOUGH AND IN THEIR
ANALYSIS TO BE ABLE TO BE
CERTAIN THAT THERE WAS- INDEED
THERE THERE WAS A SOLUTION WAS
NEEDED AND SO WE MOVED FORWARD
WITH THEM- ABSOLUTELY HERE IN.
I'VE BEEN IN MONTHS TO COME WILL
BE IDENTIFIED OF MORE BROADLY
WHAT PRESS THE SYSTEM LOOKS
LIKE. AND SO THAT'S WHERE WE GET
A BETTER IDEA OF- OF CONNECTED
BUT IN THE END. WE'RE BUILDING A
NETWORK AND EVERYTHING NEEDS TO
BE CONNECTED. OKAY I'M GONNA ASK
THIS QUESTION TO AND- IT MIGHT
BE ENTERED AT A LATER TIME. AS A
GROUP WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT A LAST MILE OF.
BROADBAND PROVIDER HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED TO CONNECT HOMES
ALONG THE- CDT NUMBER FOURTEEN
MENTAL WHILE PROJECT. DO YOU
KNOW WHETHER THAT'S A GOAL. WELL
YEAH BECAUSE THEY HAVE- LAST
MILE- PROJECTS- DETECTED TO
SERVE THE LAST MILE NEED. BUT
WHY DO WE HAVE ANY TARGET DATE
FOR THAT TO BE ACCOMPLISHED. I
HAVE TO DEFER TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION REGARDING
WHAT- WHAT IS IN THE WORKS
THERE- OKAY. STROUDWATER
NAPKINS- STILL ON YES I CAN I
CAN ANSWER THAT THANK YOU MISTER
MOROSO- THE FEDERAL FUNDING
ACCOUNT- AS I SAID EARLIER WE
EXPECT TO BE RELEASING PROPOSED
RULED SHORTLY- BUT GOAL IS TO
START- ACCEPTING APPLICATIONS
FOR LAST MILE USING THAT ACCOUNT
AND BEGINNING IN JULY OF THIS
YEAR. OKAY SO. IN CONCLUSION HOW
MANY OF THESE MIDDLE MILE
PROJECTS HAVE DEMONSTRATED
INTEREST TO ENTER. TO ENTER
CONNECT FOR ONE OR MORE LAST
MILE PROVIDERS THAT HAVE A
BUSINESS PLAN WITH ENOUGH
HOUSEHOLDS AND BUSINESSES LIKELY
TO SUBSCRIBE TO THEIR SERVICE.
IN OTHER WORDS WHAT IS THE
VIABILITY OF THESE EIGHTEEN
PROJECTS. WELL IN TERMS OF THE
EIGHTEEN THAT THERE ARE. ONE BE
CAREFUL WEEK WEEK WE SELECTED
THEM IN PART BECAUSE THEY HAD
BEEN- IDENTIFIED AS AS REQUIRING
SOLUTION AS PART OF A BROADER
NETWORK. THIS IS A NETWORK WE'RE
BUILDING AND SO- I THINK IN IN
THE IN INITIALLY A AND
IDENTIFYING THE EIGHTEEN
PROJECTS SOME OF THEM- WERE
ANTICIPATED TO. TO TRY TO OUT
SOME LAST MILE- SYSTEM MILE
SERVICE THAT WOULD BE- ERROR FOR
AREAS THAT MOVE A PROJECT THAT
HAD BEEN FUNDED. OR WE'RE GOING
TO BE FUNDED- BUT REALLY- THAT
THE CONNECTIVITY IS GOING TO
COME WHEN WE BUILT THE REST AND
IT ALL. TIES TOGETHER. AND SO
AND THAT'S THAT IS THE GOAL OF
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM IS TO- YOU
KNOW TO PROVIDE THAT- THAT
FREEWAY IF YOU WELL TO- FOR LAST
MILE PROVIDERS TO CONNECT TO.
AND I THINK THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
CASES IF YOU'RE A- IF YOU'RE A
OKAY LAST MILE PROVIDER- AND IF
YOU DON'T. HAVE THE FUNDS TO
BUILD THE MIDDLE MILE- TO GET TO
A COMMUNITY- THEN YOU PROBABLY
YOU MAY NOT HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING WHAT
IF YOU GET WHAT YOU KNOW IF
SOMEBODY ELSE BUILT IT WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE. AND SO- WE KNOW
THAT. WE KNOW THAT. THERE'S THAT
THERE'S A NEED WE KNOW THAT-
ELSEWHERE WHEN YOU'VE- MA'AM
I'LL- THE MARKET COMES AND
ADDRESSES THAT AND WHEN IT COMES
TO- AND I THINK- STRASBOURG
PROBABLY SPEAK A LITTLE MORE TO
THIS AS WELL- IF. IF BOB
PROVIDERS ARE LOOKING FOR SAY
PASS OUT FUNDING- IF THEY HAVE.
A LAST MILE MIDDLE MILE TO
CONNECT TO- IT SAYS THAT IT
MAKES A LOT MORE SENSE. SALAS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER
LACKING AND GIVEN NO ADDITIONAL
. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN THANK YOU AGAIN GENTLEMEN
APPRECIATE IT. AFTER THIS ISSUE
WE ARE DEALING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM.
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE- MISTER
CHRIS SMILE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- ACTUALLY BEFORE WE BEGIN
I WANT TO GO IN TURN THE- MIKE
OVER TO JENNIFER URBAN WHO WILL
INTRODUCE THE ISSUE INVOLVES YOU
DOING THAT'LL GET MY SCREECH OR
SET UP GREAT THANK YOU PLEASE
BEGIN WITH SERMON. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER URBAN AND I'M
THE CHIEF OF BUDGETS AND
ACCOUNTING WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. WE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PAROLE SYSTEM. BY THE CHANGE
PROPOSAL. AS YOU REQUESTING
INCREASED RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
THE C. S. P. S. PROJECT. WITH
THE CONTINUATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY. PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFE. THESE RESOURCES ARE
CRITICAL TO THE PROJECT SUCCESS
AS A SOLICIT AT THE SOLUTION
DESIGN. DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION WILL COMMENCE AS
THE PROJECT ANTICIPATES. THE
SYSTEM INTEGRATOR AND TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. IN ADDITION THE
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES.
HAS IT PRIMARY BUSINESS PARTNER
ON THE PROJECT IS REQUESTING
RESOURCES TO FULLY PARTICIPATE
IN THE NEXT PHASE OF THE
PROJECT. INTO IT HERE TO REQUEST
FOR PROJECT RELATED ACTIVITIES
WITHIN THE AGREED UPON
TIMELINES. THESE RESOURCES WILL
ENABLE COUNTY CHARGES SEX
SUCCESSFULLY MANAGE THE H. R.
COMPONENTS OF THE ARCH SKILLED
STATEWIDE PROJECT. PERSONNEL
PROJECT DIRECTOR WILL NOW
PROVIDE A STATUS. UPDATE ON THE
PROJECT THANK YOU. OKAY YOU
JENNIFER I WOULD AGAIN MY NAY IS
CHRIS MAYO AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL
SYSTEM PROJECT WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE- IS THERE
WE GO. IN MY PRESENTATION TODAY
I'M GONNA COVER LESSONS LEARNED
BY THE PROJECT TOUCH ON
INFORMATION GATHERED DURING
MARKET RESERCH. DISCUSS THE
SCHEDULE AND PROJECT FUNDING
NEEDS AND CLOSE WITH THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE PROJECTS
OVERSIGHT FRAMEWORK. DURING OUR
PROJECT PLANNING WE TOOK GREAT
PAINS TO STUDY WHAT WENT WRONG
WITH THE PAST EFFORTS BECAUSE
LESSONS ARE ONLY LEARNED IF YOU
DON'T REPEAT THE MISTAKES FROM
THE PAST. SO WE LOOK INSIDE AND
EXAMINE PROJECT ARTIFACTS
INTERVIEWED STAFF AND SEVERAL
PAST PROJECT DIRECTORS AND
PROJECT MANAGERS SEEKING THEIR
INPUT. WE DIDN'T STOP THERE WE
ALSO LOOKED OUTSIDE AND OTHER
ENTITIES WHO ALSO FAILED AND
THOSE WHO ARE SUCCESSFUL. WE
TALKED TO OTHER GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
NEW YORK CITY THE STATE OF
OREGON COLORADO NEBRASKA AND
HAWAII. WILL ALSO HOST OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF CANADA FOR
A DAY AND A HALF OF CANDID
DISCUSSIONS SHARING LESSONS
LEARNED FROM EACH OF OUR FAILED
PROJECTS. AND WE MET WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S YOU
SEE PAST PROJECT TEAM. TO LEARN
ABOUT THEIR SUCCESSFUL APPROACH.
TO DATE THE PROJECT IS
ARGUMENTATIVE OVER SEVENTY
DIFFERENT LESSONS LEARNED THAT
SPANNED MAJOR CATEGORIES SUCH AS
THOSE RAISED BY THE TASK FORCE
ON RE ENGINEERING IT PROCUREMENT
FOR SUCCESS. ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
HOW TO RUN A BETTER VIRTUAL
REQUIREMENTS VALIDATION SESSION
. TOPPING THIS LIST IS
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE MANAGEMENT
. THE PROJECT TRACKS THESE
LESSONS AND CONTINUES TO REVIEW
ITS WORK AS A PERFORMS AT AND
ADJUST AS NEEDED TO ACHIEVE
BETTER OUTCOMES. WHAT WE LEARNED
FROM OUR RESEARCH WAS THAT WE
MUST HAVE CLEARLY DOCUMENTED
REQUIREMENTS BEFORE BEGINNING
PROCUREMENT. THIS KEY ELEMENT
WAS MISSING FROM PAST EFFORTS.
BUT WE DIDN'T START BY READING
REQUIREMENTS INSTEAD WE STARTED
BY DOCUMENTING OUR CURRENT
BUSINESS PROCESSES FROM END TO
END. AND WE CLOSELY EXAMINE
THOSE PROCESSES SEEKING WAYS TO
IMPROVE THEM. WITH THIS SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS TO NEARLY FORTY
DIFFERENT STATE DEPARTMENTS WE
PUT THE PROJECT DOCUMENTED OUR
FUTURE STATE BUSINESS PROCESSES
AND THEN WROTE MID LEVEL IN
DETAIL REQUIREMENTS FOLLOWED BY
EVEN MORE DETAIL BUSINESS RULES.
AS WE ALL KNOW THE DEVIL'S IN
THE DETAILS AND THE CULMINATION
OF THIS ACTIVITY HAS RESULTED IN
QUITE AN EXQUISITE SIDE OF
REQUIREMENTS. LESSONS LEARNED
ALSO INFORMED US THAT REDUCING
COMPLEXITY IS KEY TO ACHIEVING
OUR OBJECTIVES IN THE
REQUIREMENTS WE DEVELOP REFLECTS
SIGNIFICANT COMPLEXITY REDUCTION
. THIS ONE LESSON IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE ONE STATE
CONFORMS TO STANDARD PRACTICES
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE SYSTEM IS
ALSO REDUCED WHICH INCREASES THE
PROBABILITY OF A SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION. AND REDUCES
ONGOING OPERATIONAL EXPENSE.
PAUL ROBUST AND RIGOROUS TESTING
OF COURSE WILL OCCUR DURING THE
EXECUTION PHASE OF THIS PROJECT
WE'RE FOLLOWING THIS PRINCIPAL
DURING PROCUREMENT AS WELL.
PERSPECTIVE VENDORS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO SHOW HOW THEIR
PRODUCT WILL MEET OUR
REQUIREMENTS THROUGH PROOF OF
CONCEPT PHASE OF THE
PROCUREMENT. WHERE THE STATE
WILL PRESENT THE MOST COMPLEX
PERSONNEL AND PAYROLL SCENARIOS
TO THEM AND IT WILL BE PART OF
THE EVALUATION PROCESS. NOW
GIVEN THAT WE'RE MOVING TO
REPLACE THE NEARLY FIFTY YEAR
OLD SYSTEM. WE RECOGNIZED EARLY
IN OUR PLANNING THAT THIS IS
TRULY A MASSIVE ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT PROJECT. WITH
A COMMENSURATE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY COMPLEMENT. AS I
NOTED EARLIER WE STARTED CHANGE
MANAGEMENT EFFORTS THREE YEARS
AGO WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES STAFF. THROUGH EARLY
INVOLVEMENT IN THE PROCESS OF
DEFINING OUR FUTURE STATE
PROCESSES IN WRITING AND
VALIDATING REQUIREMENTS. AFTER
THAT WE DIRECTLY ENGAGE WITH THE
STATE'S EMPLOYEES BY HAVING THEM
BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO ONLINE
ACCESS TO PERSONNEL AND PAYROLL
DATA. THROUGH THE CATHOLIC
LEAGUE CONNECT APPLICATION. WITH
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND REGISTERED USERS
TO DATE THE STATE'S EMPLOYEES
HAVE SHOWN THEY ARE EAGER TO
ADOPT NEW TECHNOLOGIES AS PART
OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT EXPERIENCE.
BY CONTINUING THESE PRACTICES
AND THREE FUTURE ENGAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES DO YOU PLAN TO ENSURE
A SMOOTH TRANSITION TO THAT
FUTURE SOLUTION. SO IN ADDITION
THE CATALOGING AND RESPONDING TO
LESSONS LEARNED WE ALSO
CONDUCTED EXTENSIVE MARKET
RESEARCH. SO WHY NOT FISCAL S.
C. O. DID IN FACT CONSIDER
INTEGRATION WITH THIS COW WAS
DID CONSIDER WHETHER INTEGRATION
WITH THIS COW WAS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STATE WE STARTED
WITH A VERY WELL ATTENDED OPEN
VENDOR FORUM WHERE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THIRTY FOUR
CONSULTING FIRMS AND SOFTWARE
MANUFACTURERS INCLUDING FIRMS
LIKE C. GI ORACLE PEOPLESOFT
WORKDAY. THEY WERE ALL PROVIDED
WITH AN INTRODUCTION TO THE
PROJECTS TO THE PROJECT BY
EXECUTIVES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY AND THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE FOLLOWING
THE FORUM THE PROJECT IS THE
HIGH LEVEL REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION TO SEE WHAT THE
MARKET HAD OFFERED. WITHIN
HOSTED GROUP DISCUSSIONS WITH
INTERESTED VENDORS TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THEIR SERVICE OFFERINGS
AND WE TOOK ANOTHER STEP DEEPER
AND RELEASED A DETAILED REQUEST
FOR INFORMATION FOCUSING
SPECIFICALLY ON THE CENTER
REQUIREMENTS WE HAD WRITTEN TO
DATE. THIS GENERATED VERY
INFORMATIVE INDIVIDUAL VENDOR
DISCUSSIONS WITH SYSTEMS
INTEGRATORS AND AGAINST AWESOME
THE SOFTWARE SOLUTION PROVIDERS.
ALL OF WHOM INDICATED THEY WOULD
PROPOSE THAT OUR MOST MODERN
PRODUCTS IN RESPONSE TO THE C.
S. P. S. PROCUREMENT. IN THE END
THE ORACLE PEOPLESOFT PLATFORM
ON WHICH THIS CAL OPERATES
ASSEMBLY NOT EVEN MENTION BY THE
VENDOR COMMUNITY. WITH ALL THIS
RESEARCH AND HANDLE PROJECT TEAM
RECOMMENDED A CLOUD HOSTED
INTEGRATED PLATFORM IS THE
SOLUTION FOR WHAT YOU MIGHT KNOW
TO BE A COMMERCIAL OFF THE SHELF
SYSTEM. SO NOW ALL THE L. A. O.
HAS SUGGESTED THE PROJECT IS
EXPERIENCING DELAYS IN THE
PROCUREMENT. PROJECTS PLANNING
PHASE LIKE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT AROUND THE
SCHEDULE. THE PROPOSED PROJECT
SCHEDULE FROM THE STAGE TO
ALTERNATIVES ANALYSIS APPROVED
BY CDT IN APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. DOCUMENTED THAT JULY OF
TWENTY TWO WOULD BE THE POINT IN
TIME WHEN WE THINK A CONTRACT
WOULD HAVE BEEN AWARDED. IN THE
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE CDT
STATEWIDE TECHNOLOGY PROCUREMENT
DIVISION IDENTIFIED METHODS OF
REDUCING THE TIME THAT IT COULD
TAKE TO CONDUCT THE PROCUREMENT.
WHILE THE SAME TIME THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY REQUIRES
THE PROJECT TO EXECUTE AND
ADDITIONAL ANCILLARY CONTRACT.
FOR ENTERPRISE ARCHITECT TO
REEVALUATE THE APPROACH
IDENTIFIED THROUGH MARKET
RESEARCH TO PROVIDE THE STATE
WITH THAT ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF
INSURANCE. THAT THAT NEW THE
APPROACHES SOUND. WELL THIS
DIDN'T JACK SEVERAL MONTHS OF
TIME TO THE PLANNING PHASE WE'RE
NOW TRACKING ON EXECUTING A
CONTRACT IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THIS IS NOT TO SAY
WE WANT TO COUNTER CHALLENGES
DURING PROCUREMENT. BUT THE
PROJECT'S RIGOROUS MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES WILL CONTINUE TO BE
EMPLOYED. TO MITIGATE THOSE
RISKS AND OF THE PROJECT
GOVERNING BODY WILL BE AT THE
READY TO ADDRESS ANY ISSUES THAT
WE MIGHT ENCOUNTER. I AM VERY
PLEASED TODAY TO ANNOUNCE THAT
THE PROJECT DID SUBMIT THE STAGE
THREE SOLUTION DEVELOPMENT
PACKAGE TO CDT ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIFTH. WHICH MARKS THE
CULMINATION OF A MASSIVE EFFORT
BY THE PROJECT TEAM TO CREATE A
SOLICITATION OF THIS MAGNITUDE.
AS A RESULT THE PROJECT IS NOW
TRACKING ON THE REVIEW AND
APPROVAL AT THIS STAGE OF THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE. AND
THE SUBSEQUENT RELEASE OF THE
SOLICITATION BY THE END OF MARCH
. AT ISSUE IS THE TIMING OF WHEN
TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THIS
PROJECT EXECUTION PHASE WHERE
THE PROJECT WILL INCUR THE
EXPENSES. OF THE SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION VENDOR AND
ASSOCIATED SOFTWARE SOLUTION
COSTS. IF THE PROJECT MAINTAINS
THE CURRENT SCHEDULE MR MILE I'M
GOING TO PLEASE ASK IF YOU CAN.
TRY TO WRAP UP YOUR REMARKS.
OKAY ANALYSTS SEE. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOU HEAR THESE
THIS PIECE HERE- SO THE
OVERSIGHT FOR THIS PROJECT. WE
ARE IN THE FOLLOWING CITIES
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE TO
THE TV AND RUBIO MANAGING THE
PROJECT WITH THE RIGOR NEEDED
FOR A PROJECT OF THIS SIZE. AS
YOU CAN SEE WE HAVE THE STEERING
COMMITTEE- WHOSE MEMBERS ARE CAL
HR AND SCO THOSE THE TWO PROJECT
PARTNERS ON THIS PROJECT
ROUNDING THAT OUT I HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND CDT.
THE PROJECT LEADERSHIP TEAM IS
MANAGED BY CALYX R&S CO. THE
PROJECT REPORTING WE ACTUALLY
REPORT TO CDC ON A BI WEEKLY
BASIS WE ALSO HAVE WEEKLY
REPORTING WITHIN THE PROJECT
TEAM ITSELF IN ON A BI MONTHLY
BASIS WE REPORT TO THE EXECUTIVE
STEERING COMMITTEE. AND AGAIN
QUARTERLY REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND OF COURSE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IT'S THROUGH ALL OF THAT
OVERSIGHT THAT- YOU WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE WILL BE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO. REALLY WEIGH IN ON THIS
PROJECT BEFORE IT'S FINALLY
APPROVED- IN MOVING ON YOU KNOW
TO ITS EXECUTION PHASE. LASTLY
THE PROJECT PER PUBLISHES THREE
EXECUTIVE LEVEL REPORTS THAT
COVER THE SCHEDULE. THE
PERFORMANCE THE TIES TO THAT
SCHEDULE THAT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL DETAILS FOR WHEN
THINGS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
OCCURRING AND FINALLY A RISK AND
IF YOU REPORT THAT SHOWS ANY
ACTIVE ISSUES OF THE PROJECT IS
TRACKING ON. IN IN THE NEAR TERM
AND LONG TERM RISKS AND WITH
ADEQUATE AND WRAP UP. THANK YOU
AS MY MUCH APPRECIATED LET'S
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PLEASE. THE ED DOMINIC
ADAIR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THIS PROJECT AND
THE REQUEST AS PROPOSED WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS BEFORE IT FINAL
VOTE ON THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
LEN. INVESTOR L. A. O. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE PLANNING DOLLARS
AND POSITIONS IN THIS PROPOSAL
BUT DEFERRED CONSIDERATION OF
THE REMAINING EIGHTY THREE POINT
THREE MILLION IN FUNDING FOR
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR RACE
THREE MAIN CONCERNS WITH
APPROVING DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDS AT THIS
TIME. FIRST THE LEGISLATURE DOES
NOT HAVE ADEQUATE INFORMATION
NOW TO APPROVE THESE FUNDS KEY
PIECES OF INFORMATION ARE NOT
AVAILABLE LOOKING UP FINAL
BASELINE COSTS SCHEDULE AND
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT SIGN VENDOR
CONTRACTS AND OTHER SUPPORTING
PROJECT DOCUMENTATION. SECOND
THE PROJECTS ASSUME TIMELINE TO
COMPLETE PLANNING IS OPTIMISTIC
IT COULD EXPERIENCE ADDITIONAL
DELAYS FROM ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES PROCUREMENT AND OTHER
RELATED ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
AGREEMENTS FROM BARGAINING
UNITS. ALSO AS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW THIS PROJECT INTEGRATES WITH
PASCAL INCLUDING AT A MINIMUM
HOW THE TWO SYSTEMS WILL
INTERFACE WITH ONE ANOTHER IF
THE. C. S. P. S. PROJECT IS
APPROVED. THIRD THE PRICE
PROPOSE SCHEDULE PROVIDE THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH FLEXIBILITY
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT THE
PROJECTS BUT AT THE COST OF
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
POSTSEASON YES I T. PROJECT IF
APPROVED WOULD BE ONE OF THE
COSTLIEST AND MOST COMPLEX IT
PROJECTS UNDERTAKEN BY THE
STATE'S. PRELIMINARY COST
ESTIMATE FOR THIS PROJECT IS
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
WITH A PRELIMINARY TIMELINE A
FIVE AND A HALF YEARS FOR
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
THAT AFFECTS MANY STATE
DEPARTMENTS. WE FIND THAT THE
BENEFITS OF STARTING THE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION A
FEW MONTHS EARLIER DO NOT
OUTWEIGH THE RISKS OF A HURRIED
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW OF THE
PROJECT PLAN. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU HEY I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ACTUALLY
ANSWERED A COUPLE OF- SOME
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD BUT I WANT
TO GO BACK TO THE CONVERSATION.
ON NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
CONVERSATIONS WITH STATE STAFF.
IN PARTICULAR. HAS THE PROJECT
COMMUNICATED WITH STATE
BARGAINING UNITS ABOUT THE
STATUS OF THIS PROJECT IN THE
POSSIBLE CHANGES THAT COULD
MEAN. TO THE WEIGHT THAT STATE
WORKERS GET PAID. I CAN TAKE
THAT ONE YES WE HAVE MADAM CHAIR
I'M SO FAR WE'VE MET WITH ABOUT
HALF OF THE BARGAINING UNITS-
THE ONLY ONES WE REALLY HAVEN'T
GOTTEN TOGETHER OF THOSE THAT
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SEE-
YOU. WE JUST REAL QUICKLY
PROVIDE THEM WITH A COMPLETE
PROJECT BLACK BACKGROUND- MUCH
MORE DETAIL THE ONE THAT I WAS
TRYING TO GIVE YOU. AND THEN WE
CAN YOU KNOW STEP THROUGH- SOME
OF THE MORE MAJOR CHANGES THAT
THE PROJECT WILL BRING. WHEN DO
YOU EXPECT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE LARGEST
UNION. THAT REPRESENTS STATE
EMPLOYEES. I AM I MIGHT NEED TO
DEFER TO THE CALORIES ARE ON
THAT ONE- I KNOW WE HAVE REACHED
OUT BUT I DON'T KNOW THE LATEST
STATUS OF WHETHER OR NOT THAT
UNION HAS RESPONDED. SB MY BET
ON THE LINE RENDON MISTER MURPHY
. YEAH I REMEMBER FOOD THAT ALEX
ARE YES WE HAVE REACHED OUT AND
WE HAVE NOT- BUT AT SCHEDULING
THAT YET BUT WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF TRYING TO. SCHEDULE
EVERYTHING. OKAY WELL I JUST
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE
CRITICAL IN THIS ENDEAVORTO TRY
TO REACH OUT TO THE LARGEST. AND
STATE EMPLOYEE GROUP AS WELL AS
THE LARGEST BARGAINING. UNIT
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO IF WE CAN
TRY TO EXPEDITE THAT THAT BE
GREAT AND IF YOU NEED ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT ON REACHING THEM. PLEASE
LET US KNOW. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU WITH NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO. ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO THE PANELISTS
ON ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN- WE'RE
MOVING ON TO DEPARTMENTAL YEAR
END CLOSING CLOSE REPORTS- WE'RE
GONNA START WITH. AB MISS CAPLIN
WEB PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT AND
STRESS THEIMPORTANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS COMMITTING A TIMELY
AND ACCURATE FINANCIAL PART THE
END OF COMPREHENSIVE FINANCE
REPORT ALSO REFERENCED TO AS THE
ACT FOR REPRESENTS THE FINANCIAL
CONDITION OF THE STATE IS USED
BY INVESTORS RATING AGENCIES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THEIR
FINANCIAL AGENT THE SESSIONS
WITH THE PUBLIC AGENCY.
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA. GIVEN THE
INCREASE REPEAT THE MANTRA
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA WAS ELEVEN
MONTHS LATER PUBLISHED IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY ACT FOR. DID NOT
INCLUDE A CLEAN AUDIT AT A TIME
WE ALSO HAVE A SURPLUS IS OUT
PRESIDENT IT SHOULD NEVER BE
REPEATED. WELL WE APPRECIATE OUR
CURRENT SURPLUS WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THIS JANET HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY IN CALIFORNIA THE
DELETE REPORT ACCURATE AND
TIMELY INFORMATION IS CRITICAL
TO SAFEGUARD OUR FINANCIAL
POSITION. UNDER ALL CONDITIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY HERE TO PARTY FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS CURRENTLY
TRACKING WORSE THAN LAST YEAR
WITH EIGHTEEN FISCAL OUT THE
AGENCIES. AND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX FUNDS DELINQUENT IN
REPORTING THEIR BUDGETARY LEGAL
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS AS OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH. THIS
REPRESENTS A 55% INCREASE IN
DELINQUENT FISCAL TOTAL FUN
REPORT SUBMITTED OVER FISCAL
YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY. AND ELEVEN
MORE FISCAL DEPARTMENTS
DELINQUENT IN REPORTING COMPARED
TO THE PRIOR YEAR. WHILE THE SCO
IS WORKING WITH ALL THESE
DEPARTMENTS DELAYED OVERSIGHT TO
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY THREE AS
PROPOSED. WILL NOT ADDRESS A
VERY REAL FINANCIAL TRAVESTY FOR
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
SHARE THE LINK WITH THE REPORT
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AFTER THIS HEARING. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU TO WE HAVE- ANY
COMMENTS FROM FISCAL ORDER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. JEFF
PARTMINER FINANCE A HAPPY DAY.
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MERION
BARCELONA INTO NEED OUT EXCUSE
ME I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO HERE AND
ABLE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU DO WE EXPECT TO CLOSE
OUT OF THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR
TO TAKE AS LONG AS THE LAST ONE
DID. ASSEMBLY WHAT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE BASED ON
THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW MADAM CHAIR WE WOULD
SAY YES IN POTENTIALLY LONGER.
HOW MUCH LONGER WHAT WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE OR TIMELINE. WELL
WHEN I LOOK AT A 55% INCREASE
AND WE DIDN'T REPORT THE
NINETEEN TWENTY UNTIL FEBRUARY
OF THIS YEAR- AND WE HAVE MORE
TO LEAK REPORTS OF THE LIQUID
FUNDS WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT. I'M SORRY CAN YOU REPEAT
THAT PLEASE. YES SO IN NINETEEN
TWENTY WE PRODUCED OUR ACT FOR
IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- RIGHT NOW IS INDICATED IN
OUR REPORTS IS THAT THE
DELINQUENCY OF AGENCIES
REPORTING AND THE FUNDS BEING
REPORTED IS HIGHER THAN WHAT IT
WAS LAST YEAR- AT THE SAME TIME.
AND SO UNLESS WE CAN OVERCOME
THESE CHALLENGES OUR CONCERN
WE MAY ACTUALLY REPEAT THE SAME
TYPE OF TIME LINE FROM A
REPORTING STANDPOINT. I SEE IS
THERE AN EXPECTED TIME FRAME IN
WHICH THE CONTROLLER FUNCTIONS
WILL FULLY MIGRATE TO THE FISCAL
SYSTEM. WELL I THINK THAT'S A
SEPARATE CONVERSATION- WITH
REGARDS TO THE YEAR AND CLOSE
REPORT FOR DEPARTMENTS- I THINK
WE WERE JUST FOCUSED ON THE
CHARTS WE'VE SHARED AND I CAN'T
TELL YOU THAT- STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WORKS VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF.
THE SCALE IN MOVING FORWARD WITH
THOSE FUNCTIONALITIES. OKAY.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT GIVEN WE
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE. FORUM
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE PANELISTS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE STARTED MOVING
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN THAT
WAS ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE- THIS
ONE IS THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
BUDGET PROPOSALS IN CYBER
SECURITY. LET'S START WITH MR
RUSS NICHOLS. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF MY NAME'S RUSTY
BECAUSE I AM THE ACTING DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY. AS
WE HAVE MIGRATED MORE MORE STATE
SERVICES TO BE USING
TECHNOLOGIES ENGINE FOR THE
DELIVERY OF THOSE SERVICES CYBER
SECURITY IS OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE
THE STATE. OF MOST IMPORTANCE TO
THE STATE. DEVELOP A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE. STARBUCKS
COMMITTEE PROBE. THAT ISSUE
ABOUT- ONLY ACROSS THE BUT ALSO
IN. WITH WE ASK. WITH PART IN
THE MILITARY AND WE SEE P. THOSE
ARE THE FRONT LINE PORTION OF
OUR SITE WHICH CORE. BUT A
BACKSIDE PIECE OF THAT IS OUR
OVERSEE OF STATE ARMAMENTS AND
HOW THEY TO PROGRAMS POLICY AND
PROCEDURES. THE AUTO THAT
DONOSTIA A RISK UP. PROVIDED TO
US AN UPDATE OF THE PREVIOUS ALL
. AND FOCUSES ON THAT OVER
PROCESS. IN THAT AUDIT REPORT
OUT THAT WE NOT YET TO. OUR SITE
OF MEASURE THE SEX STANCE STATE
CORRECT REPORTER PAUL THIS IN
UNTIL JUNE THIS. YEAH SO. WE
WILL BE A BIG THAT DENMARK'S AS
WELL MAY DO POINT OUT- I COULD
FROM THE WE WERE NOT ON THE- TO
KEEP. THE WORK IN WE AT THE END
OF THREE OF THIS HAD COMPLETED
ALL EIGHTEEN OF THE EXPECTED.
THIRTY NINE. SURE AFTER-
EXPECTED AT THAT POINT WE ARE
HOWEVER ON TAP BECOME FORTY TOLD
TWO AUDITS BY THE END OF THAT
REPORT PERIOD WHICH JUNE THIS
YEAR AND SO ARE ON TAP WITH THE
WITH THE STAFF THAT WE IN
OBVIOUSLY ARE MAY ON ARE. WE
APPRECIATE THAT FEEDBACK AND ARE
TAKING. RECORD TO IN THE CONCERT
WE CONTINUE. WITHOUT BEHALF
ANSWERING BUT OF THE END BURKE
WAS. AT THIS POINT A LITTLE PARK
CHIEF STREET OFFICE MILES FROM
THAT- TO SPEAK THE TO CPT. THANK
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS PER NOW ON THE EVERY DIRECTOR
BUSINESS CHIEF ADMIN OFFICE FOR
CD- WE TO USE TNCS- YOUR
CONSIDER. THE FIRST PC- IS A
FORTY FOUR MILLION- JOE FUND AND
- FORTY ONE MILLION THAT IS A
CONVERSION A BIG- A AND COST
RECOVERY CALL THE SERVICES
REVOLVE FUND- THE OUR IS DO THAT
FORTY ONE MILLION FROM ARE TO
GENERAL FUND. THE OTHER THREE
MILLION IS AN AUGMENTATION FOR A
STATE WIDE STRATEGIC REPORTING
WE DO THAT- IT'S AN AUGMENTATION
BECAUSE WE'RE ASKING FOR THREE
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND BUT
WE'VE NEVER HAD THAT AUTHORITY
AND CHANCERAPS WHAT'S NOT A IT'S
NOT A CONVERSION OF FUNDING WITH
NEXT DOOR THAT WE. THE SHIFT
WOULD ABOUT ALLOW US TO- PAPER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE OF OUR-
ABOUT OF CITIES OVER STAFF-
THROUGH GENERAL FUND IS TO OF
COST RECOVERY IT WOULD INCLUDE
ALL OF THE OVERHEAD POSITIONS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN TSR APP AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE- INDIRECT
POSITIONS AS WELL C. A. T. T.
LOOKS AT DIRECT INDIRECT AND
OVERHEAD COSTS THIS LIST TO
COVER THE OVERHEAD. COMPONENT
AND THE INTER COMPONENT- IT
WOULD I WANT TO POINT OUT IT-
YOU WE WOULD STILL. IF THESE ARE
TO PASS WE WOULD STILL BE
PRIMARILY A COST RECOVERY
ORGANIZATION- WHEN I CAME TO SEE
TO TAKE FOUR YEARS AGO WE WERE
ABOUT NINETY WE RECOVERED ABOUT
97% OUR COST THROUGH. OUT
HISTORY. NOW CURRENTLY WE'RE OUT
EIGHTY SIX OR EIGHTY SEVEN
PERCENT. 86% I'M SORRY- ENTITIES
TO BCPS WERE TO PASS THAT WOULD.
RAISE SHOULD BE MORE LIKE 77% SO
IT'S STILL BE A MAJORITY THROUGH
COST RECOVERY- THE SECOND BCP
RELATED BUT SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
IS IT TEN MILLION TEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND ASK.
WHICH WOULD COVER BASICALLY A
RABBIT HOLE THAT IS GOING TO BE
CREATED- CDJ THERE'S A COUPLE OF
OUR LARGER. CUSTOMERS TOUR BE
PULLING SOME OTHER APPLICATIONS
AND SERVICES OUT OF THE DATA
CENTER. SOME OF THE CLOUD AND
OTHER PLACES THAT NATURE- IT IS
A FAIRLY HIGH BECAUSE IT RUNS A
DATA CENTER WITH A FAIRLY HIGH
FIXED COST STRUCTURE JUST TO
GIVE YOU AN IDEA- ABOUT. 50% OF-
WELL 45% OF US AT THE DATA
CENTERS BUDGET. PERSONAL
SERVICES THE OTHER 45% OF
HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE SO 95% OR
90% OF THE BUDGET IS EITHER
HARDWARE SOFTWARE OR- NOT
PERSONAL SERVICES- AND A LOT OUT
WE CAN'T REALLY SHIFT IN THE
SHORT RUN SO WHEN WE WHEN WE
HAVE CUSTOMERS A LEAK. WE LOSE
THE REVENUE BUT WE CAN'T
CORRESPONDINGLY REDUCE OUR COST
STRUCTURE AT THAT SAME RATE.
BOTHOF THESE REQUESTS WERE- ASK
FOR GENERAL FUND FOR THREE
YEARS- WHICH WE BELIEVE IT GIVES
US A- LONG ENOUGH WINDOW TO RE.
HOW CD TO YOU IN THE LONG RUN
CAN CAN CLOSE THE GAP BETWEEN
ITS REVENUE AND EXPENDITURES
EXPENSES- IN AND- PULLS BACK
INTO ALIGNMENT WHERE WE NEED TO
BE AS A COST RECOVERY
ORGANIZATION. IN WHICH I. WILL
BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT LET'S GO TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PLEASE. HELLO MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FIND ONE BOOK CLUB
IN A FINANCE- WE HAD NO COMMENT
AT THIS TIME BUT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON
THE- THANK YOU LET'S GO TO OHIO
. RED SKIRT LMAO- WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVAL ONLY
BUDGET YOUR FUNDING FOR BOTH
PROPOSALS. AND REJECT REQUESTED-OUT YOUR FUNDING. TO ENSURE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT CONTINUES
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS RAISE QUESTIONS
ABOUT CITY'S BUSINESS MODEL FOR
PROVIDING IT SERVICES. THESE
PROPOSALS NOT ONLY SEEK TO
ADDRESS REVENUE LOSSES BUT A
DECLINING CUSTOMER BASE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT STATE DATA CENTER.
ONE REASON APPEARS TO BE SOME
STATE DATA CENTER RATES ARE NOT
COMPETITIVELY PRICED. ANOTHER
REASON IS DIRECT RATE COMPARISON
BETWEEN PRIVATE VENDORS AND THE
STATE DATA CENTER. INCLUDING
BENEFITS SPECIFIC TO STATE
SERVICES. IT'S DIFFICULT FOR
STATE ENTITIES TO UNDERTAKE.
WELL PROPOSAL THAT PRESENTED THE
LARGEST ALSO ARE MISSING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ANTICIPATED RATE REEVALUATION
PROCESS THAT IS EXPECTED TO.
ADDITIONAL REVENUE LOSSES AND
MAKES THE DATA CENTER RATES MORE
COMPETITIVE. BASED ON OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE IMPACTS
OF THIS PROCESS OF COURSE
SERVICES PROVIDED TO STATE
ENTITIES AND THE ANTICIPATED
SHIP THE FUNDING FOR SOME I. T.
SERVICES TO THE GENERAL FUND.
SUGGEST A MORE ACTIVE ROLE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE IN ITS OVERSIGHT
OF THE PROCESS. THEREFORE WE
ALSO RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT DIRECTS CDC AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
DEFINE THE RATE THE EVALUATION
PROCESS OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS. AND PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
INCLUDING THE THREE COMPONENTS
THAT ARE LISTED IN THE AGENDA.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT APPRECIATED-
GIVEN THE CONFLICT IN RUSSIA THE
RISK OF A CYBER ATTACK SEEMS
POTENTIALLY HI- IS THE STATE
READY TO HANDLE SUCH AN ATTACK.
WELL AS I MENTIONED WE HAVE BEEN
IN EXTENSIVE CYBERSECURITY
PROGRAM- WE HAVE. ENGAGE NOT
ONLY WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WELL PAUL ALSO WITH OUR PRIVATE
PARTNERS IN WE CAN GAUGE THE
CYBER CARE SECURITY STAFF ACROSS
THE STATE TO POSTMARK ASSURANCES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TAKING
APPROPRIATE ACTION. AND TO
INCREASE OUR MONITORING OF THE
NETWORKS THAT WOULD PROVIDE
STATE SO WHILE KNOWING THAT HE
CAN'T GUARANTEE THAT THERE WON'T
BE TACKLE. PROVINCIAL WE HAVE
TAKEN THIS PROGRAM STEPS AT. ITS
COST. TO NOT ALWAYS PREVENT
ATTACKS BUT TO ABLE TO DEDICATE
IT SHOULD HAVE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT SURE A ON THE MINDS OF MANY
AT THE MOMENT. WE ARE GONNA MOVE
ONTO THE NEXT ISSUE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TO ALL THE PANELISTS ON
ON ISSUE THIRTEEN. AND FOR THOSE
THAT ARE- WAITING TO PRESENTS WE
ARE AN ISSUE FOURTEEN AT A
NINETEEN WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM SO
YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO. DO A-
BRIEF PRESENTATION OF YOUR- A
PARTICULAR ISSUE WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO- ISSUE FOURTEEN DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES WE'RE GONNA
START WITH MISS JACQUELYN
CAMPEON. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN I
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
CAMPION I'M THE CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. CAMPAIGN I'M
GONNA ASK IF YOU COULD SPEAK A
LITTLE LOUDER AND CLOSER TO YOUR
MIND PLEASE HOLD ON JUST A
LITTLE FAR AWAY. OF COURSE IT'S
NOT BETTER YES. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH OUR FIRST PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU REQUEST ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FORTY FROM THE GENERAL FUND
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE TO REPAIR AND MODERNIZE
ELEVATOR SYSTEMS AND THREE STATE
BUILDINGS AND DIRECT DIGITAL
CONTROL SYSTEMS IN EACH STATE
BUILDINGS- WE HAVE ELEVATOR
PROJECTS. UP FOR BUILDINGS THAT-
INCLUDE ELEVATORS THAT INDUSTRY
STANDARDS PROVIDE SHOULD BE
MODERNIZED EVERY TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND ALL OF THE
ELEVATORS PROPOSED FOR
MODERNIZATION ARE CURRENTLY
BEYOND THEIR USEFUL LIFE IF-
DIGITAL DIRECT DIGITAL CONTROL
AND BUILDING ENERGY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS. ARE THANKS JULIE SMART
EQUIPMENT BACK OUR RECORD EACH
OTHER HVAC SYSTEM STEP. MS FONG
ARMS SYSTEMS THAT CENTER. THE
TECH FAULTS AND I DON'T SENATE
YOU SAVINGS A REPORT TO BE. AT
THEIR TO USE 6% BY OPTIMIZING
EQUIPMENT SETTINGS AND TIMERS
FOR OPTIMAL PERFORMANCE. AND
WITH ME IS DGS DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE FACILITIES MANAGEMENT
DIVISION JAMAL ON MEN AND WE
ALSO HAVE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE REAL ESTATE SERVICES
DIVISION JASON KENNEY AND
THEY'RE AVAILABLE WELL TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
AND I'M SURE DID YOU WANT ME TO
GO OVER THE REST OF THE
PROPOSALS AS WELL OR DID YOU
WANT TO FOCUS ON THE TWO THAT
WERE NOTED FOR OUR DISCUSSION.
WELL IF YOU CAN BE BRIEF ON THE
ONES THAT WERE ON THE AGENDA FOR
DISCUSSION THAT WOULD BE GREAT
BUT AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM
SO IF YOU CAN. THE FROM THE
PRESENTATION THAT THE GREAT
THANK YOU. COURSE I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO THANK YOU. DGS IS ALSO
REQUESTING FOUR POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN EXPENDITURES
FORTY FROM THE SERVICE REVOLVING
FUND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND THEN FOUR POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM OF
THE SERVICE REVOLVING FUND
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. TO FIND A BASS
LINE BUDGET ADJUSTMENT TO TRUE
UP THE FORTY WITH INCREASED
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH I. T.
SOFTWARE LICENSING HARDWARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CRITICAL
PRIVACY AND SECURITY UPGRADES IS
ALSO RESPONSIVE TO
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY- WE ARE FURTHER
CREASED REQUESTING AN ONGOING
INCREASE IN EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FRIENDS SERVICE
REVOLVING FUND BEGINNING IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE TO FIND THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS THAT WILL SUPPORT
ONGOING INCREASED WORKLOAD
AFFAIRS OFFICE INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL COMMUNICATIONS IN
PARTICULAR SUPPORTING MORE
CONNECTED WORKFORCE. IN A
DISTRIBUTED WORK ENVIRONMENT.
OUR NEXT PROPOSAL IS FOR THE
OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION DGS IS REQUESTING
POSITION OF FORTY FOUR FIVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
WORKLOAD RELATED TO THE RECENTLY
EXPANDED CALIFORNIA PRESCHOOL.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IN
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES
GRANT PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE
ALLOCATIONS BOARD AND PROVIDES
GRANTS TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
LACK FACILITIES TO PROVIDE FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND PRESCHOOL.
PRIORITY FOR THESE GRANTS IS
GIVEN TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
DEMONSTRATE FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
IN FOR DISTRICTS LOCATED IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THIS
PROGRAM IS A KEY PIECE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE CLASSROOM
FACILITIES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THEIR YOUNGEST LEARNERS. FOR
NEXT PROPOSAL THE PROCUREMENT
DIVISION IS REQUESTING SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FROM THE SERVICE
REVOLVING FUND IN FISCAL YEARS
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
FOLLOWED BY THREE HUNDRED AND
FIVE THOUSAND IN ONGOING FORTY
ENDING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND FIVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
ONGOING WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AND
PROCUREMENT SERVICES AND SUPPORT
STATEWIDE EMERGENCY PLAN. OUR
NEXT PROPOSAL INCLUDES- THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR OUR
REAL ESTATE SERVICES DIVISION
THIS IS A CAPITAL OUTLAY
THE LEASE PURCHASE OPTION TO
ACQUIRE AT THE JOE SIR IN A
JUNIOR CALIFORNIA EPA BUILDING
LOCATED AT ONE THOUSAND ONE I
STREET IN SACRAMENTO. THE TWENTY
FIVE YEAR LEASE AGREEMENT IS
EXPIRING IN MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND SO DGS IS EXERCISING
THE OPTION TO PURCHASE THE
BUILDING FOR ONE DOLLAR AT THE
END OF THIS LEASE TERM. ENDS THE
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS WILL
ALSO COVER REALIST RELATED REAL
ESTATE DUE DILIGENCE AND
ACQUISITION ACTIVITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TRANSACTION.
ADDITIONALLY A FACILITY
CONDITION ASSESSMENT IS
CURRENTLY UNDERWAY USING
EXISTING FUNDING WHICH WILL HELP
INFORM ONGOING MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONAL NEEDS THE BUILDING.
OUR NEXT PROPOSAL DGS IS
REQUESTING A POSITION OF
AUTHORITY USING EXISTING
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY TO
TRANSITION EXISTING CONTRACTED
ACTIVITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
BUILDING MAINTENANCE SPECIAL
REPAIRS AND PROJECT MANAGEMENT.
IS TEN DECISIONS WILL TAKE OVER
WORKLOAD FROM AN EXISTING
EXTERNAL CONTRACTS THAT
CURRENTLY BREAKS DOWN TO
APPROXIMATELY FIVE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. AND IS
SLATED TO END IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE CONTRACT
SAVINGS WILL BE REDIRECTED TO
SUPPORT THE NEW POSITIONS AND
THEREFORE NO ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURE AS AUTHORITY AND DID
YOU HAVE SERVICE RATES WILL NOT
BE IMPACTED BY THIS PROPOSAL.
OUR NEXT PROPOSAL IS FOR THE DHS
OFFICE OF RISK AND INSURANCE
MANAGEMENT WE ARE REQUESTING ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AN EXPENDITURE THIRTY
FROM SERVICE REVOLVING FUND AND
ONE PERMANENT POSITION. JUST
DEPORT UNGARO ONGOING WORKLOAD
INCREASES IN EQUIPMENT
MANAGEMENT MAINTENANCE INSURANCE
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM REPLACES
AND ORGANIZATIONS MULTIPLE
SERVICE CONTRACTS WITH A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM THAT
CONSOLIDATES THE COST OF
EQUIPMENT MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR. THE INSURANCE BROKERS-
STANDARD PRACTICE IS TO QUOTE
NOT GOING SAVINGS OF TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. AND A PILOT PROGRAM IN
TWENTY TEN PROVED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL BY GENERATING SAVINGS
OF TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM SPONG SMALL NUMBER
TGS OFFICES. THE PROGRAM IS NOW
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE OVER FIFTY
STATE DEPARTMENTS ACHIEVING
CUMULATIVE SAVINGS OF OVER
THIRTY FOUR MILLION THREE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO THIS WILL SUPPORT
THIS INCREASED WORKLOAD. AND
FINALLY OUR OFFICE A FLEET AND
ASSET MANAGEMENT HAS A REQUEST
FOR THE STATE WHY TRAVEL
PROGRAM. DGS IS REQUESTING SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONGOING
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
SERVICE REVOLVING FUND- TO
SUPPORT FOR PERMANENT POSITIONS
STARTING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE MINUTES WILL
ADDRESS INCREASING ON GOING YEAR
ROUND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
WORKLOADS SUCH AS SECURING NON
CONGREGATE HOUSING. AND SHELTER
FOR WILDFIRE EVACUEES IN
INTERNATIONAL REFUGEES AMONG
OTHER PROJECTS MISSION TASKED BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. THESE
RESOURCES WILL ALSO ALLOW DGS TO
ESTABLISH A ROBUST TRAINING AND
COMPLIANCE AUDITING FUNCTION.
ENDS YOU IMPLEMENT. A TRAVEL
RISK MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. AND
THIS CONCLUDES DGS PROPOSALS I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AND AGAIN WE HAVE
DEPUTY DIRECTORS JAMAL ALMOND
FROM THE FACILITIES MANAGEMENT
DIVISION. BURKE JASON KENNEY
FRONT OF THE REAL ESTATE
SERVICES DIVISION TO ADDRESS ANY
OF YOUR QUESTIONS AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. M. CHAIR ILLICITLY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME BUT
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS AGENDA ITEM.
THANK YOU THE L. L. PETER IS NOT
THE ONLY A WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THESE PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- AND AGAIN
MISS CAMP YOUNG THANK YOU FOR
THAT- AS DETAILED- DESCRIPTION
OF YOUR BUDGET REQUESTS
PROPOSALS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO A ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN THANK
YOU AGAIN- ME ONE MOMENT HERE
AND GET MYSELF ORGANIZED WE'RE
GOING TO GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS
BUDGET PROPOSALS WE'RE GONNA
START WITH- MISTER JUSTIN
HOWARD. THANK YOU. SPEAKING AT
CEREMONIES JUSTIN HOWARD OF THAT
THE SECRETARY FOR FISCAL POLICY
ADMINISTRATION OF THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY. FORTY FOR
HOWARD- I WOULD JUST ADD AGAIN
WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM SO IF YOU
CAN BE BRIEF IN YOUR
PRESENTATION THAT THE GREAT
THANK YOU. YES NO. VERY BRIEF WE
HAVE PORTHOLES OF YOU TODAY THE
FIRST ONE IS THE P. C. P.
PORTRAIT SESSIONS AND FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND.
RELATED TO ONGOING WORKLOAD
WITHIN OUR AGENCY AT THE TO THE
JUST FOR THE SENATE WILL HELP US
ADDRESS WORKLOADS SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO OUR EMERGENCY
SERVICES FUNCTIONS ON AT THE
STATE EMERGENCY PLAN. AS WELL AS
TO PROVIDE POLICY DEVELOPMENT
AND STATEWIDE ON PRIVACY
POLICIES FOR OUR OWN AGENCY AS
WELL AS OUR REPORTED IT TO TEACH
TO OUR AGENCY. OUR SECOND
PROPOSAL IS THE BC PEOPLE FOR
POSITIONS RELATED TO THE
GOVERNMENT EXCELLENCE AND
TRANSFORMATION CENTER THAT'S
BEEN ESTABLISHED WITHIN OUR
AGENCY. THE GOAL OF. WHAT WE
CALL THE GET CENTER IS TO
ACCELERATE THE MODERNIZATION OF
STATE OPERATIONS. BY PARTNERING
WITH STATE DEPARTMENTS CONDUCT
INNOVATIVE PILOTS THAT CAN BE
SCALED ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND THEN FINALLY HAVE TO TRICK
USERS THE TRAILER BILL- BEFORE
YOU ONE IS CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
RELATED TO- THIS. CLASSIFICATION
STATUS THAT'S WHAT HE'S FOR
WITHIN THE OFFICE OF THE
SECRETARY WITHIN OUR AGENCY THAT
THEY ARE EXEMPT EXCLUDED
PURPOSE. EXCLUDE COURT
APPOINTEES UNDER THE LAW SO
WHICH WOULD MEAN THE EXCLUDED
FROM. PARTY THE SECOND PIZZA
TRAILER BILL IS. FORMALLY
ESTABLISHED IN OUR CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER STATUTE LAST YEAR WE
RECEIVED APPROVAL TO ESTABLISH A
CHEAP BACKWARDS EQUITY OFFICER
TO SPEAK ON IMPORT. AND WE ARE
BRINGING FORTH. I TRAILER BILL
TO FORMALLY ESTABLISH THAT
STATUTE AS WELL AS- PROVIDE SOME
DEFINITIONS SURROUNDING ITS
ROLE- WITH THAT. WITH ME
CUSTOMER DROWNED AT THAT THE
SECRETARY FOR INNOVATION
ACCOUNTABILITY ENJOYED BONTA
BURKE ARE STATES DATA OFFICER
ANSWER ANY. QUESTIONS ON OUR-
THANK YOU LET'S HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. RIGHT
RIGHT BUT FINANCE IT NOTHING
THAT AT THIS TIME AND ARE HAPPY
INC YOU MIGHT HAVE TO GET. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I DO WANNA DRAW
SOMETHING REALLY TO THE CENTER
FOR- AT. WHICH SEEMS LIKE A
WONDERFUL IDEA AS WELL AS THE-
POSITION FOR- SOMEONE RELATED TO
ISSUES RELATED TO EQUITY- I WILL
SAY THIS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED SEVERE- GAPS
IN THOSE THAT HAVE ACCESS AND
THOSE THAT DON'T- FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN WE WON THE STATE ROLLED OUT
COOL THE TESTING. OUT ONE OF THE
LARGER FACILITIES WAS AT DODGER
STADIUM IN MY COMMUNITY AND WHAT
WE NOTICED WAS THAT UNLESS YOU
HAD A CAR AND YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WAIT SEVERAL
HOURS TO RECEIVE TESTING AND
THEN WHEN TESTING FOLLOWED AND
THEN WE HAD BACK SCENES. YOU
NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
VEHICLE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS AND YOU NEEDED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO A SMARTPHONE TO EVEN
BE ABLE TO MAKE. THE
APPOINTMENT- CLEARLY THAT DID
NOT RESULT IN OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES RECEIVING
ACCESS BECAUSE MOST OF HOME.
TAKE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION TO
TAKE THE BUS. OR IF THEY DON'T
HAVE A SMARTPHONE. THEY DIDN'T
HAVEACCESS TO ACTUALLY EVEN
MAKE AN APPOINTMENT. IF THEY
DIDN'T SPEAK ENGLISH THEY WERE
CERTAINLY CUT OFF BECAUSE OF
LACK OF LANGUAGE ACCESS. AND SO
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A CENTER FOR
GOVERNMENT EXCELLENCE I'M
CURIOUS AS TO WHAT THAT ACTUALLY
LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE THIS. FIRST
FACILITY. WAS IN MY DISTRICTBUT
IT WAS NOT FOR MY DISTRICT AND
SO I THINK. I WANT TO POINT OUT
HOW WILL THE CENTER ACTUALLY
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY IN WHICH
GOVERNMENT TREATS CONSTITUENTS
AND THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
MORE EQUITABLE WAY. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK-
I'M SURE AND THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD LOOK AT
IN IN THE SHAPE OF A PILOT-
WHERE WE COULD SEE WHERE.
LOOKING AT PROBLEMS IN PLACE TO
OUR- CREATE GREATER ACCESS AND
TO CREATE ACCESS ON A- MORE
REGULAR AND CONSISTENT BASIS I
MEAN WE'VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT-
REACHING OUT TO HARD TO FIND
COMMUNITIES THROUGH OUR SENSES
WORK- AS WELL THROUGH. THE
VACCINATION WORK THAT ARE-
SECRETARY LED TO- AS WELL AS THE
EMERGENCY BROADBAND. OF BENEFIT
BUT- THE CENTER WOULD UP TO TAKE
THOSE LESSONS. AND TO PUT THEM
IN A WAY THAT COULD BE MORE
EASILY SHARED ACROSS GOVERNMENT
. EITHER THROUGH A PILOT OR
THROUGH- A CASE STUDY OR A BEST
PRACTICES DOCUMENT. BUT PART OF
THE POWER OF HAVING THE
PARTICULARLY IN IN THE AGENCY
LEVEL. IS TO- THE ABILITY TO
COORDINATE AND CONVENE. AND THAT
THAT'S WHERE WE CAN GET PEOPLE
FROM THE OUTSIDE. AS WELL AS
PEOPLE FROM WITHIN THE STATE TO
KIND OF WORK THROUGH THESE
ISSUES AND COME UP. WITH A- THE
STRATEGY PARTICULARLY ONE OF THE
KEY PIECES OF THE GET CENTER IS
THE INVOLVEMENT OF THE CONTROL
AGENCIES- AND TO GET THEM TO
COORDINATE. AND ALIGN THEIR
THEIR- THEIR PRIORITIES AND THIS
IS A WAY WE COULD BUILD-
INFRASTRUCTURE IN TERMS OF
REGULATIONS AND STANDARDS. AND
GUIDANCE- CHU CHU TAKE A BETTER
AND MORE EFFECTIVE- YOU KNOW.
BUT ABILITY TO DO THIS KIND
ABOUT REGION CERTAIN PEOPLE WITH
I MEAN THIS IS- THIS IS
SOMETHING WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT A WITH WITH- THE WHOLE
BROADBAND ISSUE WHICH WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO REACH INTO
COMMUNITIES- AND DIFFERENT HAVE
DIGITAL SERVICES AND ASK PEOPLE
TO USE- YOU KNOW MODERN
TECHNOLOGIES WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO REACH THEM AND THEY HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. IN
CALIFORNIA- GOVERNMENT CULTURE
AS AS AS WELL AS ANYBODY WHO
LIVES WITH WITH VERY QUICK AND-
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER I. YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S- IT'S
INTERESTING TO CREATE A NEW
CENTER FOR GOVERNMENT THE CENTER
FOR GOVERNMENT EXCELLENCE AND IT
SOUNDS REALLY GREAT. BUT YOU
DON'T NEED TO CREATE A CENTER TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THAT CAN TELL YOU
DIRECTLY HOW COLD IT IS
IMPACTING OUR COMMUNITIES. I
THINK THE YOU SPOKE ABOUT A
COORDINATED EFFORT WITH THIS
PARTICULAR- CENTER. BUT THE
COORDINATED EFFORT IN THE
OPPORTUNITY ALREADY EXISTS IF
THE ADMINISTRATION SIMPLY
ACTUALLY COORDINATED AND
COMMUNICATED. NEEDS AND GOALS
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
MEMBERS THAT REPRESENT THESE
COMMUNITIES. AND SO I SAW THAT
THAT WAS A COMPLETE- LACK OF
SAFETY NET FOR MANY OF US
ESPECIALLY THOSE THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE HIT
HARDEST BY COLD AT MINE
INCLUDED. I REPRESENTATIVE SAID
IT MULTIPLE TIMES IN THIS
HEARING. I REPRESENT A COMMUNITY
THAT HAS TWENTY PERCENT. BELOW
THE NATIONAL POVERTY LINE MAKES
STATUS UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES.
THE CENSUS COUNT WAS INCREDIBLY
LOW IN OUR COMMUNITY SO WE KNOW
THAT THE RESOURCES ARE NOT GOING
TO BE THERE ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WAYS IN WHICH THE STATE CAN
BE RESPONSIVE. AND YET. BASIC
SOLUTIONS LIKE. COMMUNITY
CLINICS OR SCHOOL SITES THAT
ENABLE BETTER ABLE TO PROVIDE
WALKABLE. CLOSE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MULTI GENERATIONAL FAMILIES
TO BE ABLE TO GET TESTED AND GET
THE VACCINE. DIDN'T EXIST UNTIL
WE PUSHED AND PUSHED AND PUSHED.
AND SO IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN
INTERESTING TO SAY THE LEAST. TO
TRY TO FIND EQUITABLE SOLUTIONS
THAT THOSE OF US TO COME FROM
THE DISTRICT THAT WE REPRESENT.
CAN QUICKLY ARTICULATE- IN NEED
AND RESOURCES AND YET HERE WE
ARE CREATING MORE DEPARTMENTS TO
CREATE DATA TO CREATE
COORDINATED EFFORTS. WHEN WE
COULD HAVE DONE IT SOONER AND SO
FOR ME I WANT TO ASK YOU THE
QUESTION LIKE. WHAT DOES-
EXCELLENCE IN GOVERNANCE LOOK
LIKE TO YOU. IT'S JUST HARD TO
GET AND I THINK- GOOD VERY GOOD
QUESTION A VERY GOOD
CONVERSATION. SPECIALLY WHEN IT
RELATES TO. ANY SUCH AS LANGUAGE
ACCESS WHAT THE GOAL OF THE GET
CENTER IS TO DO IS TO FIND THOSE
THINGS AND STATE GOVERNMENT THAT
WORK WELL IN AND HOW DO WE SCALE
ENACTMENT COLUSA LANGUAGE ACCESS
SOME DEPARTMENTS DO A LOT BETTER
THAN OTHERS AT LANGUAGE ACCESS
AS IT RELATES TO THEIR PROGRAMS
AND HOW. AND THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
WORLD OUT TO THE PUBLIC PEOPLE I
STATE SERVICES AND SO WHAT WE'LL
DO IS WE'LL TAKE THOSE PROGRAM
SEE HOW THEY CURRENTLY WORK MORE
STAFF WILL THEN. WORK ACROSS THE
CONTROL AGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO
HELP IMPLEMENT THE BEST
PRACTICES WE CAN SCALE STATEWIDE
SO THAT THE CONSTITUENTS THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO WE'LL HAVE
THAT EQUITABLE ACCESS TO-
WHETHER IT'S VACCINES SERVICES
THREE SERVICES FOR THAT MATTER
AT THE STATE AND THAT IS KIND OF
A BALL HERE SO THAT WE HAVE A
WAR ORDINATED CONSISTENT
APPROACH WITH THINGS SUCH AS-
LANGUAGE ACCESS. JUST OTHER TAXI
OPERATION TO THESE ARE ALL TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION EVERYONE BE
TREATED THE SAME THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SO THAT IS THE GOAL HERE
AND THE STAFF THERE WILL HELP US
TO DO THAT TO RUN THESE PILOTS
AND TROOPS TO RUN THESE PROGRAMS
IN IN ABOUT A WEEK THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE OPERATIONS. OF ALL STATE
PARK. THANK YOU I THINK WITH
JUST START THE BAT WITH EIGHTY.
KELLY I C. DMV YOU DON'T NEED TO
ANOTHER. CENTER FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
THOSE ARE SOME. VERY DIRECT
THINGS SO WE CAN START WORKING
ON ACCESS TO CLINICS. ACCESS TO-
MORE DOCTORS IN THE MEDICAL
SPACE WE HAVE NOW INCREASED
ACCESS TO MEDICAL TO.
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS AS WELL
BUT- WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
OPPORTUNITY THERE WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE DOCTORS AVAILABLE AND SO. I
GET IT I UNDERSTAND BUT I CAN I
AM HEARING MORE MORE FOR LACK OF
A BETTER TERM. HURDLES TO
GETTING TO ACCESS AND GETTING TO
EQUITY UP BY. VERSUS LIKE THE
REALITY THAT. THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE KNOW WHAT OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED AND SO I HOPE
THAT THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO PLAYS A
ROLE IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT. OR NOT- I SHOULD
SAY. YEAH I THINK THAT'S A VERY
GOOD THAT YOU JUST MADE WE WOULD
LOVE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON SOME AREAS WHERE
THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IMPROVEMENTS IN STATE OPERATIONS
THIS IS A- DEFINITELY A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH AND
EVERYONE. HAS REALLY GOOD IDEAS
ON WHERE WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING
OUR EFFORTS RELATED TO THE
PILOTS THAT WE'RE GOING TO.
ENGAGE IN FUTURE. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JIM AND MUCH
APPRECIATED I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF- THAT'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY THERE ESPECIALLY
WITH LANGUAGE ACCESS WHICH WE
KNOW IS. IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
AS WELL AS TECHNOLOGY AXIS. AS
WELL THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ISSUE SIXTEEN OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS. WE WILL
BEGIN A WIN- THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH MR
SAMUELSON. GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
IS IN MY CAMERA IS NOT WORKING
YOU DON'T SEE MAYBE YOU COULD
SEE ME NOW BETTA. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. OR CARRY OUT GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN I'LL BE REALLY QUICK-
I'LL START WITH THE- PRESENTING
THE- OKAY ARTS PROPOSED
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND
STRATEGIC COMMUNICATIONS THE NEW
UP PROPOSED OFFICE. I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND- COMPOUND RESEARCH-
B. SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL BASED ON- COSTS OR
COSTS FROM THE STATE'S PREVIOUS
OFFENCES AND CORBETT NINETEEN
INITIATIVES WOULD CREATE THE-
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
AND STRATEGIC COMMUNICATIONS. TO
MANAGE- PRIMARILY THE STATE'S
HIGHEST PRIORITY PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND COMMUNITY OUTREACH
CAMPAIGNS. AS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS. RESPONSE THE
STATE INVESTED IN BUILDING
CRITICAL OUTREACH AND
COMMUNICATIONS INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR REACHING COMMUNITIES THAT
EXPERIENCED THE HIGHEST SOCIAL
AND HEALTH INEQUITIES. A POST
OFFICE WOULD BUILD UPON THIS
WORK AND DIRECTLY TACKLE THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY BOTH THE
STATE AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS IN
HELPING TO DRIVE MAJOR
INITIATIVES THROUGH TEMPORARY OR
POP POP. INFRASTRUCTURES THE
PROPOSED ONGOING FUNDING WOULD
ESTABLISH PERMANENT PARTNERSHIPS
THAT STRENGTHEN. COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT. OKAY ARE IS AN
INTERSECTIONAL SIX BODY ADULT
REGULARLY CONVENES CABINET LEVEL
EITHER SHIP OUT TO ADDRESS CROSS
CUTTING ISSUES SO HOUSING THAT
OFFICER OPR- THAT IS
APPROPRIATE- IT IS ALSO A
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LEVERAGE OTHER PROGRAMS UNDER
THE OFFICE OF CHARLES- THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL. I'LL
STOP ABOUT INTO WE HAD A YEAR
LEFT SPEND DENTAL CARE STUFF AND
MYSELF. THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN
WE HAVE THE OF FIND PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR KEVIN
CLARK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE CAN- WITH.
ASSESSMENT IN JUST ONE
UNDERSCORE THAT OPR OR REGULATE
ALREADY REGULARLY CONVENES
CABINET LEVEL LEADERSHIP TO
ADDRESS TO CROSS DEPARTMENTAL
ISSUES. AND HAS THE EXPERIENCE
AND RELATIONSHIPS TO OVERSEE
EFFECTIVE STATEWIDE CAMPAIGNS.
LET'S OPR IS REALLY WELL
POSITIONED OVERSEAS THE NEW
OFFICE THAT WE'RE PROPOSING- AS
A PURIST CHARGE AN EXPERTISE IS
BASED ON LONG RANGE PLANNING AND
CROSS DEPARTMENTAL HIGHLY
COMPLEX PROJECTS SUCH AS- THESE
THAT REPORTING. I DON'T LIKE TO
JUST TAKE A QUICK MOMENT TO-
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THE L. A. O. IS PRESENTED- IN
REGARDS TO- WHAT AMOUNT OF
PLANNING IS NECESSARY- THIS
AMOUNT OF FUNDING IS BUILT
AROUND A BUDGET. THAT'S THE
STATE'S LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS
THROUGHOUT CYCLES OF CAMPAIGNS
AND RATHER THAN STANDING UP
PARTNERSHIPS FOR EACH SPECIFIC
NEW CAMPAIGN. AND GIVEN THE
COMPLEX NATURE OF THIS PROPOSAL
THE ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
DO THE WORK OF EVALUATING
OVERALL RESOURCE NEEDS AND
COSTS. AND SO THIS INCLUDES
EVALUATING ONGOING. POSITIONS IN
RESOURCE NEEDS ADMINISTRATION
XTERRA PLANS ON PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL DETAILS AS PART OF
THE SPRING PROCESS- IN TERMS OF
THE LEGISLATURE OVERSEEING THE
NEW OFFICE R. AS YOU'LL NOTE WE
PROPOSE THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONSIDERATION. IN OUR
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT IT STRIKES
AN APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
PROVIDING ADMINISTRATION WITH
FLEXIBILITY AND MINISTERING THE
OFFICE. IS ALSO ARE CLEARLY
ARTICULATING THE PARAMETERS OF
THE OFFICE MISSION AND THE SCOPE
OF THEIR WORK- THAT WERE OPEN TO
FEEDBACK AND CONTINUE
CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE T. B. L. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT. THE BILL LANGUAGE
EXPLICITLY REQUIRES THE OFFICE
TO RATE- POTENTIAL CAMPAIGNS
BASED ON. EIGHT OF YOU HAVE-
EVALUATION METRICS AND THAT'S
CLEARLY ARTICULATED IN TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. THANK YOU L. L.
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON FRIEND
WHAT THE COURT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
FIND THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
IDENTIFIED A LEGITIMATE NEED
WITH THIS PROPOSAL BUT WE'RE NOT
SURE THAT THE PROPOSAL ADDRESSES
THIS NEED BY SHOULD YOU AGREE
THAT THIS CONCEPT HAS MERIT
THERE ARE SEVERAL IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATIONS ON WHICH WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD WEIGH IN
ON INCLUDING MORE THAN ENTITIES
SHOULD BE LOCATED WHAT AMOUNT OF
ONGOING FUNDING IS JUSTIFIED. BY
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND HOW AND WHETHER
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD WEIGH IN
ON HOW THE NEW ENTITY SUCH A
COVERAGE PROPERTIES AND HOW
WOULD THE NEW ENTITY COORDINATE
WITH OTHER STATE AGENCIES- ARE
FULL COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSAL
IN THE AGENDA. AND ALL STOCK
HERE BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO DISCUSS
ANY OF THESE CONSIDERATIONS AND
WE'RE TO TALK IT LIKE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ALSO COMMEND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR RECOGNIZING
THE IMPORTANCE. OF CONTINUING TO
REACH OUT TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND I'M HOPING THAT
WE IN THE ASSEMBLY. CAN BE A
PARTNER I THINK THAT'S A
CONTINUED AND RECURRING THEME.
AND THAT OF THE LEGISLATURE
SPECIFICALLY OUR HOUSE. HAS A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES TO BE ABLE
TO ENGAGE AND PROVIDE
INSIGHTFUL. A DISTRICT FOCUSED
LENS THAT CAN HOPEFULLY. BE ABLE
TO- PROVIDE SOME INSIGHT. TO
WHAT THE GOAL IS NOT TO
RECOGNIZING. AND NOT REACHING TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO
WITH THAT EFFORT. HOW WILL
APPEAR TO BE TARGETING THESE
COMMUNITIES WHAT IS THE GAME
PLAN ON THE GROUND. SO I CAN
TAKE ON THAT SO WE'VE DEVELOPED
CRITERIA BY WHICH WE WOULD-
SELECT- IT IS- OUTLINED IN THE
TRAILER BILL. WE HAVE- A FEW
CRITERIA THAT ARE THAT ARE
OUTLINED AROUND EQUITY FOR
EXAMPLE THE ABILITY TO TARGET
AUDIENCES BUT OUR- THAT INCLUDE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED OR
EXPERIENCE THE GREATEST HEALTH
AND SOCIAL INEQUITIES- ANOTHER
CREDITOR CRITERIAS DATA INFORMED
DECISION SO. FOR EXAMPLE
RESPECTIVE AGENCIES STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS THAT
HAVE AND OR CON PROVIDE ISSUE. A
SPECIFIC DATA TO INFORM STRATEGY
AND- EVALUATION. THAT ACTIONABLE
AREAS ARE ONE OF THE CRITERIA
ISSUES THAT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE RELIABLE AND
ACTIONABLE INFORMATION AND
RESOURCES THAT CAN EMPOWER
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. A FOURTH
ONE IS RISK SEVERITY AND URGENCY
. AT THIS ARE ISSUES THAT
PRESENT A THREAT OR CONCERN FOR
THE LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS OF THE
TARGETED AUDIENCE- OUR AUDIENCES
. F. FIFTH ONE IS CROSS AGENCY
COORDINATION AND THIS IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE IN PART OF
WARRANTY- OPR IS AN APPROPRIATE
PLACE- WE CONSTANTLY ENGAGE IN
THAT PROCESS- AGENCY
COORDINATION SO THIS WILL BE
ISSUES THAT REQUIRE COORDINATION
AND COLLABORATION ACROSS
MULTIPLE AGENCIES. OR
DEPARTMENTS I MENTIONED THAT
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL FOR
EXAMPLE BETTER SEVEN AGENCIES
THAT ARE REPRESENTED JUSTIN DOT
BUCKET BUT THE OFFICE WORKS
ACROSS MANY AGENCIES AND THEN
LAST ONE EMERGING- MERCHANT
MATTERS AND THEN- OUTCOMES
ISSUES THAT HAVE CLEAR AND
MEASURABLE GOALS. AND WE HAVE A
SHORT TIME BUT ALSO THE KEY
CRITERIA THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
BUT WE WILL DEFINITELY WORK WITH
TH LEGISLATURE. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF THE PROGRAM
DEVELOPS TO IDENTIFY. THE WAY-
COMPANIES. GET SELECTED. THANK
YOU FOR THE AS THIS IS AN
INITIAL THAT PART OF THE
GOVERNOR OFFICE VERSUS A STATE
DEPARTMENT. THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
FLOODING CONCERNS REGARDING THE
CONTINUING OF THE PROGRAM BEYOND
OUR CURRENT GOVERNOR'S TERM. HOW
CAN YOU HELP HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS. THE I'M SORRY FOR THE
FACT THAT THIS IS THAT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. VERSUS THE
DEPARTMENT. YES SO AGAIN THERE'S
NO OTHER AGENCY THAT HAS THE
SINGLE- THAT THAT- STRUCTURE
THAT REALLY REACHES OUT TO ALL
CROSS CUTTING ISSUES I THINK OPR
BY STATUES ACTUALLY CREATED TO
ADAPT AND TO ADVISE BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR AND
NOT HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY THE
WORK IT HAS BEEN DOING BUT I
THINK THE CENTRAL ISSUE IS.
THERE IS NO BETTER STRUCTURE
WITHIN THIS ESTATE AGENCIES THAT
HAS THE MOST- CROSSCUTTING
ISSUES THAT OPR AS PART OF ITS
START YOU UP TO THE- ENGAGES IN
SO. THAT WE WOULD DEFINITELY- IT
MAY BE NAMED BUT STRUCTURE AS
THE OFFICE OF THE GOVERNOR BUT
IT IS PRETTY MUCH ALMOST- AT AN
AGENCY THAT SURPRISING AND
ADVISES- BOTH ARE BRANCHES. AND
HOW IS THE SIXTY FIVE MILLION-
DOLLAR AMOUNT CREATED WHERE DID
THAT COME ABOUT. SO THOSE BASED
ON THE LESSONS FONG A LOT THE
LAST CENSUS AND CORBETT- THERE
IS MUCH LARGER AMOUNTS
IDENTIFIED THERE SO THE SIXTY
FIVE WAS BASED ON THAT-
EXPERIENCE AND A LOT OF THE- AND
SO CURRENTLY IT'S DIVIDED INTO.
POTENTIALLY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO- FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR STATE OPERATIONS THE
FIFTY MILLION IT I BELIEVE
ALMOST HALF OF WHAT WAS- THAT-
THAT SENSES OKAY WELL FROM THE
PREVIOUS PROGRAM. I THINK I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT
UP- THE CENSUS QUITE A BIT IN IN
THE CONVERSATION. SO MY DISTRICT
IS ONE OF THE LOWEST COUNTED IN
THE CENSUS AS I'VE MENTIONED A
COUPLE OF TIMES NOW AND THIS
BUDGET HEARING JUST BASED ON THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE. EXPERIENCED
CODED WELL WE'RE ALSO
EXPERIENCING EXPERIENCED THE
CENSUS COUNT AND SO WE KNOW THAT
THE NUMBERS ARE MUCH LOWER
ESPECIALLY IN UNINCORPORATED
EAST LOS ANGELES AND ON THE EAST
SIDE IN GENERAL. SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING SOUTH LOS
ANGELES ALSO- EXPERIENCE THE
SAME I WOULD I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THAT MAYBE WE LOOK AT CENSUS
TRACTS AND THE CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICTS THAT. WERE VASTLY
MOVED AND SHIFTED BECAUSE OF
CENSUS AND MY SIDE OF THE- THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES WE ACTUALLY
LOST A HISTORIC SEAT AND I WAS
THE SEAT OF. CONGRESSWOMAN
LUCILLE ROYBAL ALLARD. BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF- BECAUSE OF THE
LOWER NUMBER THRESHOLD- TO THE
CENSUS SO. I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU
START. IN AREAS LIKE FINE AND
OTHERS ACROSS THE DISTRICT IN
WHICH WE KNOW CENSUS NUMBERS ARE
MUCH LOWER THAN WHAT WE KNOW
ACTUALLY IS THE LIVED
EXPERIENCE. OF THE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND SO CAN I HOPE
THAT'S HELPFUL AT LEAST IN SOME
GUIDANCE. IN WHERE TO GET
STARTED AND I KNOW I'M NOT THE
ONLY ONE ACROSS THE STATE BUT-
BECAUSE WE EXPERIENCED A
SPECIFIC LOSS OF A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS- AND THE EXPANSION OF
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS BECAUSE
OF IT. I THINK IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR THAT TO BE
RECOGNIZED. YEAH I THINK IT'S SO
THE CENTRAL PART OF THIS
THINKING I THINK IS HOW DO WE
SUPPORT THE CBO SAID LOCAL
COMMUNITY SO WHEN I SAY FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS TO SUPPORT.
THAT TO. CREATE LOCAL RESOURCES
AND MAKE THAT PERMANENT IS NO
ONE KNOWS THE LOCAL ISSUES
BETTER BETTER BETTER THAN THE
CBO. WE WANT TO FORMALIZE THAT.
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU'RE RAISING OF THE UNDER
COUNTY- ISSUES. THEY ARE MORE
TRUSTED DONE OBVIOUSLY- OTHER
CONSULTANTS OR GOVERNMENTS-
OPERATIONS SO WE WANT TO BUILD
ON THE TRUST. AND RESOURCE OF
LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HELP AGAIN
MORE THRUST AND WE'RE- HOPING IT
OUT BUT WE BELIEVE. THAT WOULD
HAVE MORE. AND OFF IN THE
COMMENTS BUT I TAKE YOUR POINT
THAT IS- AND SPECIALLY NOW WITH.
REDISTRICTING IT IS AN ISSUE AND
IN TERMS OF WHERE WE START WILL
DEFINITELY WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO- ONE THREE IN A-
WORK ON THE DETAILS- OF. THE
SELECTION PROCESS. AS THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS ON THE
GROUND I APPRECIATE YOU SAY THAT
SAYING THAT ARE ALSO INCREDIBLY
OVERWORKED AND UNDERFUNDED. AND
SO IT'S ADDING ON TO ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES AND PRESSURES
AND SO IF WE ARE GOING TO DO
THAT THEN WE SHOULD FIGURE OUT A
WAY THAT WE ALSO FUND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE GOOD
PARTNERS. TO THE WORK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS HOPING TO DO
IN AN EFFORT TO BE ABLE TO HELP
AS MANY CALIFORNIANS AS POSSIBLE
. YEAH AND THEN THE WHAT'S WAS
REMARKABLE IN THE PREVIOUS A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGING OF THE
CENSUS WAS OR THE OUTREACH
THROUGH CORBETT WAS- THE- STOCK
THAT'D BE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF AGENCIES. I BUILD A
SIGNIFICANT DATABASE ABOUT FIVE
CBO ORGANIZATIONS. SO WE DON'T
WANT TO LOSE THAT AND COME BACK
AND- YOU KNOW FIVE YEARS TO TEN
YEARS LATER RATHER WE- RESOURCE
GOALS AND WORK WITH THEM. TO HOW
ABOUT CONTINUATION AND
FORMALIZATION- I'VE SAID THIS
BEFORE- PREVIOUSLY- OTHER STATES
ARE LOOKING TO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT AS WELL BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF FUN- WORKING FACT BE OF
COLD AND IN SOME CASES BECAUSE
OF A SENSE OF SELF I THINK THIS
STATE AND THIS PROPOSAL IS I
BELIEVE THE HEAD OF- OTHER.
STATES THAT A LOT OF PLACES ARE
LOOKING TO FORMALIZE THIS KIND
OF ENGAGEMENT AND RESOURCE LOCAL
PPO. FOR THIS PURPOSE HERE
DIRECTOR SEVEN MUCH APPRECIATED
AND I AGAIN I WANT TO DO I WANT
TO MAKE TAKE A MOMENT TO COMMEND
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE QUEUE
IN THE CREATION OF THE TREE
PROGRAM WHICH HELPED
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES RECEIVE
SOME SMALL BENEFITS- IN THE
START OF- IN THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC WHICH A LOT OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WERE A HUGE PART. IN MAKING SURE
THAT FUNDING WAS ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD TO MOVE QUICKLY SO I DO
AGREE THAT THERE'S A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY THERE IF IT'S DONE
APPROPRIATELY SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO
THE PANELIST ON ISSUE NUMBER.
SIXTEEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE MOVE
FORWARD WE HAVE. THREE MORE TO
GO BEFORE WE ARE ALMOST DONE
WITH OUR HEARING FOR TODAY. WE
ARE NOW ON ISSUE SEVENTEEN WITH
CAROLINE TEARS WE'RE GONNA START
WITH MR JOSH FRIDAY. THANK YOU
AND GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS JOSH FRIDAY AND THE
CHIEF SERVICE OFFICER FOR
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS. AND
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS THIS YEAR
CURRENTLY HAS THREE BUDGET
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION ONE IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE ACTION
COURT. TO IS A NEIGHBOR TO
NEIGHBOR PROGRAM AND THREE IS
THE FOSTER GRANDPARENTS AND
SENIOR COMPANIONS PROGRAM.
STARTING UP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE ACTION COURT THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL SEEKS TO MAKE ONGOING
THE LIMITED TERM INVESTMENT OF
THREE POINT EIGHT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN A PROGRAMMATIC
CLIMATE PROGRAMS. FOR A TOTAL
ONGOING REQUEST A FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS THIS
INITIAL APPROPRIATION RECEIVED
IN THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROVIDED
ONGOING STAFF IN ONLY THREE
YEARS OF FUNDING. FOR PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION AND NOW WE'RE
REQUESTING THAT THIS
PROGRAMMATIC FUNDING BE ON GOING
TO ENSURE THE SUSTAINABILITY OF
THE PROGRAM. THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM LET LEVERAGES FEDERAL
AMERICORPS FUNDING AND WHILE
IT'S STILL IN ITS EARLY STAGES
THE INTEREST IN THIS PROGRAM HAS
BEEN SUBSTANTIAL WITH MORE
INTEREST IN APPLICATIONS AND
POSITIONS PRESS THE BILL. AND
WE'VE ALSO SEEN THE SUCCESS OF
THIS PROGRAM IT'S RECENTLY BEEN
WRITTEN ABOUT AS A MODEL FOR A
POTENTIAL NATIONAL CLIMATE COURT
IT'S BEING WATCHED AND STUDIED
BY THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE NEW
SOME ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES
THAT THIS PROGRAM WILL BE
CRITICAL. TO MEETING OUR STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS WE HAVE PROVIDED
INITIAL OUTCOMES AND IMPACTS AND
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE FURTHER
INFORMATION ON THE SUCCESS OF
THIS PROGRAM. IN ADDITION
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS WILL
DEVELOP AN ANNUAL REPORT THAT
PROVIDES A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW
OF THE OUTCOMES HOW ARE FUNDING
AS LEVERAGE AND ANALYZES. THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM.
THEN THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR- BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN THE FOSTER
GRANDPARENTS AND SENIOR
COMPANIONS BUDGET PROPOSALS.
THEY BUILD ON THE SUCCESS WHICH
WE HAVE HAD DURING THE PANDEMIC
ACTIVATING CALIFORNIANS TO SERVE
AND TACKLE SOME OF OUR GREATEST
CHALLENGES OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS. DURING THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS LUNCH THE
NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR PROGRAM
LEVERAGING PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
DISASTER FUNDING. AND NOW WE ARE
REQUESTING TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING FUNDING TO MAINTAIN
THIS PROGRAM AND THE BILL THAT
OUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO FOR
FUTURE DISASTERS AS WELL AS TO
MEET OTHER STATE PRIORITIES.
THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE OUR
NEIGHBORS TO BE THE FIRST LINE
OF SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS TO CONNECT
NEIGHBORS TO TAKE ACTION AND TO
SUPPORT EACH OTHER. SHORTLY
AFTER WE LAUNCHED THE PROGRAM
DURING COBIT. MY OFFICE MEDIC
COUPLE FROM- THE INLAND REGION
THAT HAS LEFT A LASTING
IMPRESSION ON ALL OF US ANDI
THINK DEMONSTRATES THE WAY THIS
PROGRAM. CAN HAVE AN IMPACT WILL
HAVE AN IMPACT I REMEMBER JEAN
WHO IS EIGHTY FIVE YEARS OLD THE
TIME HER HUSBAND BEN A NINETY
TWO YEAR OLD. WORLD WAR TWO
VETERAN WITH CONGESTIVE HEART
FAILURE HAD BEEN UNDER SELF
QUARANTINE FOR WEEKS STARTED TO
RUN OUT OF FOOD AND SUPPLIES.
AND AFTER NOT BEING ABLE TO FIND
A LOCAL STORE TO DELIVER TO
THEIR HOME JEAN ACTUALLY REACHED
OUT THE NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR
PROGRAM TO CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS. AND BECAUSE OF THIS
PROGRAM WE WERE ABLE TO ALL THE
MOVIE ARRANGE THE DELIVERY OF
MILK. AEGS TOILET PAPER AND
OTHER GOODS TO THE COUPLE SO
THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC AND AS
WELL AS OTHERS DISASTERS. WE
HAVE LEARNED AND WE HAVE SEEN
THE CRITICAL NATURE OF
EMPOWERING NEIGHBORS TO HELP
EACH OTHER. AND WE ARE EXCITED
TO BUILD THIS OUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- AS WE SEE BEING CRITICAL
FOR ISSUES AND ACTIVITIES ALSO
BEYOND JUST DISASTER WEATHER AND
CLIMATE ACTION. FIGHTING
POVERTY. OR MEETING OTHER
COMMUNITY NEEDS. LASTLY THE
FOSTER GRANDPARENTS AND SENIOR
COMPANIONS BUDGET PROPOSAL IS A
ONE TIME PILOT TO EXPAND THESE
AMERICORPS PROGRAMS. AND AS YOU
MAY KNOW- THE CALIFORNIA ON. ARE
THE LARGE AMERICO AMERICORPS
PORTFOLIO IN THE COUNTRY SO THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ESTABLISH A
PASSED THROUGH A TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COMPETITIVELY
APPLY. FOR IN OUR WARD IT GRANTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE TWO
PROGRAM MODELS. WHILE THE
TYPICAL DEMOGRAPHICS OF
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS AMERICORPS
MEMBERS. ARE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AGES EIGHTEEN TO THIRTY. THIS IS
AN INVESTMENT THAT BUILT ON
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS LEADERSHIP
AND SRVICE. AND COMPREHENSIVELY
EXPAND SERVICE OPPORTUNITIES TO
ORDER CALIFORNIANS. AS WITH ALL
THESE PROPOSALS AND ALL OF OUR
OTHER PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS REMAINS VERY
COMMITTED. TO SHOWING OUR IMPACT
DEMONSTRATING AN IMPACT AND
DELIVERING ON THE INTENT OF
THESE INITIATIVES AND LIFTING
UP. ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES I'M
ALSO JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE I
HEAR ANTHONY CHAVEZ. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THESE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU MISS FRIDAY
LET'S GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PLACE- KEVIN CLARK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE WE
CONCUR WITH STEVIE'S- COMMENTS
UP TO THIS POINT AND WE JUST
POINT OUT. TO RESPOND WILL BE
THE L. A. S. COMMENTS THAT BOTH
OUR CLIMATE ACTION CORPS AND
FOSTER PARENTS AND SENIOR
VOLUNTEER PROGRAM PROPOSALS.
HAVE INCLUDED- PRIOR OUTCOMES
FROM PRIOR INVESTMENTS AND CV IS
PROVIDED INTERIM REPORTING LIKE
I MENTIONED FOR THEIR CLIMATE
ACTION CORPORATE GRAHAM. AND WE
ALSO JUST NOTES AS DID THE L. A.
O. WITH THEIR COMMENTS THAT CV'S
CHARGE. INCLUDES DISASTER
RESPONSE AND THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
FIT SQUARELY WITHIN US
CALIFORNIA MONSTERS OVERSIGHT.
THANK YOU I'LL- BRIAN WITH A
BIRD WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS EXPANDED STATE
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
IT'S BOARD OF COMMISSIONERS AND
IT'S INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THE CALIFORNIA%
VOLUNTEERS FUND WHICH RECEIVES
PRIVATE SECTOR DONATIONS TO. TO
PREPARE N ANNUAL REPORT TO
PROVIDE AN ACCOUNTING OF ALL OF
ITS ACTIVITIES VOLUNTEER
MEMBERSHIP AND FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS AND IT THIS REPORT
SHOULD BE PROVIDED TO THE FISCAL
COMMITTEES OF BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE BE MADE READILY
AVAILABLE ON ITS WEBSITE. AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSIVENESS OF
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS TO THESE
CONCERNS- PREVIOUSLY DURING THIS
BUDGET CYCLE AND THEY HAVE
PROVIDED INITIAL REPORTING ON
THEIR- NEWER INITIATIVES. ON
THAT SAID WE DO RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
IN PERMANENTLY ESTABLISHED THE
NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR. FINISHED
IF. WE DO SEE IT AS A AS A BIT
OF AN EXPANSION OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES BEYOND
ADMINISTERING THE STATE
AMERICORPS PROGRAMS AND
COORDINATING DISASTER RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY EFFORTS. BUT OTHER
STATE AGENCIES- SO CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS TRADITIONALLY SERVICE
ROLES FOR MAKING GRANTS THOSE
NONPROFITS IN CBO'S PLAY FOR
FUNDING. FOR THE AMERICA SERVICE
PROGRAMS. AND WITH THE NEIGHBOR
TO NEIGHBOR PROGRAM IT'S UNCLEAR
WHY- THE ADMINISTRATION. HAS BY
THERE'S A COMPELLING NEED FOR
THE STATE TO PROVIDE. THE NEW
COORDINATION OUTREACH MARKETING
AND TRAINING SERVICES THAT WERE
OUTLINED THIS PROPOSAL. SO WE
SUGGEST YOU ASK CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS TO EXPLAIN WHAT
ASPECTS OF ALL INTEREST IN THE
STATE ARE NOT WORKING WELL. AND
HOW THIS. PROPOSAL WOULD
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS
. ARE WE THINK IT'S- TO OUR- FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ACTION FOR
PROGRAM. HOWEVER SHOULD YOU
AGREE THAT THE- THE PROVIDING US
FIRM STATE COMMITMENT FOR THIS
FUNDING FUNDING FOR. GRAHAM
COULD BE BENEFICIAL LEVERAGING
THE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING
WE WOULD. INSTEAD RECOMMEND
PROVIDING ANOTHER ROUND OF THREE
YEARS OF TEMPORARY FUNDING THREE
TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. YEAH YOU SHOULD
ALSO PLAN TO REVIEW THE OUTCOMES
AND EFFECTIVENESS OF THE CLIMATE
ACTION CORPS PROGRAM IN SEVERAL
YEARS WHEN MORE INFORMATION IS.
MADE AVAILABLE TO YOU. AND
LASTLY WE DO NOT HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL FOR ONE TIME
FUNDING TO EXPAND THE FOSTER
GRANDPARENTS AND SENIOR
COMPANIONS PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE. RECENT STUDIES SHOW THAT
THESE PROGRAMS EXPAND SERVICE
OPPORTUNITIES TO A DIVERSE GROUP
OF PARTICIPANTS AND THE
PARTICIPANTS REPORTED FEWER
SYMPTOMS OF DEPRESSION. AND
FEELING LESS SOCIALLY ISOLATED.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER
WHETHER FOR TO FEEL LIKE YOU
WERE YOU WERE RUSHING THROUGH
YOUR PRESENTATION. S. AS WELL AS
WE'RE TRYING TO GET THROUGH OUR-
OUR LAST COUPLE OF PANELS HERE
MUCH APPRECIATED I- I AGREE WITH
SEVERAL OF YOUR COMMENTS AND I'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
TOO- MISTER FRIDAY AS WELL-
WILL- CAL POLY TEARS BE OPEN TO
CREATING A ANNUAL REPORT. THAT
PROVIDES THE DATA INDICATED. A
TO THE LEGISLATURE. YES MEDICARE. THANK YOU AND CAN YOU EXPLAIN
JUST BRIEFLY WHAT THE CALDERON
TEARS PROGRAMS CURRENTLY LOOK IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SPECIFICALLY L. A. COUNTY IF YOU
CAN. SURE SO ALL I'LL POINT OUT
THAT WHEN WE LAUNCHED THE
CLIMATE ACTION COURT- WHICH WAS
A FIRST IN THE NATION PROGRAM TO
ENGAGE EVERYONE IN CLIMATE
ACTION- WE FOCUSED ON A FEW
SPECIFIC FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE MOST IMPACTED BY- BY
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH EQUITY BEING
FRONT AND CENTER BOTH OF EQUITY
IN TERMS OF WHO WE ARE ENGAGING
IN OUR PROGRAM. AND EQUITY IN
TERMS OF WHAT COMMUNITIES WE ARE
INVESTING IN LOS ANGELES WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST AREAS AND IS ONE OF
OUR MOST ROBUST COMMUNITIES THAT
WE CURRENTLY ENGAGE WITH OUR
CLIMATE ACTION PROGRAM SO WE
HAVE A PROGRAM THROUGH OUT LA
CITY AND THROUGHOUT LA COUNTY-
THAT ARE VERY MUCH FOCUSED ON-
THINGS LIKE PROVIDING URBAN
GREENING PROGRAMS IN URBAN
FORESTRY PROGRAMS AND
COMMUNITIES. THAT WE KNOW HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY UNDER INVESTED
WHEN IT COMES TO TREE CANOPY
BECAUSE OF RED LIGHT HISTORY OF
REDLINING AND OTHER UNDER
INVESTMENT IN THESE COMMUNITIES
AND WE'RE VERY FOCUSED THERE
WERE ALSO FOCUSED ON DOING
THINGS LIKE FOOD RECOVERY BOTH
TO SUPPORT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES- IN REDIRECTING
EXTRA FOOD BUT ALSO TO DEAL.
WITH THE STATE'S GOALS AROUND
REDUCING FOOD WASTE- IS MEETING
OUR CLIMATE GOALS SO THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE ARE TAKING OUR
PROGRAMS AND VERY MUCH FOCUSING
IN PLACES LIKE L. A. COUNTY- IN
AN ALLEY CITY- WHERE WE NEED TO-
SUPPORT- COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN UNDER INVESTED HISTORICALLY
WE ALSO HAVE DOZENS OF- OF
AMERICORPS PROGRAMS THERE- IN IN
L. A. COUNTY IN IN THE REGION-
AND WE- ALSO JUST ANNOUNCED
RECENTLY. A COLLEGE COR PROGRAM
THAT ENGAGES IN PROGRAMS LIKE
KERN UNIVERSITIES LIKE UCLA CAL
STATE LA DOMINGUEZ HILLS- THE
COMMUNITY COMMENDED SEVERAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN LA TO
PROVIDE DEBT FREE PATHWAYS FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS WHO ARE ABLE
TO SERVE FOR A YEAR- WE ACTUALLY
LAUNCH THE PILOT FOR THIS
PROGRAM AT CAL STATE LA. TO
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY THERE- IT
A SPECIFICALLY. WE ALSO- HAVE
RECENTLY AND NOW THEY WERE DOING
A U. JOBS CORPS PROGRAM IN L. A.
COUNTY WERE INVESTING FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. TO HIRE LOW
INCOME YOUTH YOUTH THAT ARE
FORMING CARS RATED YOUTH THAT
HAVE BEEN TO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM YOUTH THAT ARE ARE HAVING
A DIFFICULT TIME GETTING IN THE
LABOR MARKET. TO REALLY LAUNCH
THEM ON A SUCCESSFUL CAREER AS A
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY SO WE ARE
HAPPY MEDICARE TO PROVIDE A FULL
ACCOUNTING OF EVERYTHING
HAPPENING IN LA. NOW THEY COUNTY
AND WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THE
INVESTMENTS. THAT WE'RE MAKING
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES. CAN YOU
SHARE BY NAME OR THE PARTNERS
THAT YOU HAVE ON THE GROUND AND
NÂNG- SO WE- ON THE CLIMATE SIDE
WE WORK WITH. GROUPS LIKE CITY
PLANTS. WE'RE WORKING WITH WHAT
WHAT'S RISING- IN LA WERE
WORKING- WITH LA THEY L. A.
RIVER GROUP- WE ARE- WE HAVE A
JUMPSTART IS ONE OF OUR
IMPORTANT. AIR CORPS PROGRAMS
THAT IS WORKING IN DOING-
EDUCATION WORK AND MENTORING
WORK- SO I THINK THAT THERE'S A
EXAMPLES OF A FEW BUT WE
LITERALLY FUND AND GRANTS TO
DOZENS OF ORGANIZATIONS IN LOS
ANGELES AND AGAIN WE'D BE HAPPY
TO PROVIDE. YOU IN YOUR OFFICE-
THAT COLISTIN AND ALL THE
DETAILS OF HOW MUCH WE'RE
INVESTING IN WHERE WE'RE
INVESTING. THANK YOU I THINK
WHAT I'M WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
A MISTER MISTER FRIDAY NOT ONLY
WITH WHAT YOU'RE PRESENTING
TODAY BUT WITH A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT WE HAVE HEARD
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING TODAY. IS
HOW THAT INFORMATION IS BEING
TRACED BACK TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT REPRESENTS.
THE SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES I
REPRESENT THE LOS ANGELES RIVER
THE UPPER L. A. RIVER. AROUND
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES LINCOLN
HEIGHTS IN CHINATOWN. I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT YOU ARE PROVIDING
GRANTS TO THE RIVER PARTNERS IN
MY DISTRICT AND SO I'M FEELING A
LITTLE- OUT OF THE LOOP ON
SOMETHING THAT BENEFITS MY
COMMUNITY DIRECTLY. AND SO I'M
I'M CURIOUS AS TO FIND OUT AS TO
HOW THIS INFORMATION IS BEING-
SHARED. AND HOW THOSE RESOURCES
ARE BEING SHARED WITH MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT REPRESENT
THESE COMMUNITIES. YEAH THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR ASKING THE
QUESTION AND THAT'S ON US AND I
WOULD. WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
YOU AND WITH OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE ANYTIME- WE'VE
WE'VE OFFERED TO COME AND SPEAK
TO THE ENTIRE CAUCUS- AND DO IT.
ABOUT PRESENTATION OF EVERYWHERE
THEY WERE INVESTING- BUT WE
FULLY TAKE TO HEART- YOUR I
THINK INVITATION TO- TO SIT DOWN
AND SHARE WHERE WE'RE INVESTING
WHO WERE INVESTING WITH THEM.
AND HOW REALLY WERE TRYING TO
LIFT UP THE COMMUNITIES THAT YOU
REPRESENT. AND THE HOPE IS THAT
AS WE'RE DOING THESE WE WORK
SIDE BY SIDE WITH YOU- TO MAKE
THESE PROGRAMS ACCESSIBLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
JOBS FOR- YOUNG PEOPLE. WHO ARE
HAVING A HARD TIME GETTING LABOR
MARKET IN YOUR DISTRICT- THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING THE ABILITY TO
TAKE CLIMATE ACTION AND- AND
RECEIVE A STIPEND AND THE
SCHOLARSHIP FOR COLLEGE IF YOU
DO TAKE CLIMATE ACTION. WITH
YOUR DISTRICT AND DEBT FREE
PATHWAYS TO LOW INCOME SCHOOL SO
WE'RE WE'RE DOING THESE PROGRAMS
AND- WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO-
TO BE MORE OPEN AND- TRANSPARENT. WITH YOU ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT
IS BEING INVESTED. DO YOU HAVE
INFORMATION READILY AVAILABLE TO
YOU WHEN PEOPLE TO PROVIDE THAT
CAN TELL ME. YOU KNOW FOR AND I
KNOW IT MIGHT BE CHALLENGING TO
GO DIRECTLY DISTRICT BY DISTRICT
BUT AT LEAST L. A. COUNTY OR THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. WHAT IS
YOUR VOLUNTEER BASE LIKE THE
KELOLAND HERE'S AN AND MY CITY
OR IN MY COUNTY ALONE. YEAH YES
WE CAN THE ANSWER IS YES- AND
WHAT I WILL SAY THOUGH THAT. I'M
SORRY WITH THAT. FIND THE MORE
THEY COME FROM HOW DO YOU OUT
REACH TO THEM. A LOT OF IT IS
WITH IN COORDINATION WITH
ORGANIZATIONS AND SO
SPECIFICALLY IN LA FOR INSTANCE
WE GRANT TO AND WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH L. A. WORKS. WE
ALSO GRANTING WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH CORE- AN ORGANIZATION BASED
IN LA AROUND AT PROVIDING
VOLUNTEERS FOR DISASTER RELIEF
EFFORTS SO WE WORK WITH THEM TO
RECRUIT VOLUNTEERS- IT'S ALSO
WHY FOR A NEIGHBOR TO NEIGHBOR
CAMPAIGN WE WANT TO HELP BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. US SO THAT
THAT WE CAN HELP TRAIN AND
IDENTIFY LOCAL LEADERS IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT CAN THEN DO THE
RECRUITING- AND ENGAGING OF
VOLUNTEERS- WE CAN IDENTIFY AND
PROVIDE INFORMATION BOUT WHAT
VOLUNTEERS WE HAVE RECRUITED A
LANE THAT IN FOR INSTANCE. THAT
WE FOCUSED AND SUPPORTING THE
FOOD BANKS WHICH IS A MAJOR
OPERATION THAT WE LED OPERATION
FEED DURING THE PANDEMIC TO
SUPPORT- THE LA FOOD BANK AMONG
MANY OTHERS- AS A RESULT IN WE
CAN GIVE YOU THE NUMBERS OF HOW
MANY VOLUNTEERS- WE'VE SUPPORTED
FOOD BANKS AND OTHER ACTIVITIES
WITH- THE TRUTH IS THOUGH- AND I
THINK THIS IS ALSO REFLECTED IN
SOME OF THE- REMARKS FROM THE L.
A. L. O. DESPITE THE FACT THAT
OUR NAME IS CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS- WE'RE JUST BEGINNING
TO BUILD OUT BECAUSE OF THE- THE
VERY RECENT- INVESTMENTS HAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE- WE'RE-
JUST BEGINNING TO BUILD OUT.
VOLUNTEER INFRASTRUCTURE AND ANY
ABILITY TO RECRUIT TRAIN OR KEEP
TRACK OF VOLUNTEERS AND SO AS WE
WERE STARTING- WE ARE BUT AS
I'VE MENTIONED HAPPY TO PROVIDE.
ALL OF THE DATE DETAILS AND
METRICS- BUT WE ARE JUST
BEGINNING THIS PROCESS AND THIS
IS THIS IS NEW FOR- THEY THIS
AGENCY DESPITE THE FACT THAT-
OUR NAMES CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
. THANK YOU FOR THAT- THE FORM
MOVE ON THE ISSUE I'LL JUST PUT
SOMETHING UP ON YOUR RADAR-
PERHAPS A COLLABORATION WITH
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS FOR EXAMPLE
ALLEY UST LOCALLY. THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR STUDENTS TO BE
ABLE TO VOLUNTEER CERTAIN HOURS
SO VOLUNTEERING ALSO MEANS THAT
YOU HAVE THE MEANS AND RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITHOUT
GETTING PAID. THAT'S VERY HARD
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY POST COBIT AMID
RECOVERY TO BE ABLE TO- YOU KNOW
BE ABLE TO JUST VOLUNTEER TIME
IT'S A IT'S A WONDERFUL
ENDEAVOR. BUT MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
IN MY COMMUNITY ARE ALSO TRYING
TO. HELP THEIR FAMILIES AND PAY
THE RENT AND PROVIDE AND THAT'S
A- A BURDEN THAT IS NOT OFTEN
SHARED ACROSS THE STATE. AND SO
I SAY THAT TO YOU IN AN EFFORT
TO SAY THERE COULD BE A
COLLABORATION. OF ALREADY AN
EXISTING GRADUATING REQUIREMENTS
THAT CAN ALSO EXPAND ON CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
YEAH IT'S A IT'S A TERRIFIC IDEA
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
LOVE TO EXPLORE AND THE SPIRIT
OF YOUR QUESTION IS ALSO WHY
WE'VE BEEN SO FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE THAT. WE'VE INCREASED THE
SCHOLARSHIP FOR SERVICE OF UP TO
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA- DID TO PUT TOWARDS
IF YOU GO TO SCHOOL IT'S WHY WE
WE'VE PUT SO MUCH. FOCUS ON
GRADING SERVICE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT DO CREATE JOBS THAT DO.
PROVIDE A STIPEND AND A
SCHOLARSHIP SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
IT ACCESSIBLE AND INCLUSIVE AND
THE IDEA OF EXPANDING WORKING
WITH SCHOOL BOARDS TO EXPAND AND
MAKE THIS THE CULTURE OF WHAT'S
POSSIBLE FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA. IS EXACTLY THE
SPIRIT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT CALIFORNIA GOING
TO YEARS SO- WE WILL TAKE YOU UP
ON THAT SUGGESTION. THANK YOU
FOR THAT- MUCH APPRECIATED WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME. AND WE ARE. QUICKLY
WRAPPING UP. ADDITIONAL BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR OPR MR ASSEFA
YOU'RE BACK ON. GREAT THANK YOU
BUT I'M CARE TO ALL START WITH
THE ON AND I'LL TRY TO BE REALLY
QUICK I'LL START WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION. THE- CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION LEARNING LAB OR CELL
WAS ESTABLISHED BY THE- BUDGET
OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
IMPROVE LEARNING OUTCOMES AND
CLOSE. EQUITY GAPS AND OUR
PUBLIC COLLEGES. ESPECIALLY THE
KINDS OF GAPS WE SEE FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
INTERESTED IN PURSUING SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND
MATHEMATICS OR KNOWN AS SPAM.
BILLS UP THE BUDGET INCLUDES
THREE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
GENERAL FUND TOO MANY ENOUGH
WHICH IS- TO RESTORE CUTS MADE
THAT THREE DURING THE HEIGHT OF
THE PANDEMIC AND WOOD CREEK
SOUTH THAT GROUNDBREAKING CUP
ABILITIES TO PRE PRE PANDEMIC
LEVELS. ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
FIND THE EXPANSION OF ON OPEN
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCE PROJECT IN
STATEN ACROSS ALL THREE SEGMENTS
OF OUR EDUCATION. UC CSU AND
COOK COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIS
INVESTMENT WILL REDUCE-
EDUCATIONAL COSTS FOR STUDENTS-
BUT YOU MENTIONED MADAM CHAIR
THE CHALLENGES ESPECIALLY FOR
LOW INCOME- AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
FAMILIES. AT THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR A
GRANT TO THE CARNEGIE SCIENCE
CLIMATE RESEARCH BOB. VISIBILITY
IN PASADENA. AND THEN- A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO ESTABLISH THE GOLDEN
STATE AWARDS GRANT PROGRAM FOR
THE PURPOSE OF INCENTIVIZING AND
ELEVATING HIGH IMPACT
INNOVATIONS CREATED IN
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD HAVE TO GO
TO STOP THE REST CORRECT ROSA A
PARDON THE INTERRUPTION I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF PROPOSALS ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE BUT THE L.
A. O. DOES HAVE CONCERNS WITH
JUST A FEW. SO WHY DON'T WE DO
SOMETHING JUST A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT AND HEAR FROM. AT THE
CONCERNS AND THEN MAYBE TRY TO
ADDRESS THEM BECAUSE THE REST OF
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL SEEM TO BE-
IN ALIGNMENT SO LET'S- LET'S
HEAR FROM THE L. A- IF YOU DON'T
MIND. FOR THANK. I THINK YOU
THIS IS BRIAN WEATHERFORD WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE AN ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND AS YOU NOTED- ARE A
COMMENT ON THE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS ON THE AGENDA AND WE
DO NOT RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT MOST
OF. BUDGET PROPOSAL. OF THE ONE
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO- HIGHLIGHT
IS OUR- OF THE PROPOSED- GOLDEN
STATE HIGHER EDUCATION AWARDS
PROPOSAL. I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
STATE IS DONE THE SORT OF THING
IN THE PAST AND WE WOULD CAUTION
AGAINST DOING SO AGAIN. AND WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL- BECAUSE IT IN
PARTICULAR HAS A FUNDAMENTALLY
POOR DESIGN. AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
DISCUSS- THAT IN FURTHER DETAIL
PEOPLE. THANK YOU FOR THAT-
LET'S GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THAT WILL GO INTO
THE SPECIFIC- PROPOSAL SMITH A
DIRECTOR OF SUCH. YOU GO UP
THERE. CLARK THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE THEY CAN TURN OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE JACKSON WALT ANSWER
THIS QUESTION. RESPOND OKAY. HI
YES HI THIS IS JEFF WELTMAN
FINANCE- AS NOTED THAT CALPERS
BUDGET INCLUDES THIRTY MILLION
ONE TIME- GENERAL FUND OR- WORKS
. TO YEAH OUR AWARDS FOR-
INNOVATOR- PROJECTS- IT'S SAD
YOU KNOW WHILE THE STATE HAS
DONE. SIMILAR PROJECTS TO THESE
IN THE PAST I THINK WE'VE WE'VE
FOUND- THE SPONSORSHIP OF
INNOVATION TO BE HIGHLY
BENEFICIAL ACTIVITY FOR THE
STATE'S UNDERTAKING AND ONE THAT
THE ANSWER THE COMMITTEE'S
QUESTIONS. TRECORA SUFFERED DO
YOU WANT TO- SPEAK IN PARTICULAR
TO THESE PROPOSALS. AGAINTHAT
BY DON'T HAVE MUCH TO PROVIDE
THIS PLAN BUT OF ALL BE HAPPY
TO. RESPOND TO THE SPECIIC
QUESTIONS- IN WRITING FOR THIS.
OKAY WHAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
KNOW THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
THINGS ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE-
WITH BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT THE TWO
THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO THE ALLEY-
WITH CONCERNS. WE'LL GET SOME OF
THOSE QUESTIONS TO YOU- THEY ARE
IN THE- AGENDA. AND SO WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO. TO AGAIN MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE A COPY OF THAT AND
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS AS NEEDED. WE
WILL THANK YOU SO MUCH I
DIRECTOR AND DO WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME-
THIS LAST ISSUE IS ON. XS ZERO
FIVE WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MISTER
CHRIS HEALTH. GOOD AFTERNOON
CRYSTAL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I UNDERSTAND IT'S BEEN
A LONG HEARINGS LITTLE TRYING ON
A BRIEF AND LYFT POINTS- THE
ROOT OF THIS ISSUE LIES IN THE
EDUCATIONAL REVENUE AUGMENTATION
FUND STATUTES IN THE- ALL
LICENSE FEES WHAT'S THAT. UNDER
CURRENT LAW. A SMALL REVENUE
OFTEN BOND WITH REPORTERS. AND
CITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS REGARDLESS OF NOT
MONEY INTO THE ROUTE WHICH THEN
GOES TO THE CAPE- TO THAT THE
SCHOOLS WITH AN ACCOUNTING. AND-
UNDER ONE OF THE LAWS OF THE
EDUCATIONAL REVENUE AUGMENTATION
ONE OF THE ROUTE IRAP MONIES
CANNOT GO TO WATER REFERRED TO
AS BASIC EIGHT SCHOOLS WHAT OUR
SCHOOLS ARE FULLY FUNDED TO
THEIR- LOCAL. FORMULA THAT'S
BUILDING. THE THIRTY UNTIL
SOMEONE ELSE YEP YEP MALEGAON
I'M NOT SURE WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH YOUR AUDIO YOU'RE YOU'RE
BREAKING UP QUITE A BIT. L. I'M
SORRY I'M TELL MAYBE IF WE TRY
TRY ENOUGH IT MAY BE FISCALLY
TURNING OFF THE VIDEO YOUR AUDIO
MY COMMAND A LITTLE BIT CLEARER
LET'S TRY THAT. CORRECT OUT OF.
IS IT COMING FROM WORKING WITH.
IF YOU CAN CONTINUE LEVEL YOU
MIGHT BE ABLE TO HEAR YOU MORE.
ALL RIGHT. SO I'LL JUST DUMB
TAKE IT FROM THE TOP EACH COUNTY
HAS AN EDUCATIONAL REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FUND INTO WHICH ON
THE CITY'S THE COUNTING ON THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS PART OF A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF PROPERTY TAX
THAT GOES TO BENEFIT THE
SCHOOLS. UNDER THE. IT'S NOT GO
TO ARE REFERRED TO AS BASIC
EIGHT SCHOOLS AND A BASIC EIGHT
SCHOOL THE SCHOOL THIS WEEK BUT
IT TO ITS REVENUE LIMITS WITH
PROPERTY TAX. SO WHAT HAPPENS IN
A SITUATION WHERE. IF YOU HAVE
ENOUGH BASIC EIGHT SCHOOLS IN
THE COUNTY. THAT IRAQ NOT BE
FULLY ABSORBED. IT RAPID REFER
TO IS ACCESS THE ROUTE AND IT IS
VERY TURN TO THE CITIES COUNTIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS. SO THAT'S
WHAT ACCESS. THIS LICENSE FEES
WHAT STATUTES- IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE TO FOURTEEN OCCURRED
MINISTRATION REDUCE THE VEHICLE
LICENSE FEE FROM 2% 0065% THAT
RESULTED IN A REVENUE LOSS FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES. IN THE
STATE MAY HOLD THAT REVENUE LOSS
BY ALLOWING. CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT THAT AIM TO
THE ROCKS. AND IF THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH MONEY IN THE EASY ROUTE
TO REIMBURSE. THE LOST THE.
THANKS IS A PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
SHIFTED FROM THE NON BASIC EIGHT
SCHOOLS THOSE ARE SCHOOLS WHICH
RECEIVE STATE FUNDING BECAUSE
ARE NOT FULLY FUNDED TO THEIR-
REVENUE LIMITS THE PROPERTY TAX
. UNDER THE CURRENT DEAL LEFT
STATUTES. ACCESS THE ROUTE WHICH
IS RETURN TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
DOES NOT COUNT BOARD HANG THE
VEHICLE LICENSE FEE BACK BILL
FOR THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
INSTEAD. WHAT HAPPENED. THE CARD
FOR JUST PROJECT REVENUE THE
BASIC AID FROM THE NON BASIC
EIGHT SCHOOLS. THANK IS A TO THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO PAY THE
VEHICLE LICENSE FEES WHAT. AND
WHAT ARE TRAILER BILL PROPOSES
TO DO IS TWO THINGS. FIRST OUR
TRAILER BILL SAYS THAT. BEYOND
ACCESS THE ROUTE WHICH IS
RETURNED TO THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES BECAUSE IT CANNOT BE
ABSORBED BY THE SCHOOLS. SHALL
HENCEFORTH BE COUNTED TOWARDS
PAYING THE VEHICLE LICENSE
FEEDBACK BILL FOR THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES. AND WHAT ARE TRAILER.
BILL ALSO DOES THAT SAYS IS
INSUFFICIENT THE BILL A LOSS THE
ADDRESS DOWN WE'RE CREATING
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION FOR THE
GENERAL FUND THE FACT THAT THE
DIFFERENCE. UNDER CURRENT LAW
THAT BACK BILL IS NOT REQUIRED
HOWEVER THE STATE HAS BEEN
PROVIDING THAT BACKED BILL FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW THE BEST
PRACTICE. AND IT IS ESTIMATED TO
COST APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
FISCAL YEAR WHILE. SO WITHOUT
HAVING AFTER THE MAIL. THANK YOU
LET'S HEAR FROM THE L. A- PLEASE
. GOOD EVENING TO LOOK THIS
MODEL THAT'S WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
BEGINNING IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR- FISCAL YEAR
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
CHECK A PROCESS TO CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATE STATE GENERAL FUND
TO BACK THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHEN THERE'S INSUFFICIENT IRAQ
TO ADDRESS THE PLS POP.
ADDITIONALLY THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO OFFSET THE STATE
GENERAL FUND BACK FILLED WITH
EXCESS EVEN HALF BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
IMPORTANTLY IT IS UNIQUE THAT
COUNTY TAP BOTH INSUFFICIENT YOU
HAVE TO ADDRESS THE BLS WHAT.
AND ACCESS YOU WRAP AFTER THE
STATE SHARE. THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE IS MEANT FOR SCHOOLS.
AXISDIRECT THE A SPECIAL CALL
THEM. THAT CURRENTLY BENEFITS
FIVE COUNTIES AND EXIST BECAUSE
THEIR PROPERTY TAX REVENUE IS
VERY HIGH RELATIVE TO THE
STATUTORY FUNDING REQUIREMENTS.
FOR SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. FOR COUNTIES WITHOUT
EXCESS IRAQ THE BATTLE PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
CONSIST ENTIRELY OF STATE
GENERAL FUND. IN CONCERT THE
APPROACH PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION MAKES SENSE OF
THE PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REIMBURSEMENTS. MORE QUICKLY
THAN THE CURRENT PROCESS AND
STREAMLINES THE PROCESS FOR
CLEANING A BACK FILL. UNDER
CURRENT PRACTICE THE STATE
GENERAL FUND IS PROVIDED TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO AN ANNUAL
BUDGET. ACT OF APPROPRIATION ON
A ONE TIME BASIS TO COVER
INSUFFICIENT YOU WRAPPED. UP THE
BACK WELL AS PROVIDED IN ARREARS
CHART ALSO HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY
LOW IN PAST YEARS BUT GROWING
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE. COMBINED
WITH MORE BASIC EIGHT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE INCREASED THE
INSUFFICIENCIES. AND PROJECTIONS
ASSUME CONTINUED GROWTH IN THE
SHORTFALLS CONTINUE DELAYS IN
THE BACK BILL. MAY BECOME MORE
CHALLENGING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MANAGE AS THE
PACKED FULL AMOUNTS GROW SINCE
THE ELECT IS AN IMPORTANT.
SOURCE OF GENERAL PURPOSE LOCAL
REVENUE. I THE PROPOSED TBL A
STAY COMPTROLLER OFFICE
RESPONSIBLE FOR REVIEWING AND
APPROVING AS WELL AS AUDITING
CLAIMS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. OF
INSUFFICIENT YOU WRAP UNDER THE
CURRENT PROCESS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR IF
YOU NEED THESE CLAIMS SCO DOES
NOT CURRENTLY HAVE CAPACITY OR-
THIS IS A POLICY EXPERTISE TO
REVIEW THAT AND APPROVE THESE
ECONOMY ROCK CLAIMS.
ADDITIONALLY IT IS UNCLEAR
WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE FOR SCO
TO DEVELOP THIS EXPERTISE AS IT
MAY NOT BE APPROPRIATE. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TYPICALLY SCO MAKES
PAYMENTS TO COUNTIES BASED ON
DIRECTION PROVIDED TO THEM BY
OTHER STATE ENTITIES THAT
ADMINISTER RELEVANT PROGRAMS. SO
WE ARE CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT
SORT OF WHAT STATE ENTITY WOULD
BE BEST POSITIONED TO REVIEW AND
APPROVE THESE CLAIMS. SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO MEET BEFORE
THE STEPS YOU KNOW PROCESS FOR
PROVIDING A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION FOR.
INSUFFICIENTLY RAF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- ONE ONE
SECOND PLEASE. JUST UP REALLY
QUICKLY WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO
THIS ACCESS IRAQ REVENUE IF THE
BLF HAD NEVER BEEN REDUCED. I'M
SORRY IF THE PEOPLE WERE
REDUCED. NEVERBEEN REDUCED IF
OF THE BILL UPWARDS STILL AT 2%
OF THE VEHICLE'S VALUE THAN THIS
ACCESS THE RAP WOULD JUST
CONTINUE TO BE RETURNED TO THE
ON THE DONOR CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES IN THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. AND WE WOULDN'T HAVE
A VEHICLE LICENSE FEEDBACK BILL
LOCATION SO THAT THAT REVENUE
JUST DUMB FLOW. AFTER COOPER'S
AT SOME SPILLOVER ACCESS THE RAP. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME WE ARE DONE WITH THE
FINAL ISSUE MUCH APPRECIATED WE
WILL CONTINUE TO HOLD THAT- ITEM
OPENED WE ARE NOT GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THE NUMBER
877-692-8957 PUBLIC ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. AND WE HAVE ONE PERSON-
HERE IN OUR ROOM AT FOUR FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T
KNOW WHICH MICROPHONE. TWENTY
SECOND LET'S FIGURE THAT OUT CAN
WE MAKE SURE THAT THIS REMARKS
ON. HELLO. I'M NOT A CHARITY HI
KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF THE NAPA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ONE
OF THE TWO PARTIES ONE SECOND.
THANK HI I'M STILL RESTING. WE
ALL ARE PLEASE RESTART THANK YOU
MONSTER ARE LAYING ON THE OF THE
NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
ONE OF THE TWO COUNTIES THAT'S
BEEN WORKING ON THAT PROPOSED
LANGUAGE THAT YOU JUST HEARD
EVEN IF THE SOUND IS CLEAR IT
PROBABLY SOUNDS ABOUT THE SAME
YOU START LEARNING ABOUT THE-
LEFT THE NEXT A FEW ROCKS. AT
FOR NAPA COUNTY WHEN THERE'S A
SHORTAGE WHEN IT DOES OCCUR AND
ARE NOT INTO THE SHORTAGE YET
BUT WHEN IT WOULD OCCUR IF THE
MEDIA FORTY MILLION DOLLAR HIT
TO THEIR BUDGET IN THE CITY'S
BUDGET AND SO THEY HAVE TO MAKE
IMMEDIATE CUTS TO THEIR
PROGRAMMING AND EMPLOYEES
WITHOUT SOME SORT OF IN YOUR
SOLUTION SO WHAT WE DID WAS
DRAFTED. MOST OF THE. BILL AND
THEN THE LAST- THE AN UPDATE.
WITH NEW WHEN WE THOUGHT WHEN
THE TRAILER BILL IS RELEASED. ON
ON PAGE FIVE F. ONE. BASICALLY
JUST MAKE THEM TAKE OTHER LOCAL
MONEY TO COVER THE SHORTAGE. AND
TO FIND OUT BY FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND YOU'D STILL HAVE TO MAKE
THOSE CUTS. SO WE'RE HOPING TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE STATE
TO COVER. WHAT THE COUNTY WOULD
NEED TO JUST MAINTAIN I'M NOT
TRYING TO GET ONE OVER ON THE
STATE OR THE SCHOOLS. CURRENTLY
SIXTY SIX CENTS OF EVERY DOLLAR
THAT THE COUNTY COLLECTS. GOES
TO THE SCHOOLS THEY'RE NOT
TRYING TO TAKE ANY OF IT AWAY.
THEY. THERE FROM WHEN YOU'RE AT
YOUR COMMITTEE. AND THEN ON TOP
OF HUMBOLDT COUNTY JUST. JUST
BEGGING FOR HELP ON THE- EXCISE
TAX IN THE CULTIVATION TAX FOR
HUMBLE AFTER HUMBOLDT COUNTY
GROWERS. ARE PEOPLE ACTUALLY
TAKEN OUR LIVES THERE AFTER
LOSING EVERYTHING DUE TO THE
CONDITIONS THERE SO. IT'S A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM WITH THEIR
NUMBER LOOKING FOR TO SOME
RELIEF BURSTING THINKING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES PLEASE OPERATOR. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
THEN ZERO. FIRST WE WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY NINE- GOOD AFTERNOON
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK FROM CRUISE
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE IN
THE TAIL COUNTY ARE CALLING
TODAY AND TO CONVEY THE COUNTY
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED
INSUFFICIENTLY ROCK TRAILER BILL
THAT WAS JUST THE FACT. THAT THE
BENEFITS OF A NEW PROVISION ACT
ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
YOU'RE JUST PROVIDED FOR NAPA
COUNTY BUT I'LL BE HAPPY TO
MATTEO THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
WOULD CHANGE THE CURRENT BLS
ACTING IN A WAY THAT WOULD NEED
TO GET MY ARMS. COUNTY AND CITY
. CHOIRMASTER YOU OUR OWN LOCAL
TAX. TO THE FEE FEEL ABA. THE
PROPOSAL ULTIMATELY WILL. IN THE
CARE COUNTY AND CITY BEHIND OF
MILLION OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
BUT ALSO THE COUNTY TURN BASED
IT. IS TIME RD BUDGET BRIDGEPORT
. PUBLIC SERVICE IN OUR TOWN.
AND WITHOUT REMOVE FY DECREE
TRAILER BILL GOES BACK ON PBS.
EIGHT AND INTO LAW. REGARDING
ITS TO BE A BUT BEING ABLE TO
TAKE HUNDRED OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AWAY FROM THE COW.
BUDGET ARM. THAT CRITIC PUBLIC
AND HOW SERVICES ACCOUNT PROVIDE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
OPERATOR AND AGAIN TO THE-
GENTLE REMINDER YOU HAVE ALL
COLORS HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE SEVENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS THING
HUTCHINGS WITH THE BRITISH
PUBLIC POLICY GROUP- CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF REDWOOD
CITY FOSTER CITY HILLSBOROUGH
AND BELMONT- WITH RESPECT TO
DEVELOP PARTNERSHIPS HEARD. ONE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH. NAPA
COUNTY AND SAN MATTEO COUNTY- WE
COULD BE SEEING- I GENERAL FUND
CUTS RANGING FROM ANYWHERE FROM
FIVE TO FIFTEEN PERCENT- IF THIS
IF THIS PROPOSAL GOES AFTER
POSED. RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING
ABOUT TO ASK ONE- OPPOSE MUCH
MEANT THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ADRIAN SHELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE THE CHILD'S
FAMILY SERVICES REPRESENT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE WERE SERVING
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES AND
PUBLIC HUMAN SERVICES SYSTEMS
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR TWO ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY FIRST IS ITEM FIFTEEN AND
SPECIFICALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- ABOUT THE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP HOWEVER
IT'S CHAIR CAREER NOTED WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN OUR STATE
ABOUT WHO HAS ACCESS TO IT IS
NOT. AS SIGNIFICANT AND
EQUITIES- SO WE BELIEVE THAT TO
TRULY ADDRESS EQUITY IN OUR
STATE SYSTEMICALLY WIN
STRATEGIES ACROSS ALL OF OUR
DEPARTMENT THIS IS WHY WE ARE
SUPPORTING THE CREATION OF THAT
OFFICE OF REGIONAL EQUITY BACK
TO WORK IN CONCERT WITH THIS NEW
POSITION AND SECOND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF PEYTON SIXTEEN
OPPORTUNITY PARTNERSHIP UNDER
OPR WE BELIEVE THAT FORMALIZING
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN STATE
GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS NECESSARY AS
THE STATE CONTINUES TO TACKLE
CHALLENGES LIKE YOU BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. AND RECOVERY FROM THE
KOPET. NINETEEN PANDEMIC THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BLIND. EIGHTY CAN
YOU MONITORING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- TONE ACCORDING HERE
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES ONE
OF THE STATE'S LEADING HEALTH
EQUITY ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION I'M
CALLING IN ON ISSUE FIFTEEN-
PARTICULARLY PARTICULARLY
RELATING TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON THE
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOUR BY
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ALLOCATE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE
THOUGHTLESSNESS OF THE STATEWIDE
OFFICE RACIAL EQUITY WERE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON THE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER THE STEP TOWARD
ADDRESSING ADDRESSING EQUITY.
WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENT- HIRING
AND CONTRACTING PRACTICES- IT'S
NOT ENSURE MENTIONS THE
ELOQUENTLY ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
ACCESS ARE NOT ONE AND THE SAME
OUR COMMUNITY ACCESS NOT JUST
TECHNOLOGY AND ACTIVE COMES WITH
OVERSIGHT THAT CENTERS THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA- THIS OFFICE WILL
CENTRALIZE COORDINATE PLAN IN
INSTITUTIONALIZED CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIES FOR DISMANTLING
RACISM ACROSS THE AGENCIES IN
INCREASING ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES DEPRIVED. SO
AGAIN WE REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE
ALLOCATE THE FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CREATION. OF THE
OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY THANK
YOU. ONLINE AT. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS UNDER ME
DOES CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF HAPPENED BAY SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE TOWN OF COAL
MINE WITH RESPECT ISSUE
NINETEEN- JUST ALIGNING WITH THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
BEFORE ME THE CITIES ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE EXCEPT EUROPE
TRAILER BILL PROPOSAL UNLESS
AMENDED TO REMOVE PROVISION. AB
ONE THANK YOU. LINE. NINETY SIX.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS NOT DONE I
AM WITH THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER CALLING WITH
REGARD ISSUE FIFTEEN WE ARE
PLEASED WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
KIND OF THE LANGUAGE ON THE
CHIEF THAT THE OFFICER AT THE
STEP TOWARD THE DRESSING ATHLETE
WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENT HIRING
AND CONTRACTING PRACTICES
HOWEVER GOTTEN THAT WOULD
POSITIVELY AFFECT THE RAKING
ACROSS OUR LAWS AND GOVERNMENT
DEMAND THAT WE DEVELOP A STRONG
HAPPY TO BE AT THE FRAMEWORK AND
STRATEGY. ANCHORED BY AN OFFICE
THAT TURNED DARKLY COMMITMENT.
ABSOLUTELY STRATEGIES.
LEGISLATURE OUR PUTTING DOLLAR
FOR THE OF THE- OF RACIAL BUT HE
- THANK YOU. ALIGNMENT. THREE
THERE ARE ROUGHLY HALF OF THE
TOWN OF TRUCKEE IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE EIGHT THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CULTURAL DISTRICT
AND THE TURKEY CULTURAL DISTRICT
OF THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAS
WORKED SUCCESSFULLY WITH THE
LOCAL ARTS COMMUNITY IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE TOWN TO
COMPLETE THE JOB FIRST PUBLIC
ART MASTER PLAN AS WELL AS
CREATED A SERIES OF LOCAL
ARTIFACTS HIGHLIGHTING ALL THE
LOCAL ARTISTS. FALL SHOULDER
SEASONS DURING THAT SPAN TOWARDS
THEM THE BETTER OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE NOT. SNOW THE PENDANT
NO REGION THANK YOU. LINE AT.
NINETY TWO. FIFTY WHITE LOOK AT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
FOR THE DISCUSSION TODAY AND FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT WE'RE
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO BE ALLEN THE
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER VOTING
BECAUSE THEY THINK TO GO A STEP
FURTHER AND JUST WISH I COULD BE
ACROSS THE PARTNERS BY
ALLOCATING FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE CREATION OF THE
OPERATIONAL EQUITY EQUITY SHOULD
NOT BE ACHIEVED INSIDE LOOK AT
THE AT THE STATE TO ONE AND THEN
THE GREAT THE CONSERVING THAT
AFTER YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THE
CREATION OF THE OFFICE. AT THE
SHORE EQUITY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BLIND AND- FOUR. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JANE
HURST CALLING IN TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA.
ISSUE NINETEEN RELATING TO
INSUFFICIENT IRAQ- WE READ ALL
MY IN A COMMENT WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM NAPA AND SAN
MATTEO R. AS WELL AS YOUR WE NOW
THAT THIS SCENARIO DOESN'T
ALWAYS HAPPEN AND HI WELCOME
PLEASE ALSO HAPPENS IN COUNTIES
WITH EXCEPTIONALLY DECLINING
ENROLLMENTS ARE LIKE ALPINE AND
ANIMAL AND. SO WE'RE LOOKING.
AIR POLLUTION AT THIS ISSUE AND
A PRE. THE OPPORTUNITY CUT
COMPETE. TO THANK. LINE. FIFTY
SIX. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
CARILLO AND STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE BURKE BUT BUILT TO PAY
PICS GROUP ON BEHALF OF PERFECT
UNION AND CURE RELIEF TO
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED CANNABIS
COMPANIES HAVE LIKE TO- MAKE
SOME COMMENTS REGARDING AGENDA
ITEM TO. PRIMARILY SHOWING OUR
GRATITUDE FOR DIRECTOR ELLIOTT
AS THE DIRECTOR OF OUR
DEPARTMENT SEE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL UNDERSTAFFING
PROMOTING TRANSPARENCY AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT THAT
LETTING CURRENT ISSUES IN THE
INDUSTRY. I LIKE TO REITERATE
THAT WE'RE AT A PIVOTAL MOMENT
FOR THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND
IT'S CLEARLY OVER TAX AND WE
SUPPORT THE LIMITATION OF
CORPORATION TAX AND A REDUCTION
IN EXCISE TAX AND ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR EQUITY APPLICANTS.
THANK YOU. LINE AT. NINETY NINE.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ONLY OFFENSE MARIA ON BEHALF
CONNECTION POLICY I'M CALLING ON
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCIES I
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS IN TERMS OF SEEING IN
THE TRALER BILL LANGUAGE AS IT
RELATES TO CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER
. DURING THE HEARING THE ISSUE
OF LIKE WITHOUT THAT ACCESS TO
MOTHER WAS BROUGHT UP ON. AS AN
ISSUE GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS HOWEVER
YOU HAVE TWO DIFFERENT AGENCIES
GOV OFTEN OKAY ARE TRYING TO
TACKLE THE SAME ISSUE WE KNOW
ALL AGENCIES STRUGGLE WITH IN
TERMS OF CULTURALLY COMPETENT
COMMUNICATION WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO CALL CALIFORNIA HOME.
ADVOCATES BELIEVE THAT THE
OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY IN
COORDINATION WITH THE
COLLABORATION OF THE CHIEF
EQUITY OFFICER TO COORDINATE
PLAN INSTITUTIONALIZED CAL
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIES FOR
DISMANTLING RACISM ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS. THANK
YOU. LINE SEVENTY SIX. GOOD
EVENING MA'AM SURE MEMBERS
RECTANGLES IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
EIGHTEEN CARNEGIE SCIENTISTS
SEEKING TO CONSTRUCT THE STATE
OF THE ART ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT RESEARCH FACILITY IN
PASADENA STATEMENT EXCEPT ON
RAISING FUNDS FROM PRIVATE
SOURCES HAVE SECURED THE LAND
FOR THE BUILDING AND THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FUNDS
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FIVE
WOULD BE THE FINAL PIECE TO
ENABLE CONSTRUCTION AT THE
RESEARCH FACILITY. THERE'S NO
OTHER ENTITY THAT COMPARES TO
THE DEPTH SCOPE AND EXPERTISE
THE CARNEGIE SCIENCE HAD SUCH
SPACES AS CLIMATE CHANGE
RESEARCH WILDFIRE PREVENTION
OUTCOMES WATER QUALITY RESEARCH
AMONG SO MUCH MORE VERY EXCITING
THE CARNEGIE EXPANDING IN
PASADENA WITH PLACE CALIFORNIA
AT THE CENTER OF SUCH IMPORTANT
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH. WE GOT YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
ONE. PRETTY MEMBERS JEFF MEAL
WITH THE CAL STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES- ECHOING THE
COMMENTS ON THE EXCESS CARE ACT
ITEM FROM THAT YEAH COUNTY
COUNTY SAID OF TESTIFIED ALREADY
AND JUST TO JUST TO CLARIFY THE
SITUATION AND MAKE A LITTLE BIT
SIMPLER IN THE NINETY FIFTH ST
SHIFTED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
PROPERTY TAX BUT WE CAN COUNTIES
AND CITIES TO BENEFIT BECAUSE
THERE WAS A BIG STATE BUDGET
PROBLEMS AND IF THERE WAS A
PERMANENT CHANGE AND THEN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS THE STATE AT
THE PROPERTY TAX ON COOPS BUT
THAT WAS A LOCAL REVENUE SOURCE
IN SEVEN THIRTY GIVEN THAT MONEY
FOR CORRECTLY THEY SAID TELL YOU
WHAT YOU CAN JUST KEEP A NOTE OF
THAT. PREVIOUS YEAR TO COVER THE
DIFFERENCE AND WE'LL CALL IT
GOOD INTERNATIONAL IF YOU
COUNTIES. LARGE AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID. IT AT HOME. IS
ALL OF THE INCREASE IN PRICE.
BACK THERE ISN'T A MONEY FROM
THE FIRST HALF COVETOUS PACKAGE
. AND SO YOU CAN OF THAT. YOU
KNOW WOULD EVEN BE AN ISSUE IF
THE STATE HAD TAKEN. A COUPLE OF
ACTIONS TO. SHIFT MONEY AWAY
FROM FROM COUNTY THE CITY
ITSELF. I LINE MY COMMENTS ARE
THERE SUPPORT CITY OF THIS
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTY FIVE. HI GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JULIE BAKER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
OUR TOPIC IS CALLING ON ISSUE
EIGHT THE COURT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INVESTMENT AND
ARTS AND CULTURE INCLUDING
THIRTY NINE DOLLARS FOR CULTURAL
DISTRICT AND WHILE METING
EQUITY TARGET PROPOSED ON THE
TWENTY NINTH NINETEEN ASSESSMENT
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM SHE IN
ADDITION TO CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS COALITION HAVE
DEVELOPED PROPOSAL ON HOW THE
THIRTY MILLION COULD BE EXPANDED
I'M NOT INFORMATION HOW MUCH
YOUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANT TODAY
WE ALSO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER INCREASING BASE LIKE. A
FINE FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
DEEPER INVESTMENT IN OUR ONGOING
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE LOCAL IF
THAT'S ALL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE V. ATPASE FIND
BUDGET HAS NOT INCREASED IN
THREE YEARS IT HAS REMAINED AT
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS OR
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY SIX POUNDS
PER PERSON IN CALIFORNIA WITH
THE START BUTTON LEGISLATOR MADE
LAST YEAR. TO PROVIDE RELIEF
FUNDING FOR THE ARTS WE WANT TO
ENSURE THESE INVESTMENT CLASS BE
ASK YOU TO CHAMPION THE DOLLAR
FOR THE ARTS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE BUDGET-
BY PROVIDING AN INCREASE OVER
THREE YEARS OR SO STATE FUNDING
TO THE CFPB ORGANIZATIONS TIME
FREE KILL THEIR PROGRAMS AND
WORKFORCE IS IMPORTANT TO ME CAN
BE INCOME COMPANY IT WILL TAKE
MORE THAN FIVE YEARS FOR THE
ARTS AND ENTERTAINMENT AND USED
TO GET BACK TO TWENTY NINETEEN
LEVEL CONTRIBUTION TO GDP. THANK
YOU AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE. ARTS THRIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHY EIGHTY. THANK
YOU- THANK YOU TO YOUR CAR YOU-
MY NAME IS DAVE GRIFFITH I'M
HERE BEFORE YOU AS THE CURRENT
CHAIR OF THE ALPINE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS I DON'T HAVE TO
THINK YOU STADIO AND ONE REQUEST
REGARDING ITEM NINETEEN ACCESS
THE RAP. BUT FIRSTLY HI COUNTY
AGREES WITH A COMMENT LETTER YOU
RECEIVED ON BEHALF OF SHE SAID
UCC RC RC. L. CITIES AND THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA. SECONDLY
STAFF COMMENT THAT THE ACCESS
THE RAP ON THE DOCKING. ONLY A
CURSE. IN SOME OF THE WEALTHIEST
AREAS OF THE STATE IS SIMPLY
FALSE. BY COUNTY IS BEING
ENTITLED TO ACCESS THE RAFT FOR
MANY YEARS. DESPITE BEING A LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY. 55% OF OUR
POPULATION BEING NATIVE AMERICAN
ABOUT 50% OF OUR PRIMARY SCHOOL
STUDENTS SHOULD BEING NATIVE
AMERICAN WE ARE NOT WEALTHY.
WELL ACTUALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WRONGLY DENIED HER
APPLICATION FOR EXCESSIVE HEAT
MAPS BUT IT JUST CLEARS
201-617-2017 EIGHTEEN. AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. YOU
KNOW THE REQUIREMENTS TWO
LETTERS REQUESTING THE FUNDS
RATHER THAN THE ONE LETTER
REQUESTED PREVIOUSLY AND
PERSONNEL TURNOVER IN OUR
FINANCE DEPARTMENT. MR NEED PER
SECOND LETTER- QUESTION JOHNNY
HUNDRED NINETEEN. SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN DOLLARS WHICH IS A
LOT OF MONEY FOR SMALL COUNTY
SUCH AS OPENING. UP AN ACCOUNT
IS REQUESTING THAT ANY CHANGE
THE LEGISLATION SPECIFICALLY
REFUND IS THE THREE HUNDRED
NINETY TWO THOUSAND. SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN DOLLARS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. LINE. EIGHTY FOUR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HARASSMENT
AND I AM THE CULTURE OF THE
TRUCKEE ARTS ALLIANCE I'M
REPRESENTING TURKEY'S CULTURAL
DISTRICT WHICH IS A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS PROGRAM BEING
CONSIDERED FOR FUNDING IN- ITEM
EIGHT SH ARE HAVING DIRECTLY
EXPERIENCE THE POSITIVE AND
WIDESPREAD IMPACT OF THE
CULTURAL DISTRICTS PROGRAM UPON
MY OWN COMMUNITY I'M GRATEFUL
FOR GAP OF FOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
REQUEST TO PROVIDE FUNDING THAT
WOULD NOT ONLY SUPPORT MY HOME
DISTRICT AND ITS RUBRIC DIVERSE
AND RICHLY CREATIVE COMMUNITY
ALLOWING US TO EXPONENTIALLY
EXPAND SERVICES AND PROGRAMS TO
REACH AND SUPPORTER OUR WHOLE.
SWATHS OF. EIGHTY BUT IT WOULD.
ALSO EXPANDED THIS BENEFICIAL
PROGRAM TO WIDER DEEPER SWATH OF
THE ENTIRE DIVERSE AND BEAUTIFUL
STATE THAT I LOVE SO MUCH. PART
OF THE SPECIAL AND IF ANYTHING
CAN SERVE AS A POSITIVE POINT OF
BEAUTIFICATION DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES IT'S THE RICH
CULTURAL TAPESTRY. MADE FROM OUR
DIVERSE AND BEAUTIFUL CREATIVE
EXPRESSION BUT EFFORT THE THINGS
THAT MATTER MOST WHEN ALL ELSE.
ALL THE WAY ORDERS MOVING
UNDERNEATH OUR FEET. OUR BRIDGES
COLORS OUR COMMUNITY. PROVIDE
THE POINT OF CONTACTING
UNIFICATION AND CANNOT GET INTO
THE FUTURE. OUR ARCH I WOULD
ARGUE WITH THE BEST OF US. AS
HUMANS WE NEED TO SUPPORT WHAT
IT IS THAT MAKES US BETTER AND
RICHER IN VERY REAL WAYS. I
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING THE
FUNDING OF THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS PROGRAM. ONE
ONE HUNDRED. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS UNDERWATER
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
CALL IN SUPPORT OF THE CREATION
OF THE OFFICE OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS WITHIN THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING RESEARCH THANK YOU.
ONE ONE HUNDRED ONE. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JULIA KAPLAN I'M NOT
A PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE AND I'M CALLING
ON I DIDN'T FIFTEEN REGARDING
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY MY
TEAM AT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE RUNS THE CAPITAL
COLLABORATIVE ON RACE AND EQUITY
WHICH HAS WORKED OF THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WITH OVER FORTY.
DIFFERENT STATE DEPARTMENTS
AGENCIES AN OFFICER
UNDERSTANDING HELPING THEM TO
UNDERSTAND HOW INSTITUTIONAL
RACISM PLAYS OUT IN THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND DEVELOPING
PLANS TO DRAFT THEM AND WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE
COURT APPOINT THE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER POSITION WE THINK THAT
THE CRITICAL AND I'M ALSO HERE
TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
CREATION OF AN OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY WHICH WOULD BE ADDED TO
THAT WOULD SUPPORT. RACIAL
EQUITY WORK IN AREAS THAT THE
BUDGETING PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
GRANT ALLOCATIONS UNITY
PARTNERSHIP THEY CALL GUARANTEED
RENT AND SO MUCH MORE SO WE URGE
YOUR ALLOCATION OF FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY IN ADDITION TO THE PORT
OF PETITIONS THAT THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS. AGENCIES THANK YOU.
WHY NINE FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON%
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS PETER COMISKEY AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE BALBOA PARK
CULTURAL DISTRICT A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS COALITION SUPPORTING
CONTEMPLATE FUNDING FOR THE
CULTURAL DISTRICTS THE CULTURAL
DISTRICT IN BALBOA PARK IS A
UNIQUE AREA DENSELY PACKED WITH
NON PROFIT ART SCIENCE HISTORY
AND CULTURAL WITHIN SECTIONS
OFFICE TO START BUILDINGS AND
GOT. YOU'VE HEARD THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL DISTRICTS
PROGRAM OFFERS ENORMOUS
POTENTIAL THAT POTENTIAL COMES
FROM CELEBRATING THE DISTRICTS
WITH ORGANIZATIONAL SUPPORT
PLANNING SUPPORT AND FUNDING
ALLOCATED TO SPECIFIC PUT PLANS
DEVELOPED BY THE CULTURAL
DISTRICTS THEMSELVES. AND
GROWING THE PROGRAM'S TRULY
REPRESENT THE RICH CULTURAL
TAPESTRY OF CALIFORNIA. SPEAKING
FOR BEHALF OF THE FORTY MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS COALITION I KNOW THEY
ARE ALL KEEN TO REFLECT AND
CELEBRATE THE UNIQUE NATURE. AND
SHARE BOTH WITH EACH OTHER AND
TO OFFER THEMSELVES AS MENTORS
FOR CULTURAL GROUPS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHO WHAT YOU WISH TO
BECOME CULTURAL DISTRICTS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS. AT THE
REMINDER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
LEAVE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY YOU
CAN DO SO BY PRESSING ONE AT
THAT ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SEVENTY FOUR. YEAH THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS DOLLY KING I'M THAT
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS MANAGER FOR
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT CALIFORNIA-
I'M CALLING IN TO VOICE OUR
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR UP LISTING-
BECAUSE FOR EQUITY AND WANTING
TO CONTINUE PURSUING TRYING TO
ACHIEVE EQUITY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- HOWEVER WE
SUGGEST THAT- WE FULLY SUPPORT
THE- OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY SO
THEREFORE REQUESTING THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CREATION. OF THE OFFICE OF
RACIAL EQUITY- AT IT AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S- VIEW
AT THE CREEK BED SHEETS- THE
OFFICER'S POSITION AS WELL AS
THE OTHER- OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITIES THAT HE'S CREEK DRUG
DEPARTMENT HOWEVER WE FEEL THAT
IT'S NECESSARY FOR THERE TO BE
AN OVERARCHING. VISION AND A
MISSION- A DEFINITION OF WHAT
EQUITIES IS AND WHAT IT MEANS
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGH THIS OFFICE WE CAN
CREATE MARKERS- CHECK IT THAT WE
KNOW WHAT AND THAT AND
TRANSPARENT ACCESSIBLE TO
EVERYONE SO WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
ALL WORKING TOWARDS. THE GOAL-
AND- THE CHAIRMAN REALLY GREAT
AND IS WHAT DOCTOR THE PANDEMIC
WERE AT WAS- NECESSARY BUT- MARK
THIS SO HOPEFULLY THE STOCK WE
ACCEPT. THE HAVE THE LIKE NOT
MAKE THESE MARKERS SIX TO PRESS
TO PLEASE WRAP HERE. FOLK THANK
YOU WHAT HAPPENED. OPERATOR
ANYMORE CALLS. KALEIDO ONE
HUNDRED THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTENOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SUSAN CARLSON
NOT A MEMBER INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG A COALITION OF EIGHTY
GROUPS THAT CALIFORNIA AND WE
HAVE ENDORSED SB SEVENTEEN I'M
CALLING ON ISSUE FIFTEEN
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY I
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY IN OFFICE
OF RACIAL EQUITY TO COORDINATE
AND LEAD THE STATE STRATEGIES
FOR ADVANCING RACIAL EQUITY
ACROSS STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. THE STATE MUST PLAY
A MORE ACTIVE AND DEDICATED
STATEWIDE ROLE IN DISMANTLING
RACIAL INEQUITIES AS WE KNOW
THIS WILL LEAD TO BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR ALL RESIDENTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO STRUGGLE
TO RECEIVE EQUITABLE HEALTH CARE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES EMPLOYMENT
AND IT WAS DISCUSSED ALREADY
THAT THERE INEVITABLE
POLITICIZED- IN ORDER FOR THE
STATE TO DELIVER MEANINGFUL
EQUITABLE OUTCOMES EQUITY MUST
BE EXPLICIT AND CENTERED IN ANY
APPROACH TO ADDRESS. THIS THIRTY
FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
ADDRESSING THESE DISPARITIES
CANNOT AND WILL NOT HAPPEN BY
ITSELF IT REQUIRES DESIGN
MECHANISM TO IDENTIFY AND
CORRECT AND NOT PLEASE- HERE TO
ALLOCATE FORTY MILLION FOR THE
CREATION OF AN OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY THIS WILL ALLOW FOR
COLLABORATION OF THE CHIEF
EQUITY OFFICER TO COORDINATE.
AND ESTABLISH STRATEGIES FOR
DISMANTLING RACISM ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES. THIS WILL BE A LATE
ARRIVAL THAT ARE COMMON.
DEGENERATE AND- AND- ONCE YOUR
POLICY ABOUT DIVERSITY FAIRNESS
AND RACIAL. AND SERVE AS A
NATIONAL MODEL THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY A BOTTOM LINE ONE OF
THE BIG BOTTLE SIX- GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS TORY MINGLE ON AND
I'M CALLING IN TO SUPPORT- I
DIDN'T TAKE THE FUNDING FOR THE
CULTURAL DISTRICT I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE OCEANSIDE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL DISTRICTS
AND I AM A MEMBER ALSO OF THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL DISTRICT
COLLECTION. AND I HEARD YOU TO
KEEP THE FUNDING ALLOCATED FOR
THE CULTURAL DISTRICT IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET HE ORIGINAL
FOURTEEN DISTRICTS HAVE WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO CELEBRATE AND
PRESERVE THE UNIQUE CULTURAL
HERITAGE THAT EACH DISTRICTS
REPRESENT WHATEVER WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS HAVE BEEN DONE WITH HERE
TO KNOW FUNDING AND OFTEN ARE
ALMOST PRIMARILY WITH VOLUNTEER.
THIS IS AN UNSUSTAINABLE MODEL
FOR SUCH AN IMPORTANT STATES
LIKE CALIFORNIA WITH SUCH A RICH
AND DIVERSE CULTURAL HERITAGE IT
IS OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE THAT OUR
CULTURAL DISTRICT BOTH CURRENT
AND FUTURE EXPANDED. DISTRICTS
ARE SUPPORTED. HE PROVIDE- PAST-
LET'S SEE THE FOURTEENTH PROVIDE
PLEASE PROVIDE THE BEST THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FUND TO THE
CULTURAL DISTRICTS SO THEY CAN
OPERATE EFFECTIVELY SUSTAINABLY.
AND EQUITABLY TO DO THE
IMPORTANT WORK THEY WERE
ESTABLISHED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATOR TO DO. THANK
YOU. REPORTER FIND. ONE OH FOUR
ONE OH FOUR. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS JIM LINDBERG CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA-
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTEEN
I'M CALLING ON ISSUE FIFTEEN
REGARDING THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY. BOB WE
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO CREATE A CHIEF
EQUITY OFFICER. HOWEVER CREATING
EQUITABLE HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES
WILL REQUIRE A LONG TERM
STRATEGY. THAT CUTS ACROSS ALL
STATE AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS.
THEREFORE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOCATE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CREATION
OF THE OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO A NINE ONE ONE
SEVEN BASEBALL HAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS LIZA CUTER AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING GROWTH FUNDING
ABOUT THE CITY CULTURAL DISTRICT
AND TRUCKEE CULTURAL DISTRICT
HOTNESS. THE REQUESTED OFFERED
SUPPORT TO COMPANIES BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR THE R. INCLUDING
THIRTY MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SUPPORT AND EXPAND
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS PROGRAM. ARE OUTLINED
IN A FIGHT TO THE H. OF TODAY'S
AGENDA. TOP OF THE PROGRAM'S
SUCCESS IS THAT IT REQUIRES A
HOTTER **** BETWEEN UNITS OF
GOVERNMENT BUSINESS ACTED ON THE
CREATIVE SECTOR. PROVIDES A
HIGHLY ACCOUNTABLE PUBLIC
PRIVATE INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
RESPONSE TO A BROADER RANGE OF
OPPORTUNITIES MUCH FUNDING
INNOVATION AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
A FRAMEWORK EQUITY. OUR STATE OF
THE NATION'S OF HELP THE
SUNLIGHT FROM SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WE HAVE
WHAT ONCE WAS BARELY RECOGNITION
FOR INDIGENOUS PEOPLE THE NEXT
NINE. ONE OF THE MOST IN. AND
DANGEROUS PRICING CALIFORNIA NOW
HOW THE DOWNTOWN LOCATION A
GALLERY IN THE HEART OF ONE OF
OUR BUSINESS DISTRICT. WELL WHAT
CHAU TRIBE IS THE FOCUS OF THE
LARGEST CREATIVE PLACEMAKING
INITIATIVES ARE COUNTY HAS SEEN
. SUPPORTING OUR INTANGIBLE
CULTURAL HERITAGE IS VITAL I'M
NOT STATE OF THE NATION OF
CALIFORNIA COLLEAGUES WRAP UP
YOUR COMMENTS ALL THE- SUPPORT
HERITAGE THAT FORMS THE VERY
MAKE UP OF OUR REGION I'M NOT
LEAST VISIBLE COMMUNITIES. WITH
INVESTMENT THESE HISTORY AND OUR
HERITAGE WILL BECOME LESS
INTANGIBLE I'M MORE A CRITICAL
PART OF OUR EVERY DAY LIFE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN QUEUE FOR
COMMON QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OPERATOR I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS THAT WERE
PART OF OUR- OUR HEARING TODAY
IN BUT IT'S A FOR AS WELL AS
ARE. VERY DEDICATED BUDGET STAFF
THANK YOU SO MUCH- HEARING IS
ADJOURNED. THANKS.